ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
BASS COVERING GUIDELINE. AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
WE'RE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH SOME OF OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
TODAY WE HAVE A FEW MEMBERS
SENATORS CORTESE DOLLY MEN-
WITH US REMOTELY WELCOME. WE
ALSO HAVE WITNESSES WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK AND I ASK
THAT EVERYONE. EVERY TIME YOU
WISH TO BE RECOGNIZE THAT YOU
USED TO RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE
IN THE PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP
UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO AND MUTE
PRESELECTED MU BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING R. I. T. PERSONNEL
WILL PUT YOU BACK IN THE QUEUE.
A BACK ON MUTE I'M SORRY WHEN
YOU WERE DONE ONCE RECOGNIZED
TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU
CAN BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE
YOUR NAME. AND THEN YOU ARE
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE
HAVE ADMITTED MY OF THE- TO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I'LL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR.
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN
THREE SIX TWO EIGHT THREE ONE.
FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON
HO THE TELECONFERENCES TO
WORKS. PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE AND OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
FOR TODAY'S HEARING WILL BE
HEARING FROM ALL THE PANELS OF
WITNESSES ON THE AGENDA. PRIOR
TO TAKING ANY PUBLIC COMMENT.
MONTHS WE'VE HEARD ALL THE
WITNESSES WE WILL HAVE A PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD FOR THOSE WHO
WISH TO COMMENT ON THE TOPIC OF
TODAY'S AGENDA. IS THE NOTE
THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR
YOU CLEARLY AND TO BOOT AVOID
ACOUSTIC FOR FEEDBACK. PLEASE
MUTE THE DEVICEYOU'RE
WATCHING. THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM AS WELL DURING THIS
YEAR THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY. AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE HEARING
MEETING SERVICE. WELL EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS.
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS AND IS
BECAUSE OF THE MATTER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING. TO THE USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES.
NOW THAT WE FINISHED WITH OUR
ANNOUNCEMENTS CAN BEGIN THE
HEARING. I'D LIKE TO WELCOME
EVERYONE AND ALL MEMBERS AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
PARTICIPATING. MAKING OUR
TRANSPORTATION SUSTAINABLE IS A
MAJOR ENVIRONMENTAL CHALLENGE.
AND WE'VE BEEN CHIPPING AWAY AT
IT FOR SOME TIME. WELL THERE
ARE MANY WAYS TO REDUCE OUR
TRANSPORTATION. GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS THIS HEARING WILL BE
FOCUSED ON ARTS ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE STRATEGY IN CALIFORNIA.
WE'VE HAD MANY GOALS FOR.
GETTING STEPS ON THE ROAD OUR
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN PRETTY
SUCCESSFUL. WE'VE CLEARLY GOT
SO MUCH MORE TO DO. AND I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
THE DISCUSSION PROGRESS THAT WE
NEED TO MAKE TO REACH OUR
GOALS. I'M PARTICULARLY
INTERESTED IN UNDERSTANDING OUR
STRATEGY. AND WHAT THE
LEGISLATOR BLEACHER NEEDS TO DO
TO HELP. NOW I WOULD LIKE TO
WELCOME OUR CO CHAIR SENATOR
AKOWSKI. FROM BUDGET SUB TWO.
AND I'D LIKE TO. ASK IF HE HAS
ANY OPENING REMARKS. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND I HAD. YOUR
WORK IN YOUR IN. IN THIS AREA
YOU TO YOUR STAFF. GOT FOR
PULLING THIS. HUG HEARING TO GO.
AS WE ALL HOME WE FOR IT OVER
AND OVER AND- IN TALKING BY THE
TRANSFER. ACCOUNTS FOR FORTY OF
THE- GREENHOUSE IN THE
INCREASING THE HERE. EMISSION
VEHICLES OBVIOUSLY SCREWED TO
RE THAT NUMBER BUT- OUR FOCUS
IN FOCUS OF THE BUT SUB TO IS
HOW CAN WE THAT HAVE. WE'VE
SPENT LOTS OF MONEY. ON DESERVE
AND RE YEARS. BUT WE'RE STILL
ALL WAY. FROM ARTICLE ARE. IN
THE WHITE PAPER THAT PREPARE
AND A FOR THE- PAST SPENDING
HAS BEEN. ACROSS MULTIPLE
PROGRAMS WITH LITTLE
COORDINATION BETWEEN THEM AND
NOW WE HAVE ANOTHER SERIES OF
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT WE WANT TO
DO SO ALL OF THIS RAISES THE
QUESTION. AND I THROW THIS OUT
TO GO PEE IS ED THE NATURAL
RESOURCES. OF THE LISTENING
CAREFULLY WHAT IS THE STRATEGY.
HOW ARE WE GOING TO FOCUS OUR
EFFORTS AND PUT THE RESOURCES
OF THE STATE TO BUILD ON THE
SUCCESSES THAT WE HAVE ON THE
PAST. BUT HELP REACH THESE
GOALS I DON'T WANT GIMMICK I
DON'T WANT JINGOISM I DON'T
WANT A LOT OF NOISE ABOUT
EMPOWER MEN. OR HOW WE'RE GOOD
OR- RESPOND THE MALL. I WANT
I'M A NUTS AND BOLTS TYPE OF
GUY SO CHU IS BE LOOK AT WHAT
ARE YOU DOING. TO THE NEEDLE
AND THE PRESS RELEASES. THE
MINISTRY SHOULD HAVE HIS LOFTY.
THERE'S AN IMPISH BUDGET PER
FOR THE YEAR BUT IT IS FUN TO
TODAY SUB. HELLO GOOD BILL ON
THESE PASS EFFORTS AND HOW. DO
ADMINISTRATION IS AT GIVEN THE
NEED. THEN THIS HEARING I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO. IT'S A FOR
AFTER I'M ALL YEAR. I WANT TO
GET A AND- OF WHAT THIS IS NOT
A- OVERALL. HOW WE CUORE YOU A
LOT OF. BUT HOW YOU CLEAR THAT.
AND HOW WE'RE ACT. IN FOR.
COULD MOVE THE NEEDLE AND MORE
A- AS- AND THEN PARTICULAR.
WHAT ELSE DO YOU WANT FOR THE
LEGIS. BECAUSE WE ARE PART. IN
THIS TO REACH THE GOALS. AND
THERE'S BEEN. A SERIES. OF
ADMINISTRATOR EXECUTIVE ORDERS
AND I'M REMINDED OF LYNDON
BAINES JOHNSON'S WATCHING
SOMETHING ON PUBLIC RADIO AND
HE SAID WHEN HE WAS CONSIDERING
THE CIVIL RIGHTS WORK IT'S JUST
PAPER. YOU KNOW WHETHER IT'S
GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER
GOVERNOR BROWN THE GOVERNOR
NEWSOM AN EXECUTIVE ORDER IS
JUST PAPER AND WE'RE WOEFULLY
BEHIND ON THE LOFTY GOALS THE
PEOPLE HAVE SAID SO. MANAGER I
AM DELIGHTED TO BE HERE TO BE
ALL EARS TO LISTEN TO WHAT. THE
NATURAL RESOURCES. THE HAS AND
AS WE AS THE GO IS AND HOW THIS
MOVES. CAN COME IN A COURT. AND
UNDER. PLAN BUT DON'T YOU THINK.
WELL I KNOW THAT WE GET TO DAYS.
AND TO. MAN ABSTRACTIONS TO
DON'T UNDER WHAT THE INCENTIVE
IS WE'RE WE'RE SO WITH THAT
LOOK FOR TO OUR FOR WITNESS
THANK YOU SENATOR RECOUNTS
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A GOOD MEET
I KNOW- AND WE ARE HAVE SAID
ARCHERS WHO IS HERE AT HE'S
ALSO SEE SENATOR STERN WHO IS
PART. WITH AS WELL WELCOME- SO
BEFORE WE BEGIN AGAIN WITH OUR
SPEAKERS I'D LIKE TO IT ONCE
AGAIN INVITE THE PUBLIC WOULD
LIKE TO PARTICIPATE TO CALL AND
NOW ONCE AGAIN THE TOLL FREE
NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR
WHEN PROMPTED PLEASE USE ACCESS
CODE SEVEN THREE SIX TWO EIGT
THREE ONE. NOW WE WILL HEAR
FROM OUR FIRST PANEL EACH
PANELIST WILL HAVE A FEW
MINUTES WE SHOULD CONCLUDE AT
THIS PANEL IN ABOUT THIRTY
MINUTES THE FIRST PERSON I ON
OUR DOCKET IS ROSS BROWN WITH
THE L. A. O. LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. WE WILL THEN
HAVE SIMON SIMON WEEK- AND
CHECK SHE LUCK WITH TO A
CONSULTING BUT FIRST WE'LL HEAR
FROM ROTH BROWN MISTER GO RIGHT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MISTER
SHE- I'M- AGAIN ROSS BROWN WITH
THE LETTER. PANEL OFFICE. NAY
HAVE A- RISK PRISON. TO SHARE
HERE JUST FEW SLOW. SO I'M
GOING TO. HOLD UP. HOPEFULLY
YOU CAN SEE THAT PLEASE LET ME
KNOW- IF YOU CAN'T SEE IT- BUT
I'M NOT TAKE MY TIME I KNOW YOU
ARE A FULL A HERE SOME DISCO
TAKE A FEW MINUTES AND MOST. I
JUST CRIED SOME BACK ON
INFORMATION AND CONTACT TO KIND
OF STOP THIS FOR A HEARING TO.
AND YOUR- I'M GOING TO SAY ARE
THESE ISSUES. SO I GOING TO
JUMP RIGHT AND. FOR SOME REASON
WE'RE THERE WE GO. GO TO THE-
FIGURE AND THIS IS REALLY A BIG
STEP BACK. TO BIG PICTURE.
HONEST GREENHOUSE GAS SCHOOL-
YOU CAN SEE- VOLUSIA AREA HERE
AS I. GREENHOUSE GAS IN. SINCE
TWO SO. AND THEN THE STATE'S. I
STARTED GREENHOUSE GAS ARE THE
TO TWENTY TRI IS THAT DOCUMENT
IN THE TWENTY THIRD TARGET ON
THE RIGHT. YOU CAN SEE ACTUAL
MISSION ARE THE CAR SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED TWO IS A-
AND WE'VE ACTUALLY. MY THESE
WHY GOALS YEARS EARLY SO THAT'S
ONE- KEEP. AND THAT'S A BIG.
BUT I THINK REALLY KIND OF THE
OTHER KEY POINTS FROM CHART. IF
YOU LOOK AT THE TWENTY THIRTY
TARGET- THAT GOAL IS MORE IN.
THAN TWENTY TWO TARGET.
ADJUSTING SHARE KIND OF GONNA
TURN IT'S- ABOUT ONE FOR.
ANNUAL RETURN NEED TO MEET THE
TWENTY TWO TARGET- THE ANNUAL.
NAY TO MEET THE THIRD TARGET
ARE CLOSE 24% SO THAT'S A BIG
DIFFERENCE IN TERMS OF-
AMBITION- THEN THE OTHER THING
I JUST WANNA HIGHLIGHT IN THIS.
IS THIS. ERROR HAS ACTUALLY
BEEN A SLIGHT UPTICK OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS OVERALL. SO
MOVING ON TO THE SECOND CHART
HERE AND THIS IS REALLY JUST
GOING TO GIVE THE CONTEXT OF
WHERE TRANSPORTATION FITS IN ON
BOTH GREENHOUSE GASES AS WELL
AS- OTHER POLLUTANTS FOUND A
CHART ON THE- CHART ON THE
RIGHT IS NITROUS OXIDES
CONTRIBUTORS TO. A SMOG AND
OZONE SO TRANSPORTATION AS
SENATOR WHITEHOUSE YOU
MENTIONED IS- 40% THOSE ARE THE
DARK BLUE SHADED PARTS OF THE
GREENHOUSE GAS CHART SO IT'S
ABOUT 40% OF GREENHOUSE GASES-
BUT ON THE NITROUS OXIDES ON
THE LOCAL AIR POLLUTION
TRANSPORTATION REFLECTS ABOUT
80% OF THE POLLUTANTS
CONTRIBUTING. TO- TO SMOG. SO-
BIG CHUNK OF BOTH BUT I
TRANSFERRED IT IS IT IS KIND OF
ANY BERMAN BIGGER OR OF LOCAL
AIR POLLUTION. I ONE OTHER
THING I DO WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT
THIS CHART- FOR THE GREENHOUSE
GAS. THE TRANSFER TRONG THE
PIECE OF THAT LIGHT DUTY
VEHICLES WHICH IS BIGGER THAN.
HEAVY DUTY OFF ROAD A MEDIUM
DUTY- BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
NITROUS I. ON THE- IT'S KIND OF
FOR AS AN OFF AND HAVE DUTY THE
ARE LARGER CHUNK OF THE
EMISSION FIGURE FROM DUTY BE SO.
TO SUPPORT KIND SOMETHING ABOUT
OF HOW YOU PRICE- AND ENTER
POLICY ARE BASED ON A CLINICAL
AS WELL LOCAL GOALS. THIS NEXT.
BUT I DO THINK IT IS IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT AND THOSE GIRLS
ARE STARTING EXECUTIVE ORDER
ORDERS AGAIN AS AS SENATOR WHAT
KASKY. MENTIONED THERE NOT A
STATUTORY GOALS- BUT THIS CHART
REALLY KIND OF- ZEROS IN ON THE
ONE OF THE MORE RECENT GOALS
ESTABLISHED BY THE GOVERNOR ON
LIGHT DUTY VEHICLE SALES AND
KINDA THIS HOPEFULLY GIVES YOU
A SENSE OF. THE SCALE OF THE-
OF THE TRANSITION IS NEEDED TO
MEET THAT GOAL WHICH IS A 100%
DOWN SALES FOR LIGHT DUTY
VEHICLES BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE.
YOU CAN SEE- THIS EXAMPLE CHART
FROM CARB- IN TWENTY TWENTY
WERE ATABOUT 80% OF LIGHT
DUTY. VEHICLE SALES ANNUAL
VEHICLE SALES ARE DESERVES AND
THIS IS THE KIND OF THE TYPE OF
TRANSITION THAT WILL NEED. TO
SEE- 100% ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
SALES BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE SO
IT'S A- IT'S. A BIG SHIFT THAT
THAT WILL BE NEEDED. AND THE
FINAL CHARGE- HERE BOTH I CAN-
OF WRAPPED UP IN- OFFER
DISTRICT OF BRIEF COMPANY. I
DON'T. THE WORD AT THE MISS.
YEAH I THINK NOT ON. SORRY MR
SHOULD I WORRY I'M GOING
SENATOR RUBIO. JUSTTRYING A
SHE BASICALLY SAID- RIGHT AHEAD
I THINK WE'VE- PERHAPS MUTED
THE PERSON OR- HAVE THAT
FIGURED OUT SO RIGHT WHEN YOU
GO AHEAD AND- OKAY GREAT
RECEIVE THANK YOU SO. LAST
CHART HERE NOT APOLOGIZE THIS
IS BIT OF A CHART WAS JUST
PULLED- WE DID A COUPLE OF AGO-
AND THE DIZZINESS MAYBE IS
PARTLY TO POINT IS KIND OF.
TRYING TO- SOME. THE STATE PRO
THAT WE HAVE THOSE THAT ARE
TRANSFER. EMISSIONS AND IN
PARTICULARLY. PROGRAMS THAT ARE
AIMED AT PROVIDING FINANCIAL
SUPPORT FOR- VEHICLES AND
FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE AND
INCENTIVES TO. TO PROMOTE
CLEANER- CLEANER VEHICLES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SO THIS IS
NOT- ZAB SPECIFIC THERE ARE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE ON THIS CHART
THAT INCLUDES- JUST KIND OF
VEHICLE REPLACEMENT AND
UPGRADES SO THEY'RE NOT
NECESSARILY AS I'M SPECIFIC BUT
I THINK. THE IDEA IS JUST GOING
TO GIVE YOU A SENSE FOR ALL THE
DIFFERENT STATE PROGRAMS THAT
WE HAVE THAT PROVIDE. FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES FOR VEHICLES AND
FEELING AFTER STRUCTURE IS ALSO
DOES NOT INCLUDE- THINGS THAT
ARE FOCUSED POLICIES ARE
FOCUSED ON VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED SO YOU KNOW TRANSIT
LATER ACTIVITIES FOR EXAMPLE
ARE NOT ON HERE- DOESN'T
INCLUDE- MANY REGULATORY
PROGRAMS AT THE STATE HOUSE AS
WELL- BUT I THINK YOU CAN KIND
OF SEE- THE LONG LIST OF
PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE ON THE
LEFT SIDE OF THE CHART HERE.
RANGING FROM THE LOW CARBON
FUEL STANDARD WHICH IS A
REGULATORY PROGRAM BUT IT
ESSENTIALLY GOING TO PROVIDE
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES FOR ZERO
EMISSION. VEHICLES WE HAVE A
VARIETY OF PROGRAMS AT THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD ON THE LIGHT
DUTY HEAVY DUTY AND EQUITY-
PROGRAM SIDE OF THINGS- RADIOS
AND YOU HEAR FROM A LOT OF THE-
THAT ARE. THESE PROGRAMS- LATER
IN THE YEAR. THE FINAL THING
WANT TO KIND OF HIGH IS NOT
CALL HERE WE HAVE TO FUNDING
SOURCES THAT SUPPORT ALL OF
THESE ARE PROGRAMS AT THE STATE
HAS RANGING FROM AGAIN LCS US-
CREDIT REVENUE WHICH IS A
REGULATORY PROGRAM DOESN'T. RUN
THROUGH THE. STATE BUDGET BUT
ALSO AS NO G. R. S. I'LL BE
RIGHT THERE FOR. LEGAL ON- AND-
REVENUE SOURCES. AND WHEN GOT
OUT ALL THE UP- IN RECENT YEARS
IT'S ROUGHLY BILLION DOLLARS
HAS GONE TO. ME FRANCE.
PROGRAMS AGAIN NOT ALL OF. A
SPECIFIC FOR IS A BUT JUST
GONNA GIVES YOU HOPE A- BIT OF
SENSE OF THE LANDSCAPE OF THE
Y. VARIETY OF PROGRAMS THE
STATE HOUSE NECESSARY- I DON'T.
PROBABLY GOING TO BRING UP
AGAINST MY TO HERE I DO JUST TO
HIGHLIGHT. A DISTRICT COUPLE OF
COMMON AND SHIP COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS THAT CAN AS YOU-
ENGAGING YOUR HEARING TO AND
I'M GOING. A COUPLE SEEK. THAT
WE CURRENT I THINK IT ONE OF-
JUST OF THE LEAD. ONE TO BE IN
A ZERO B. O. GOALS I MENTIONED
YOUR THE GOVERNOR. HOW HOW
WOULD IT LIKE TO BALANCE
REGULATORY PROGRAMS VERSUS
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS BOTH- CAN
HELP ACHIEVE A LOT OF THESE
GOALS AND HOW HEAVILY DOES THE
LEGISLATURE WANT TO FOCUS ON.
ON FINANCIAL INCENTIVES VERSUS
REGULATIONS AND HAVE IMPORTANT
IMPLICATIONS FOR WHO BEARS THE
COST OF MEETING SOME OF THESE
GOALS FOR EXAMPLE- AND THEN
FINALLY- AND ISSUE THAT COMES
UP AND HAS COME UP IN SOME OF
THE BUDGET DISCUSSIONS AND
THERE HAS BEEN A QUESTION FOR A
WHILE NOW IS. A FOUR ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE INCENTIVES HOW
MUCH EMPHASIS TO PLACE ON THE
VEHICLES- AND HOW MUCH OF PLACE
ON THE FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE-
AND THAT'S A- DIFFICULT
QUESTION IN THE MINISTRATION MY
DISCUSS IT'S- A PROPOSED BUDGET
FOR THIS YEAR- WHICH- PLACES
SOME OF AN EMPHASIS ON FUELING.
INFRASTRUCTURE AS PART OF THAT
DISCUSSION AND WE THINK THAT'S-
REASONABLE BUT THERE ARE
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS ABOUT
TENANTS YOU KNOW HOW. HOW THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD LIKE TO
EMPHASIZE VEHICLES AND FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE BOTH CAN BE
ATTRACTIVE WAYS TO PROMOTE
JOBS- BUT IF YOU HAVE LIMITED
FUNDING- HOW DO YOU KIND OF-
PRIORITIZE YOUR HOW MUCH
EMPHASIS DO YOU PLACE ON EACH
ONE OF THOSE GOALS. SO IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME I WILL WRAP UP
MY COMMENTS AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU KNOW.
THANK YOU MISTER BROWN AND
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO TAKE
QUESTIONS AFTER THIS PANEL- SO
NEXT WE HAVE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
SIMON WE- CLEAN VEHICLES AND
FUELS GROUP CLIMATE AND CLEAN
ENERGY PROGRAM- FROM THE
NATURAL. RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL. GO RIGHT AHEAD MISTER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
MISTER MEMBERS OF THAT THE
COMMISSION- SO I ASKED- AS AS.
ACTOR AND FOR NATURAL RESOURCES
COUNCIL REPRESENTS A BUNCH. AND
A LITTLE RESEARCH. THAT WE CAN
GET. WITH I SURE LOCK AND IN
ENSURE. AND ENTERTAINING
CONSULTING IS ALSO ON THE SCENE
MEETING. HELP ANSWER ADDITIONAL.
FACING WE LOOKED. HOW
INCENTIVES INTO THE WORLD OF
RENT. AND INFRASTRUCTURE AND
BASS AND REALLY AT A HIGH LEVEL
WHAT THE SCHOOLS. ACTUALLY FOR
THE STATE IN TERMS OUT THE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES. IN MY ACROSS
THE STATE- AS AS INTERNET. ON
CLEAN VEHICLES FUELS. I
GENERALLY THREE CAPITA A POLICY
THAT ARE UTILIZED BY. TO
REALLY- OVERCOME THE BARRIER TO
THE EMISSION. THESE INCLUDE
FIRST REGULATIONS LIKE THE ONES
WE HAVE HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
CLEAN CAR STANDARDS. REALLY ARE
FOCUSED ON INCREASING THE
SUPPLY AND AVAILABILITY AND
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGIES THROUGH
REQUIREMENTS ON MANUFACTURERS
REALLY PRODUCERS OF THE- SO
POLICIES REALLY FOCUS ON THIS
SIDE OF THE- THEN. YOU SORT OF
HAVE HALL AT A OF ON YOU THAT.
SUPPLY YOU'LL NEED. IN THE
INTEREST TO CHARGER TO REFUEL
THAT VEHICLES IT'S SORT OF LIKE
IF APPLE WERE THE VEHICLE. THE
I. CHARGE CELLULAR IN TOWERS
WOULD BE SORT OF INTEREST MAKE
EVERYTHING. FINE EVEN IF YOU'RE
THE FOR SHE TO THERE ARE REMAIN
BARRIER OF COURSE TO THE END.
OF THE CONSUMER LEVEL WHEN
FLEET LEVEL ZERO VEHICLES.
MANAGER HAVE YOU BOTH MOM. AND
NON INCENTIVE PROGRAM SIMILAR
THOSE THAT BEEN AND DONE INTO
AND ARE BEING DISCUSSED TODAY.
I JUST TAKE A STEP BACK ON WHY
EIGHT. SUBJECT LEADER IN ALL OF
THESE TYPES OF PRO. NOT ONLY A-
THE WILL FIFTH LARGEST AND HOT
WHICH GERMAN AND INDIA. BECAUSE
HEALTH STATE. ARE REALLY AND
PROGRAM ARE REALLY DONE OR
CONSIDERED BY MY OF THE S. MORE-
YOUR- HERE CALVET CLEAN
STANDARDS WELL AS CHANGED
STANDARDS HAVE BEEN A JOB. OR
BEING CAN. I STATES ARE THE
COUNTRY RIGHT. OVER FORTY PER
OF THE MAR. SO STATE ACROSS THE
AS WELL AS JURY. AND YOU'RE NOT
INCLUDING AND EUROPE ARE
LOOKING AT YOUR CHILD'S. FOR
THE POLICY LEADERSHIP SOLUTIONS
REALLY TACKLE AIR POLLUTION AND
CLIMATE CHANGE AND REALLY HOW
TO MAKE SMARTER INVESTMENTS. IN
CENTERPOINT. SEVERAL WHY ARE WE
EVEN TALKING ABOUT IN. AND
TODAY I'M HERE A GREAT. YES ONE
OF MAJOR- TODAY IS AN INCOME
COSTS PRETTY BASED BY CAN. WERE
LOW TO AND EMISSION VEHICLES.
SUCH AS A LIFE CARS CHAU HERE-
BUT GOOD NEWS IS THAT THIS.
THAT SHALL. ARE AROUND COST
KNOWLEDGE. BOTH ON THE
PASSENGER MARKET AS WELL AS FOR
MEDIUM HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS. THE
CULTURE COME DOWN RIGHT. AND
THIS EXAMPLE HERE SHE THAT I
THINK SHOULD RED DOT IN COST OF
BATTERY. AND A CON US. IN
SEPARATE ACTION STARTING TO
GIVE ME. THE INITIAL PRICE
PREMIUM IS FALLING PURSES AND
GAS. INTERNAL ENGINE VEHICLE
BASED YOU SEEN NOW- DOWN O
ZERO. OUT WITHIN THE TWENTY TWO
FIVE TO TWENTY THIRTY TIMES
RIGHT. TAKE HERE IS THAT YOU
DON'T NEED VEHICLE ONE'S. I'M
NOT TO CONTINUE FOR AT. BUT
REALLY YOU JUNE THEM EARLY. YOU
ADDRESS THE CAN VALUES RIGHT
YOU THE POINT IN THE ORDER. FOR
CAL YOU NEED I AMBITIONS CHARGE
A BEST THIRTY YEAR OLD WHETHER
BE GOVERNOR'S. ORDER AFTER THAT
HAPPENS. I'LL WILL BECOME
BECAUSE CONTROL ON THE OWN. SO
WHAT I'M SURE CONSULTING DID
REALLY IS TO FOR THIS HEARING
IS A LOOK AT IF YOU OF THOSE.
UP FRONT. ON INDIA BASED.
ACROSS ENTIRE FLEET. THAT YOU
TO GET THAT EIGHT MILLION STAFF
BY. TWENTY NOT JUST PASSENGER
VEHICLE CARS AND BUT ALSO THE
BIG BIG RIGS YOU KNOW THE
MEDIUM AND HAVE DUTY AS WELL.
AND THROW IN THE INTEREST BASS.
IN TO ENABLE SUCCESS. AT A
REALLY HIGH LEVEL THE FRONT. OF
THAT TOTAL. BROUGH TWENTY THIRD
WELL TO BE ABOUT FORTY SIX.
ANNUALLY THAT WOULD BE NEEDED
IN OF. SIDE IN I DIDN'T ASK
RATHER CONSIDER WITH WEEDS AS
WELL AS- IN- LOOK LIKE PRETTY
LARGE NUMBERS BUT YOU'RE JUST
QUIT THE IN YOUR- WE SPEND
ROUGHLY A HIGH. INSTEAD FIVE
BILLION AND- IN CAL TO PURCHASE
NEW. VEHICLEAND USED VEHICLES.
REGISTER AND CAR CARD SURE. TO
ALLOW THOSE. ANNUAL NUMBERS
AREN'T INSIGNIA. REALLY THESE
TRANSITION COSTS REALLY MORE.
IN COMPARE AND TO WHAT WE'RE
CHANGE. SO HE'S KIND OF THE
COST OF TRANSITION. NOW I
SHOWING. THE OTHER SIDE THE-
OUR SYSTEM IT WHAT ARE THE BEST.
IN TERMS OF THOSE. COSTS RIGHT
WHAT ARE THE- FROM WHICH- HIS
GOAL. AND COMPARING JUST HOW
THEY STACK UP. AND HERE I ADDED
THE BETTER. ON THE NAY SIDE IN
CHINA TERMS OF. FOR SO WHILE
AND IT. EARLY OR IS THE NEXT
COST FOR THE STREET. OVER TIME.
AS YOU. START YOUR EAGLES.
LARGELY BY FOR SAY BUT- AS WELL
AS NEW. HEALTH BENEFITS.
AVOIDED MORE. AWARDED MORE IT
FROM. SOCIAL CONSTANT- THOSE
BENEFITS THAT THAT DOES START
TO BREAK X. THE COST OF THE
TRAIN. ITSELF AND I'LL JUST FLY
IN THIS TO AND WE ONLY HAVE
TIME TO AT. FROM ACTUALLY ARE
UP PARTICULAR MATTER AND NOT.
WHICH IS SMART. IN AS- WHAT WAS.
EIGHT ALL THE WAY THROUGH
TWENTY FIFTEEN ONE OF THOSE
COST LOOKS LIKE ONE OF THOSE.
YOU'LL SAVINGS AND THIS IS JUST
A WATERFALL CHART THAT SHOWS
ARE MOVING FROM THE LEFT TO THE
RIGHT THE- TRANSITION COSTS IN
TERMS OF THE VEHICLE ADDITIONAL
VEHICLE CONSTITUTIONAL MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTY THE ACOSTA
INFRASTRUCTURE COSTS. BUT THEN
WHEN SEE IS FOR SAVINGS JUST
THOSE. IN TERMS OF SAVING RIGHT.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE HEALTH
OF NOT VERY NARROWLY JUST
HEALTH. IT DOESN'T ALL OF
LEARNS. AS WELL AS CLASS OF
CARBON NO TWO BY THEMSELVES
HELP. INVEST THERE IS FROM THE
SURE AND- THAT WE OVER EIGHT
BILLION IN SAVING ACCOUNTS.
NEARLY AS TWO BENEFIT CONCERT.
AND SO WE CAN ALL OF THIS. WE
NEED TO START BACK A LITTLE
INTO OF. I DOES TRANSITION CALL.
EVERYONE I'VE DONE HERE IS
STAFF UP- THE TRANSITION SHE
EARLY. FORTY SIX THE YEAR AND
COMPARED. TO THE DIRECT IN
CENTER- ARE TAKEN FROM ROSS IS
CABLE BUT IT'S- THANK LIKE
CALCIUM CASSON AND FOCUSING
MORE ON THE- INCENTIVES. ARE
ALL SEASON AND SETTLE- BANK
INTEREST AND YOU KNOW. WHAT
INCENTIVES REPRESENT ABOUT
THEIR PER OF THE OF THE- FOR
THE VIEW INCENTIVE. SHOWN THE
SEVEN JENNIFER DOWN BOTTOM OF
STRESS INCENTIVE JOHN. HI
NICHOLS. IN ORDER TO CAPTURE
THIS ENORMOUS BENEFITS I SHOWED.
ME THE PRO SUPPORTED BY
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS OR-
AND- PRESSURE. ARE TERMS OF
PROBATION AND THEY'RE NOT GOING
TO AS SO I JUST SORT SUGAR. AND
POTENTIAL GEEK OUR IN TWO
TWENTY THREE ASSUMING PRO.
DON'T GET X. SO AS AB EIGHT
RICH ARM OR THE SMOG YOU KNOW.
OUT OF THIS MONTH. AT AND SHOW
THAT DECLINE OVER TRY. AS AND
SEND PROGRAMS GET YOUR OUT-
SUBJECT. IS SET TO AND- ANOTHER
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY NO FOR YEAR
DESPITE THESE WERE CRITICAL.
AIR POLLUTION AND CLIMATE- IN
TERMS OF THE INTEREST QUESTION
I CAN ASK EARLIER INTEREST ME
NOT AS YOU GO FORWARD. THE
VEHICLE AND IN A LAST LESS THAT
TOTAL TRANSIT COSTS.
INFRASTRUCTURE CAN. THAT ALLOW
TO BROWN UP AND THAT'S IT'S
IMPORTANT TO. THINK OF. HOW
THESE TRAINS HAPPEN IN WHAT
FRAME. OUT WHILE WE WERE TO
COME AND SALES WHERE. NEAR
DEATH HOUSE MONTH THE FIFTY AND
UP WITH THE DEMAND FOR TRY A-
IN TERMS OF ENGINE. TO FOR
STABBING THIS. MICHAEL AND
CHECK ARE WELL AHEAD OF ON THIS.
AND CAL WHAT LACKING THERE AS
YOU TRAIN. PRO. SAMPLES ARE NOT
THE LONG TERM BENEFITS STOLEN
DOING SUCH WELL EXCEED THE COST-
THERE'S KIND OF A INTERPLAY
BETWEEN THE VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE COST INCENTIVES-
ACTUALLY DECLINING OVER TIME
WHILE CONTINUED CAPITAL
INVESTMENT IN INFRASTRUCTURE
REMAINS- THE ROLE OF ALL THREE
POLICIES IS QUITE CLEAR IN A
LOT OF THE WORK NOT JUST IN
CALIFORNIA BUT ACROSS
JURISDICTIONS. I THINK WE HAVE
TO ULTIMATELY BRING THIS BACK
DOWN HERE. HOW EQUITY JOBS AND
EACH THESE ARE THE BENEFITS
RIGHT FROM THIS TRANSITION OR
NOT JUST DURING THIS TRANSITION
ON BUT ACTUALLY THERE IS A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY HERE TO
IMPROVE PUBLIC HEALTH. LIVER
MORE EQUITABLE TRANSPORTATION
OUTCOMES IN AND OUTSIDE OF JOBS
LOWER TRYING TO GET RESTITUTION.
THANK YOU I'M HERE AS WELL
STRUCK TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. DEPUTY
DIRECTOR LEE AND CHUCK DID YOU
WANT TO GO HEAD AND I WE HAVE
CHECK SHE LOCK AS WELL-
PRESIDENT OF JULY CONSULTING
I'M NOT SURE IF YOU WANTED TO
ADD ANYTHING BEFORE WE GET TO
QUESTIONS. OKAY YEAH I THINK
HE'S- I THINK I DELIVERED DAHLE
MUCH OF THE FINDINGS FROM THIS
REPORT ANYTIME TO. OFFER ANY
QUESTIONS OKAY GREAT THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THAT. ALL RIGHT- SO
WE'VE CONCLUDED THE FIRST PANEL
THANK YOU SO MUCH JOHN AMEND
AND WE'LL GO TO MEMBERS FOR ANY
QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME AND
SENATOR WHAT KASKY HAS A
QUESTION START WITH HIM. FIVE
IF I THINK I'M- READING THE-
THE REPORT CORRECT WE'RE SAYING
THAT. VEHICLE SUBSIDIES PERHAPS
BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WE'RE NOT
GOING TO NEED TO DO ANY
SUBSIDIES BECAUSE THE THAT
AMOUNT IS GOING TO BE ABLE TO
THE COMPETITIVE WITH CAST TO
THE QUESTION WOULD BE. WHAT
THIS IS SUBSIDY LOOK FORM
FISCAL TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO IN
FOR THE NEXT FOUR YEARS TO
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WE'VE SORT
OF USED TO TARGET OF TWO
HUNDRED- MILLION I UNDERSTAND
THAT. RECEIVE THE RP IS GONNA
RUN OUT OF MONEY IN ABOUT THREE
WEEKS- HOW DO WE- BRIDGE THAT
LONG TERM GOAL VERSUS- A YEAR
YEAR. UN ALLOCATION CANNOT
INPUT KNOWING THAT TO GET THE
LATEST VERSION HAS ZERO FUNDS
IN THERE NOW. AND DINNER
CORRECT GO RIGHT AHEAD AND JUMP
IN AND ROSS IF YOU WANNA FOLLOW
UP LIKE I THINK THAT THE-
QUESTION IS WE REALLY SPOT ON
AND THAT- THERE'S OBVIOUSLY A
AGE GAP IN IN TERMS OF. WHAT'S
AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW IN TERMS
THAT ZERO AMOUNT I THINK THERE
ARE WAYS TO OBVIOUSLY IMPROVE
THE WAY THE VEHICLE INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS PARTICULARLY IN THE
LIGHT DUTY- RAMP. UP AND-
GETTING EQUITY AS WELL AS LOWER
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS WE COULD DO A
BETTER JOB THERE BUT ULTIMATELY
I THINK BECAUSE OF THE SCALE
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. THAT
WERE REALLY- NOT ALLOWABLE
RIGHT THAT WE PROBABLY NEED TO
BE IN TERMS OUT ENCOURAGING
CONSUMERS TO ADOPT THESE
TECHNOLOGIES AND MAKING ACCESS
AVAILABLE TO ALL CALIFORNIANS
INCEPTION I THINK TWO HUNDRED
MILLION AS A STARTING POINT OF
COURSE- BUT REALLY THE QUESTION
AROUND. CONTINUITY IS A KEY ONE
RIGHT- WHETHER THESE CONSUMERS
KNOW ABOUT THESE PROGRAMS AND
IT TAKES YEARS TO EDUCATE
CONSUMERS BUT IT EVAPORATES ONE
YEAR AND THEN STARTS UP
ANOTHER. DOWN. THE ROAD YOU
KNOW THOSE ARE. NO WAS ALSO THE-
OF THE- THOSE TYPES OF STARTS.
I GUESS. DIçN OF MISTER BROWN
OR DOCTOR BROWN WANTS TO SAY
ANYTHING- YEAH I'LL JUST MAYBE
JUST ADD TO- ONE BRIEF
COMMENTS- YOU JUST WANT MORE OF
THAT KIND OF CONSIDERATION WHEN
THINKING ABOUT THE OVERALL
MAGNITUDE OF FUNDING NEEDED TO
KIND OF GET TO SOME OF THE
GOALS THAT HAVE BEEN LAID OUT
AND- I THINK IT'S JUST AROUND
KIND OF SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
AND KNOWING KIND OF WHAT LEVEL
OF INCENTIVES NEEDED TO
ENCOURAGE- YOU KNOW CONSUMER
ADOPTION I THINK THEY'RE YOU
KNOW THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
DIFFERENCE. CHARACTERISTICS
THAT CONSUMERS VALUE AND THEIR
VEHICLES A LOT OF DIFFERENT
FACTORS THAT THEY TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THINK. YOU KNOW SYSTEMS
A NICE JOB OF KIND OF
IDENTIFYING THE- THE GAP
BETWEEN KIND OF PURCHASE PRICE
AND- SAYS VERSUS OTHER
VEHICLES- BUT SOMETIMES I THINK
IT'S IT CAN BE A LITTLE BIT
MORE CHALLENGING TO KNOW KIND
OF EXACTLY WHAT LEVEL DOES THE
INCIDENT NEED TO BE EXACTLY NOT
AMOUNTS DOESN'T NEED TO BE A
LITTLE BIT LESS DOESN'T NEED TO
BE MORE IN ORDER TO KIND OF
ACTUALLY. CHANGE CONSUMER
BEHAVIOR SO I THINK THAT'S KIND
OF ONE OF THE OPEN QUESTIONS
THAT MAKES ME OF THIS- YOU KNOW
THE QUESTION THAT YOU ASKED-
SOMEWHAT DIFFICULT TO. ANSWER
AND SO MAYBE AN AREA FOR KIND
OF SIZE AND FUTURE EXPLORATION
AND RESEARCH FOR EXAMPLE IT
SORT OF BEGS THE QUESTION WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE I GUESS THE-
HEAD OUT THAT WE HAVE IS IF YOU
THINKING THAT. THE INCENTIVE
PROGRAM TO CHANGE PEOPLE'S
BEHAVIOURS BASICALLY TO TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE YOU GOT FOUR YEARS-
AND THEN THERE'S A SWEET SIXTY
EIGHT MONTHS TO GET A REBATE
THERE'S CLEARLY SOME REFORM
THAT YOU WOULD PUT MONEY ON THE
HOOD AND SAY IT'S NOT A REBATE
YOU GET THE MONEY. OFF YOUR
TAXES ARE OFF YOUR DMV
SOMETHING SIMPLE THE PEOPLE
HAVE BUT ALSO FRONT LOADED FOR
FOUR YEARS AND SAYING THIS IS
IT IT'S A BILLION BUCKS AND
FIRST COME FIRST SERVE YOU YOU
GET YOUR MONEY I DO HAVE A
QUESTION ON INFRASTRUCTURE
BECAUSE WE GO. THE PRESIDENT'S
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL TALKS ABOUT
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION IN PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT NOT NOT
APARTMENT BUILDINGS NOT MY
BACKYARD- IN IF I DO THE MATH
RIGHT NOW 12% OF THAT WOULD BE
SIXTY TWO MILLION BUCKS FOR
CALIFORNIA SORT OF. A NICE
NUMBER- THE GOV SCOTT OF.
DOLLAR THERE. BUT DEPUTY SIGN
HERE TALKING. FOUR TO SIX
BILLION OVER A NINE YEAR PERIOD
AND SO LET'S SAY WE'RE A TWO WE
GET TO SIXTY TWO WERE HORT OF
THE FOUR BILLION OR MAYBE WE
MAKE THE TWENTY TWENTY TWO
GOALS BUT THE REST OF THE
TRAJECTORY DOESN'T SHOW AT
LEAST THE INVESTMENT. IS MY
MATH RIGHT IS THIS IS THIS IS
THIS GOING TO OUR ARE WE
MEETING OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS FOR THE YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY TWO IF WE GET IT WE SENT
A BILLION BUCKS WE TAKE THE
MONEY FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. IT'S A IT'S A GREAT
QUESTION- YOU KNOW IT'S REALLY
GREAT NEWS THAT THE BINDING
RESTORATION HAS PROPOSED
INVESTMENTS IN THE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE. THINGS LIKE
DOMESTIC MANUFACTURING BILL
CERTAINLY COMPLEMENT RIGHT IF
IT PASSES THROUGH CONGRESS YOU
KNOW COMPLIMENTS CALIFORNIA
EFFORT. TO HELP REACH THIS
LARGE TRANSITION GAP ON I'M
SHOWING WE'RE SHOWING IN TERMS
OF INFRASTRUCTURE. COSTS IT
WON'T FILL THE ENTIRE NEED
DENTAL- I THINK THAT'S WHERE
THINGS LIKE EASY CHILE PROGRAMS
RIGHT COME INTO PLAY- PRIVATE
INVESTMENTS COME INTO PLAY SO
THAT'S TRANSITION COSTS I THINK
THE QUESTION IS. NOT HOW MUCH
OF TRANSITION COSTS ARE. BUT
REALLY. HOW MUCH SHOULD THE
PRIVATE. THE SURPRISE AND YOU
TAKE OUT ON HOW MUCH CONSUME
TAKE THAT ON. FIRST IS OUT
PUBLIC DOLLARS IN TERMS OF
PUBLIC. CHANGE AND- HOW LONG DO
WE NEED TO AS FAR AS IN IT'S
TRUE WHAT WE'RE SHOWING IS. YOU
KNOW OVER THE FIVE NEXT FIVE
SIX YEARS IS A BIG NEED BUT AND
WE KIND OF HAD A MAGICAL SPOT
LIKE WE'VE DONE WITH RENEWABLES
AND- WHERE THE INCENTIVES MAY.
JUST BASICALLY ARE. I THOUGHT
HE LAST NEEDED OVERTIME. OKAY
THANK YOU SENATOR MCCASKEY WILL
MOVE ON TO SENATOR DOLLY. GOOD
MORNING OR GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CAN'T.
MY QUESTION IS A ON THE
INFRASTRUCTURE SIDE OF IT
ACTUALLY I JUST LOOKED LAST
NIGHT TO. MAYBE PURCHASE A- IS
THAT VEHICLE- BUT IF THE
STRUCTURE FOR CHARGING WHAT
WOULD YOU WHAT WOULD IT SEEMS
LIKE TO ME THAT THAT'S ONE OF
THE BARRIERS THAT ARE HOLDING
BACK PEOPLE FROM PURCHASING I
LIKE MYSELF BECAUSE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE JUST REALLY NOT
AVAILABLE AND I WOULD HAVE TO
PUT IN A YOU KNOW PUT A
PERSONAL PRIDE. STATION
CHARGING STATION AMOUNT OF
RESIDENTS. CAN YOU EXPLAIN WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE GOING FORWARD
AND WHAT WHAT WHAT THE NEED IS
TO GET TO WHERE WE WANT FOR THE
OBJECTIVES TO. MEET THAT- LOFTY
GOALS WE HAVE. SO I CAN TAKE A
AN INITIAL STAB AT IT AND- I
THINK ACTUALLY THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL PROBABLY BE
ABLE TO SPEAK TO THIS ISSUE A
LOT MORE THE ENERGY COMMISSION
HAS DONE QUITE A BIT OF
ANALYSIS AROUND- INFRASTRUCTURE
AND KIND OF WHAT'S NEEDED TO
MEET THE STATE GOALS I THINK
JUST. A COUPLE OF NUMBERS MAYBE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION'S GOAL
IS TO MEET ITS TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE-
TARGETS TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND- CHARGERS THAT'S ON A
LEVEL TWO CHARGERS AS WELL AS-
DC FAST CHARGER SO THAT DOESN'T
INCLUDE THE KIND OF HOME
CHARGERS ARE ONES THAT ARE IN
KIND OF A SINGLE FAMILY HOMES
IT'S KIND OF MORE PUBLIC OR
SHARED PRIVATE. CHARGERS RIGHT
NOW I THINK WE'RE AT- CLOSE TO
SIXTY OR SEVENTY THOUSAND DON'T
QUOTE ME ON THAT EXACTLY BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF FUN UNITS IN
THE PIPELINE TO KIND OF BUILD
OUT THAT CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE OVER THE NEXT
FEW YEARS AND SO- THERE'S A AS
A GAP OF ABOUT SIXTY THOUSAND
CHARGERS AND I THINK THAT ARE
NEEDED TO KIND OF NEED THAT
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE GOAL AND
THAT'S KIND OF THE- ONE OF THE
MAIN FOCUSES OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S INFRASTRUCTURE
PROPOSAL THAT'S IN THE BUDGET
THIS YEAR AND THE BILLION
DOLLARS- AT LEAST A FEW HUNDRED
MILLION OF THAT WILL BE TIME
TO. TO MEET THAT IDENTIFY .COM
TO TWENTY TWENTY FIVE SO THAT'S
ONE PIECE I THINK WHEN YOU LOOK
FURTHER OUT OUT TO TWENTY
THIRTY AND SOME O THE MORE AN
AMBITIOUS GOALS KIND OF LONGER
TERM GOALS- I KNOW SOME OF THE
ENERGY COMMISSION ANALYSES
SIDES I SAID THAT TO KIND OF BE
ON TRACK TO MEET THE-
GOVERNOR'S MOST RECENT
EXECUTIVE ORDER GOALS- THE
STATE'S GONNA NEEDS- CLOSE TO
ONE AND A HALF MILLION CHARGERS
SO THAT'S YOU KNOW AN INCREASE
FROM TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
AND TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TO. ONE
AND A HALF MILLION AND TWENTY
THIRTY SO THAT'S A LARGE RAMP
UP AND I THINK YOU'RE PRESS
GETS TO SOME OF THE NUMBERS
THAT- SIMON TALKED ABOUT BEFORE
AND IN TERMS. OF KIND OF
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED AND I DO
JUST WANT TO KIND OF HIGHLIGHT
ANY OTHER POINT THAT YOU MAY AS
WELL AS- ONE OF THE BIG
QUESTIONS THINK IS. AND WHAT
THE STATE'S ROLE WILL NEED TO
BE AND- SUPPORTING NOT
INFRASTRUCTURE BUILD OUT HOW.
WILL BE COVERED BY. PRIVATE
ENTITIES- VERSUS KIND OF WHERE
WE'RE OR RULES FOR EACH OF THE
STATE WILL BE. OKAY THAT'S
HELPFUL. IF YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR DOLLY I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THERE ARE NO OTHER
QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS- I'M
SORRY SENATE SENATOR ARCHER
LETTER RIGHT IN FRONT OF ME I
APOLOGIZE GO RIGHT AHEAD. THANK
YOU VENTURE- I'D LIKE TO POINT
OUT TO THE- THE CO CHAIR OF FOR
THE BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE- YOU
RIGHT ON SENATOR WITH SOME OF
YOUR COMMENTS IN YOUR OPENING
REMARKS. THAT OPENED UP A LOT
OF QUESTIONS THAT- OBVIOUSLY
KEEP COMING UP AS AN EXAMPLE I
BRING- TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR
GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER AT THE
TIME ISSUED EXECUTIVE ORDER-
WELL FOR THE LAST. TWO DIGITS-
FOR TO DEVELOP A NETWORK OF
HYDROGEN FUELING STATIONS AND
IN CONVERSATION- TODAY WE'VE
NOT HEARD ABOUT HYDROGEN AND
HOW THAT IS- IT NECESSARY TO
PLAY IN THE GOLD OF THE FUTURE.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE BELIEVE IT OR NOT
IS AROUND THE CORNER WITH WITH-
WITH THE FACT THAT WE'VE GOT.
SO MUCH ON OUR PLATE. AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN I THINK- OUR GOAL WAS-
TWO HUNDRED HYDROGEN FUELING
STATIONS- AND TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND ELECTRIC FEUDING.
CHARGING STATIONS SO IF WE'RE
LOOKING TO COMBINE HYDROGEN AND
WITH IT AND I AM HOPING THAT WE
ARE WE'VE GT TO THINK ABOUT
THE INFRASTRUCTURE. BUT AS YOU
TALK ABOUT THE ELECTRIC FUELING
STATIONS- YOU HAVEN'T MENTIONED
ABOUT A PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
EDISON COMPANY IN A PARTNERSHIP
WITH SOME ELECTRIC COMPANIES.
IS THAT SOLELY GOING TO BE OUR
RESPONSIBILITIES STATE TO
ESTABLISH THESE VARIOUS FUELING
STATIONS AT LOCAL PARKS MARKETS
WHEREVER THEY MIGHT BE. AND
ALSO IT IS IT IT'S A IT'S A
NECESSARY I THINK FOR ALL OF US
RIGHT NOW TO UNDERSTAND. THAT
IF WE DON'T ADD HYDROGEN TO OUR
GOALS WE'RE GOING TO FALL
SHORT. AND I KNOW THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT- SMALL VEHICLES
PURSES LARGER TRUCKS AND SO ON
AND I THINK WE ALL KNOW THAT
THESE LARGE TRUCKS COMING OUT
OF- THE CHAIRMAN'S LOCATION AND
OUT OF THE PORT OF LONG BEACH.
CANNOT HANDLE A BATTERY RUN
HUGE HUGE EIGHTEEN WHEELER. BUT
MAYBE IN THE FUTURE. A EIGHTEEN
WHEELER CAN BE RUN ON HYDROGEN.
AND TOWARD LIKE YOUR THOUGHTS
ON THAT AND SHE HOW WEAK YOU
FEEL THAT HYDROGEN MIGHT BE
PART OF THIS ENTIRE- SUBJECT
HERE. THANK YOU SENATOR
ARCHULETA IN WHO FROM OUR PANEL
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE THAT
QUESTION. I CAN GET THIS I
THINK. THAT QUESTION ON. YES IT
SHOULD THE PRESENTATION DIDN'T
FOCUS ON ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES
WHICH INCLUDES PLUG IN
ELECTRICS AND SHE'LL SELL
VEHICLES WE DO SEE A ROLE TO
PLAY ON THE MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY TRUCK SIDE FOUR HUNDRED IN
FUEL CELL TRUCK DEPLOYMENT
ACTUALLY THE INFRASTRUCTURE
COST NUMBERS I SHOWED. INCLUDED
BOTH THE HYDROGEN AS WELL AS-
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE. YOU
KNOW I'M THE YOU KNOW HORSE IN
THE RIGHT NOW- THERE ARE WARM
MODELS ALECTRA PEOPLE'S BEING
DEPLOYED- FIFTY TO SIXTY RIGHT
NOW- NOT AS MANY AT FROM THE
HYDROGEN SIDE BUT I DO THINK.
IT IS WORTH. TAKING A CLOSER
LOOK AT WHETHER OR IN THE-
LATER YEARS TWENTY THIRTY
TWENTY FORTY WHETHER THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION I'M TWO HUNDRED
STATIONS TARGETED HOW HOW THAT.
IT WILL THAT BE SUFFICIENT
WILL- THEY BE WELL UTILIZED HOW
DO YOU PUT TOGETHER THE VEHICLE
AND FEELS TOGETHER IN TERMS OF
THE INVESTMENTS ON TO MAKE SURE
THAT EIGHT. FORTY NINE EXCEPT
AS A PRIOR- CENTER SAD. YOU
KNOW IF YOU'RE LOOKING TO BUY A
VEHICLE YOU REALLY NEED TO.
HAVE INSURANCE SAYS THAT YOU
KNOW THERE'S INFRASTRUCTURE NOT
JUST AT THE HOME OF PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE AND REALLY THAT
THE CHALLENGE HERE IS THAT
THOSE INTEREST AFTER HAAS
RIGHT. ET AL MAN YOU DIDN'T DIE
IN THE STRIP OF HIGHWAY RIGHT
IT WAS A COLLECTIVE DECISION
TO. TO CREATE A NETWORK RIGHT
WHETHER IT BE THAT THE
TELEPHONE POLES OF OLDER. AND
THE CELL NETWORKS AND HIGHWAYS-
ALL OF THAT NEEDS TO BE SORT OF
THAT PUBLIC INVESTMENT A GOOD
COMPONENT. IT NEEDS TO BE A
PUBLIC BUS. I'D LIKE TO FOUR
AND OUT THAT BEARD MICHAEL IS
TO PAY. OF ELECTRIC VERSUS. BY
TO MAKE IT A- IN OUR GOAL- FOR
OUR ECONOMY AND NOT ONLY ARE
ARE- ENVIRONMENT AND SO ON BUT
I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT NINE BY
TWO TO DO THIS PRESENT MADAM
CHAIR I'D LIKE TO. INVITE YOU
DO THIS WITH IS WELL CAL STATE
LA. RIGHT OUTSIDE MY DISTRICT.
THE ENTIRE FLEET OF CAL STATE
ARE LAKE VIDEO BECAUSE OUR RUN
ON HYDROGEN THEY HAVE A
HYDROGEN FUELING STATION. LOOKS
LIKE A MINI GAS STATION. AND
THEY RUN ALL THEIR POLICE
VEHICLES SCHOOL VEHICLES AND I
BELIEVE THEY HAVE SOMEWHERE
ABOUT TO TWENTY EIGHT TO THIRTY
VEHICLES. AND PRETTY EFFICIENT
AND IT'S OPEN TO THE PUBLIC AS
WELL SO I THINK WE NEED TO TAKE
A LOOK AT THAT- BECAUSE I THINK
I HEARD SOMEONE MENTION THEY
HAD TO. INSTALL THE- THE
ELECTRIC- HOOK UP AT THEIR
HOME- WELL IF THE HYDROGEN IT
IS THERE IN A PUBLIC LOCATION
AT GAS STATIONS AS THERE IS ONE
HERE IN SACRAMENTO. THEN WE
HAVE A LEG UP. ON
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT WE NEEDED TO
PUT THAT ON THE LINE AND- AND
MAKE IT PART OF OUR FUTURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
ARCHULETA AND I HAVE A QUESTION
AND I THINK ALL DIRECT THIS TO
DEPUTY DIRECTOR ME AS WELL-
YOU'D MENTIONED AND THE- BAD TO
SAY THAT YOU HAD SUGGESTED THAT
WE- SEE THAT CALIFORNIA WAS
LAST FOR CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE AS WE'VE-
MENTIONED THAT. AND NUMEROUS
TIMES. AND SPECIFICALLY YOU
CALL THAT THE MULTI DWELLING
UNIT- UP PROGRAMS WOULD BE A
GOOD START SO. SINCE WE'RE SO
BEHIND AND I KNOW THAT THERE
HAS BEEN SOME- PIECES OF
LEGISLATION THAT OF REDUCE
BARRIERS TO ENTRY FOR MULTI
DWELLING UNIT. OF PROPERTIES
BUT WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS
AROUND- THAT AND HOW WE CAN
ACCELERATE THAT AND ESPECIALLY
YOU KNOW. THE WAY I LOOK AT IT
IS IN SPACES LIKE LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES IT TRULY REALLY
NEED THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE
INVESTMENTS THERE. YEAH YEAH
IT'S AN IMPORTANT QUESTION IN
THE DEPLOYMENT TO ENSURE ACCESS
RIGHT IN TERMS OF HOW WE DEPLOY
INFRASTRUCTURE ENERGY C. IS
PART OF THE- A GROUP OF
COALITION OF GROUPS INCLUDING-
GREEN LINING AND COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR- ADVOCATING RIGHT NOW
OR- INVESTMENTS YOU JOINED
ASPIN INSPITE- TO COMMISSION
AND AS WELL AS AT THE PUCT. TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS EQUITY
TARGETS THAT ARE ARE FAILED IN
TERMS OF DEPLOYMENT A LOT OF
THOSE INVESTMENTS TODAY- ARE
ARE BEING STARTING TO BE
TARGETED IS JUST A START THOUGH
AND WE REALLY WANT TO SEE THOSE
MULTI UNIT DWELLINGS ARE
CRITICAL IN PLACES WHERE YOU
REALLY. YOU KNOW THE TENANT
DOESN'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO
TELL A LANDLORD NOW SHALL PUT
IN INFRASTRUCTURE HERE BECAUSE
OTHERWISE I CAN'T GET A VEHICLE
SO THERE NEEDS TO BE SIGNED. UP
I REALLY HI SO ON ON MULTI UNIT
DWELLING. HOW DO I REALLY GET
LANDLORDS HOW TO INCENTIVIZE
THEM HOW DO YOU CREATE-
BUILDING CODES AND REQUIREMENTS
SUCH THAT. WE MAKE SURE THAT
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES I AND
MODERATE INCOME COMMUNITIES ARE
REALLY FIRST IN LINE RATHER
THAN GETTING LIKE A TECHNOLOGY
ACCESS LATER DOWN THE- AND JUST
AS A FOLLOW UP TO THAT THE
SINCE WE ARE LAST IN TERMS OF
BUT COMPARED TO OTHER STATES
ARE THERE. OTHER STATES THAT
ARE DOING THIS I OBVIOUSLY
THEY'RE DOING THIS MUCH BETTER
THAN WE ARE BUT ANY- EXAMPLES
IN OTHER STATES THAT WE CAN.
SORT OF LEAN ON. IT IN IN THIS
MULTI DWELLING UNITS BASED.
YEAH I AND I DON'T WANT TO
DISCOUNT CALIFORNIA'S
LEADERSHIP WHERE WE'RE LACKING
IS THAT THE INFRASTRUCTURE
RIGHT HASN'T CAUGHT UP TO OUR
EASY DEPLOYMENT WE JUST HAVE SO
MANY MUCH NEEDED APPOINTED
COMPARED TO OTHER STATES AND
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE IS
LACKING FROM THAT YOU KNOW IF
YOU JUST LOOK AT THE RATIO
BETWEEN THE TWO- I THINK
SURPRISINGLY THERE'S A LOT OF
GOOD STUFF HAPPENING- I NEW
YORK JETS DOT COM. ANNOUNCER
WILL BE INVESTING IN
INFRASTRUCTURE- WITH FOCUSING
ON ON MULTI UNIT DWELLINGS-
WE'VE WORKED IN OHIO. WHERE-
THE CITY OF COLUMBUS OHIO. AND
REALLY TRYING TO TACKLE THIS ON
YOU KNOW I'LL I'LL PUT A PLUG
IN FOR SAN DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC
THEIR WORK- WE- GET AT THIS
TENANT LANDLORD ISSUE- HAS BEEN
A- GREAT MODEL IN TERMS THAT
APPROPRIATE STEP CROUCH- THIS
MULTI UNIT DWELLING. BUT I
THINK THE GOAL HERE IS TO
REALLY ENSURING THE STATE'S
QASSIM TARGET. MAKE SURE THAT
THE- TARGETS INCLUDING THE
MULTI UNIT DWELLINGS AND THAT
WE ARE. YOU KNOW AT THE VERY
LEAST EQUALIZING THE PLAYING
FIELD TO GET INTO YOUR MACHINE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND YES THE
SAN DIEGO HAS PLUG IN SAN DIEGO
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH SANDAG
GREAT PROGRAM THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT I SEE NO OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS- SO ITH
THAT WE'RE GOING TO HEAR AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO OUR
FIRST PANELISTS FOR ALL OF YOUR
THOUGHTS- NEXT WE WILL MOVE ON
TO OUR SECOND PANEL WE'RE
FORTUNATE TO HAVE A VERY STRONG
PANEL POLICYMAKERS AND DECISION
MAKERS FROM THE ADMINISTRATION.
I THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE
WILL START FIRST WITH TYSON
ACKERLEY A DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE MARKET
DEVELOPMENT AT THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT WILL START WITH
YOU. AND WILL SAVE AGAIN ARE
QUESTIONS FOR AFTER THE PANEL
MEMBERS THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CAN
OKAY THANK YOU SORRY. I'VE HAD
SOME SOME SCREEN DIFFICULTIES
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THAT'S IT
IT'S BEEN MY NAME IS TYSON ACT
REALLY THANK YOU- CHAIR AND CO
CHAIR FOR SETTING THIS UP WE'RE
VERY EXCITED TO BE HERE TODAY
I'M TYSON ACTUALLY I THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR EXAM MARKET
DEVELOPMENT AT THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND- MY JOB IS
REALLY TO PULL ALL THE PIECES
TOGETHER- FOUR THREE THROUGHOUT
THE MARKET I THINK THIS IS BEEN
A REALLY GOOD- DISCUSSION
ALREADY I THINK THE ONE THING I
WANT TO REALLY STRESS. IS THAT
THAT MARKET DEVELOPMENT IN ITS
ABSENCE IS REALLY A TEAM SPORT
IT TAKES CONTRIBUTIONS FROM ALL
OF THIS TO MAKE THIS ALL OF US
TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN ITS STATE
AGENCIES IS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IT'S PRIVATE
INDUSTRIES NGOS ITS
MUNICIPALITIES- IN PO'S I MEAN
THERE'S A LOT OF ACRONYMS WE
COULD THROW AT. YEAH I'M AND SO
WILL THIS GONNA GIVE OAKLEY
LANHAM ECOSYSTEM THERE AND THEN
BEFORE JUMPING INTO IT IT DID
WANT TO WEIGH IN ON THE-
HYDROGEN AND ELECTRIC AND PLUG
IN CHARGING- IN BATTERY
ELECTRIC CARS I THINK WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS PLAY TO
THE STRENGTHS OF BOTH
TECHNOLOGIES SO YOU KNOW RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE FORTY FIVE LIGHT
DUTY HYDROGEN STATIONS. WITH
SOME HEAVY DUTY HYDROGEN
STATIONS UNDERDEVELOPMENT SOME
REALLY EXCITING STUFF COMING
OUT NOW- AND THEN ON THE
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE WE
STILL WE DO LEAVE THAT NATION
AND CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
THIS WE'VE HAD TO BE A 50% OF
THE MARKET- AND CARS AND I
THINK PRETTY CLOSE 50% OF THE
MARKET ON CHARGER SO. BUT
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO
GO I THINK YOU KNOW WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT ALL THE PEOPLE WE
HAVE. COORDINATED A KEY PART OF
THE STRATEGY IS REALLY MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE A CLEAR NORTH
STAR AND I THINK YOU KNOW WE'RE
ALL HERE WE'RE VERY FAMILIAR
WITH GOVERNOR NEW SENDS THAT
SEPTEMBER EXECUTIVE ORDER AT BY
FEELS TO ME LIKE THIS WAS TWO
YEARS AGO BUT IT'S THOSE JUST
IN SEPTEMBER BUT YOU KNOW THE
100% TARGETS FOR LIGHT DUTY BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE TWENTY FORTY
FIVE FOR HEAVY DUTY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE FOR DRAYAGE IN
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE FOR OFF ROAD
SO THOSE ARE ALL JUST AROUND
THE CORNER. WE NEED TO
EVERYBODY RUNNING AT FULL STEAM
TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN. AND SO AS
PART OF THAT- EXECUTIVE ORDER
THE GOVERNOR TASS GOBIZ. WITH
DEVELOPING IS THAT MARKET
ADMINSTRATION A THREE. AND
REALLY THIS IS COVER THE- AND
IT I DO. WOULD LOVE YOU FOR
YOUR READ AT AND IT'S YOU OPEN
AND- IT IS OVERHEAD. PAGES BUT
I WON. IT'S TO PAGES. THE MEAT
AND THERE'S A LOT OF APPENDICES
TO KIND OF PULL ALL THESE
PIECES TOGETHER BUT REALLY AT
THE HIGHEST LEVEL. WE'RE TRYING
TO DO FIVE THINGS WITH THAT
IT'S- ARTICULATING THE CORE
PRINCIPLES FOR COLLECTIVE
ACTION LIKE WHAT ARE WE TRYING
TO ACCOMPLISH. CLEARLY
IDENTIFYING THE METRICS AND
TARGETS SO. HOW DO WE WILL.
AGREED UPON METRICS THAT WE CAN
MEASURE SUCCESS AND FAILURES
AGAINST SO WE HAVE WE'VE-
LEARNED A LOT A LOT OF NUMBERS
AROUND WE GET TO A CLEAR THING
WE CAN. HAVE A SNAPSHOT. IN
TIME AND EVERYBODY KNOWS THE
HEALTH OF THE MARKET. ITS
ESTABLISHING THEIR ROLES AND
OBJECTIVES OF AGENCIES A MAJOR
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS OF WHO'S
DOING WHAT AND WHY. AS ORGANIZE
OURSELVES AROUND COLLECTIVE
PROBLEM SOLVING NO SINGLE.
AGENCY NO SINGLE STAKEHOLDER
HAS ALL THE ANSWERS WE HAVE TO
DO THIS TOGETHER AND THEN
FINALLY ENSURING THAT WE'RE
LEARNING LESSONS AND CARRIED
THEM FORWARD NOT JUST FOR OUR-
OWN IMPLEMENTATION BUT FOR A
FUTURE STATE TONIGHT. I GOT A
TRUCK A LITTLE BIT THAT CENTER
WHITE HOUSE MEANS THAT DON'T
USE THE WORD IN POWER AND I.
WAS ALREADY MY FLIGHTS BUT- IT
WE DO MEAN THAT IS TRYING TO
PUT IN POWER MARKET ACTORS TO
EXCEED EXPECTATIONS IS. PUTTING
POWER IN DECISION MAKING AS
CLOSE TO THE GROUND AND IS
CLOSE TO WHAT'S HAPPENING AS
POSSIBLE. AND SO. ALL THE
STRESS. IS AROUND THE SKY OF
CORE IMAGE. AND THE IDEA THAT
THERE YOU KNOW FOR. PILLARS OF
THE MARKET WE HAVE THE VEHICLES
INFRASTRUCTURE END USERS AND
WORK FORCE AND WE NEED ALL FOUR
PILLARS. TO BE AN IMBALANCE TO
BE ABLE TO ADVANCE THE MARKET
TOGETHER. HALF ONE FALLS BEHIND
WE WE'VE LACKS IT JUST AS WE
JUST TALK ABOUT IFRASTRUCTURE
WE NEED INFRASTRUCTURE TO
ENABLE VEHICLES. AND VICE VERSA
IT'S BUILT ON A FOUNDATION OF
OUR CORE PRINCIPLES THE FIRST
ONE AND I'M- INTENSELY THE
FIRST ONE IS. MAKING SURE THAT
WE HAVE EQUITY IN EVERY
DECISION AND EVERY ACTION SO
IT'S REALLY TAKING. A PRIORITY
COMMUNITY NEEDS INTO ACCOUNT AS
WE'RE MOVING FORWARD WITH OUR
PLANS. IT'S THE IDEA OF
EMBRACING ALL THAT PATHWAY SETS
YOU KNOW BATTERY ELECTRIC AND
FUEL CELL ELECTRIC IT'S HIGH
SPEED RAIL IT'S EVERYTHING THAT
CAN HELP. GET PEOPLE OUT OF AND
COMBUSTION VEHICLES AND INTO
CLEAN MODES OF TRANSPORTATION.
THAT'S VOTES IN A COLLECTIVE
PROBLEM SOLVING WHICH I'VE
ALREADY TOUCHED ON. THE IDEA
THAT PUBLIC POLICY COMPLIMENTS
PRIVATE. INVESTMENT WE REALLY
NEED PRIVATE CAPITAL HELP SCALE
THIS MARKET IT'S ONE THING TO
GET AT THE TO SEE THE MARKET
WITH PUBLIC CAPITAL BUT THE
PRIVATE CAPITAL HAS TO COME AND
TO GET READY TO GO AND THAT. WE
HAVE TO WORK TOGETHER AND THEN
FINALLY THE DESIGNING FOR
RESILIENCE AND OUT ADAPTATION.
SO IT'S BOTH A CHALLENGE AND AN
OPPORTUNITY YOU KNOW YOU LOOK
AT VEHICLE GRID INTEGRATION YOU
COULD USE THAT ACTUALLY
INCREASE. THE ROBUSTNESS AND
RESILIENCE OF THE GRID. ALL
THIS IS SUPPOSED TO FEET UP
INTO THESE CORE OUTCOMES YOU
KNOW BETTER AIR QUALITY REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. AND
CRUDE AND IMPROVE MOBILITY
ACCESS- YOU LOOK AT THE PARTY
COMMUNITIES IN PARTICULAR AND
THEN. ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
JOBS ALL HOLDING OUT INTO YOU
KNOW LARGE. SCALE CAPITAL
MARKET DEVELOPMENT. SO THE
OVERALL. THAT WOULD TALK WITH
LOOK BIT UP WITH THE STORE SO
WE HAVE. AS THEIR STRATEGY WHY.
WHICH KINDA HOUSES ALL THE
LATEST INFORMATION THE
DOCUMENTS THE PROGRESS METRICS.
THAT WE'RE THAT WILL BE GOING
THROUGH. AND FROM THERE WE
HOUSE BOTH IT DOES THAT
STRATEGY DOCUMENTS THIS IS
REALLY KIND OF OUR GUIDING
DOCUMENT. THAT I'M- YOU KNOW
IT'S UPDATED EVERY THREE YEARS
WE- SET OUT THE PRINCIPLES THE
CORE OBJECTIVES IN THE
DIRECTION. I'M I HAVE TH TABLE
HERE IS THAT NGOS TO TABLE NINE
AND THEN IN THE DOCUMENT ITSELF
I PUT THEIR PURPOSE IS NOT JUST
STATE AGENCIES AS WE NEED
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM ALL OF THESE
PARTNERS SO. WE HAVE THAT YOU
KNOW HIGH LEVEL THEY HAVE
CONNECTION THE EQUITY
CONNECTION AND THEN THE
CONNECTION INTO THE PILLARS.
AND WITHIN EACH OF THESE GROUPS
GROUPINGS LIKE NGOS OR FEDERAL%
GOVERNMENT OR STATE AGENCIES
WE'VE IDENTIFIED. I'LL LEAVE
YOU KNOW ONE OR TWO LEADS AND
SUPPORT FUNCTIONS WITHIN EACH
OF THESE PILLARS. I'M WITHIN
THAT DOCUMENT WE'VE GOT A
LITTLE DEEPER ON THE AGENCIES
SO WE SET OUT CLEAR OBJECTIVES
SO USE GO BUSINESS AN EXAMPLE
THE FIRST ONE BEING. ORGANIZING
IS THAT STRATEGY AND ITS
CONNECTION INTO THE PILLARS AND
THEN WE'VE ALSO ADDED. THE
DOCUMENTS THAT.ARE PRODUCED BY
OUR AGENCIES TO HELP MOVE THE
MARKET FORWARD AND INCREASED
UNDERSTANDING IF YOU LOOK AT
SOME AGENCIES LIKE CARPOOL HERE
FROM IN A MOMENT. IF YOU HAVE A
VERY LONG LIST OF DOCUMENTS BUT
THEY ALL HAVE A ROLE TO PLAY IN
AND ADDRESS KEY QUESTIONS
WITHIN THE SUBMARKET. SO IT'S
ONE THING TO HAVE. OBJECTIVES
AND STRATEGY. ANY OF THE ACT
BILL THAT EXIT STRATEGY IT'S
HARD BUT IT. IS EASY EXECUTION
AS HARD. THE STATE AGENCY
ACTION PLANS ARE REALLY ABOUT
EXECUTIONS WE HAVE TWENTY NINE
STATE AGENCIES BET EMBEDDED IN
THIS PLAN. AND EVERY YEAR THEY
SAY THERE IS A MEETING. AND
ANNUAL ACTION PLANS WHAT WE'VE
DONE IS CHALLENGE THE AGENCIES
TO TAKE THOSE OBJECTIVES AND
THEN PUT OUT THE KEY RESULTS
THAT WE HOPE TO ACHIEVE. WITH A
FOCUS. ON COLLABORATION IN
EQUITY. AT THE END OF EACH YEAR
WE'RE GONNA TAKE THOSE FEW
RESULTS A MEASURE AGAINST THEM
WHAT DO WE GET SHE WHERE DID WE
FALL SHORT WELL WHAT CAN WE
LEARN AND TO APPLY THAT MOVING
FORWARD. SO THESE ARE ALL
POSTED OUR WEBSITE HANKER YOU
TAKE A LOOK AT FUND CLICK
AROUND THAT WE WE'RE A LITTLE
BIT LOOSE ON THAT DESIGN IT'S
YOU'LL SEE SOME BUT DIFFERENT
THAN OTHERS. BUT THE DIRECTION
IS REALLY TO BE CONCISE OF THAT
YOU KNOW WE CAN GO IN AND
QUICKLY UNDERSTAND WHAT EACH
AGENCY IS UP TO AND HOW IT
CONNECTS OTHER AGENCIES AND
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS. AND THEN.
FINALLY YOU MOVING FORWARD WE
WE'RE WORKING THIS IS. UNDER
DEVELOPMENT BUT IT'S WHAT
RECLINER. IN A PILLAR PRIORITY
ACTION PLANS. THE ONE OF THEM
SENDING EQUITY ENGAGEMENT WHICH
THEY DON'T HAVE SKETCHED OUT
HERE. BUT IT'S REALLY PUTTING
ALL THE ENGAGEMENT WE DO AS
THIS AS A STATE ALL THAT.
ACROSS ALL AGENCIES UNDER ONE
DOCUMENTS AND ONE ROOF. TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE. REACHING OUT
TO THE PRIORITY COMMUNITIES AND
THAT ORGANIZED. COLLECTIVE WAY.
AND THAT WE'RE FEEDING THAT
INFORMATION INTO ALL OF OUR
PROCEEDINGS REGULATORY
DEVELOPMENT INCENTIVE PROGRAMS.
AND THE SECOND ONE IS KIND OF
THIS IDEA OF THIS MULTI COLOR
ACTION PLAN. SO VERY SIMILAR TO
THE STATE ACTION PLANS THIS IS
MORE OF A COLLECTIVE VIEW WHAT
ARE THE- KEY THINGS WE'RE
TRYING TO ADVANCE- THIS YEAR.
THE TAKE THAT THAT'S KIND OF
THIS COLORFUL CIRCLE HERE THE
IDEA THAT YOU KNOW
INFRASTRUCTURE IS AN ENABLER
WHAT WE GONNA DO UNDER
INFRASTRUCTURE THIS YEAR. WE
NEED TO CHANGE BEHAVIORAND YOU
GET PEOPLE THE YES. WHAT WE
GONNA DO THERE AND MEASURE
AGAINST. ONCE YOU HAVE THOSE
TWO COMPONENTS SCALE IS REALLY
IMPORTANT IT'S ABOUT INCREASING
INVESTOR CONFIDENCE THAT'S HOW
WE GET FROM WHERE WE- WHERE WE
ARE TODAY TO WHERE WE NEED TO
BE. AND THEN FINALLY IS THE
IDEA OF BUILDING THE INDUSTRY
IN CALIFORNIA YOU'LL HEAR FROM.
YOUR WHOLE CHILL ABOUT YOU KNOW
IF THIRTY FOUR AS THAT
MANUFACTURERS IN CALIFORNIA. WE
GET ATTRACT A LOT OF THE
CAPITAL- AND SO THERE'S A BIG
OPPORTUNITY TO GREAT. AT
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND JOBS.
AND FINALLY THERE'S A LOT TO DO
AN IMPLEMENTATION WE'RE LASER
FOCUSED ON THAT. IMPLEMENTATION
AND EXECUTION. AND THEN BELOW
THAT. WITHIN THE PILLARS THERE
IT'S IN COMMON BUT SHARED
UNDERSTANDING FOR EXAMPLE THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DEVELOPMENTS
ITS USE MY HAND WRITING HERE
ABOUT A LOT OF FUN WITH MY- MY
SERVICE. AND THE FACT. IDEA
HERE IS YOU KNOW WITHIN
VEHICLES INFRASTRUCTURE END
USERS WORKFORCE. EACH OF THOSE
HAS AND THEN I LIKE THE METRIC
THAT WE NEED TO DEVELOP OUT.
AND FURTHER. REINFORCED TO
HELP. COLLECTIVE UNDERSTANDING
WHERE WE ARE IN THE MARKET.
THERE'S BACKBONE POLICIES
YOU'LL HEAR ABOUT FROM OUR CORE
AGENCIES AND THEN THERE'S ALSO
REGIONAL LEADERSHIP I REALLY
WANT TO SHOWCASE- IN THAT KIND
OF. REALLY CREATE A RACE TO THE
TOP. SO TODAY'S PANEL. YOU KNOW
IT'S A SET COMPONENT OF THE TWO
NINETY. THAT SHOW EARLY. BUT
YOU KNOW WE HAVE CAR. THE AND
HE IS. AND IS THERE ARE MANY.
AT LEE. AGE A- WAS THE LEAD ON
VEHICLE AND END USERS. THEN WE
HAVE THE I CC AND THE UC
COLLEAGUES ON INFRASTRUCTURE
BUT EVERYBODY. IS TALKING TO
EACH OTHER MAKING SURE THAT WE
ARE COORDINATED WITH THE
PROGRAMS THAT THEY ARE
COMPLEMENTARY GOING FORWARD.
AND NOT IT'S NOT JUST THESE
THREE AGENCIES IS THE TWENTY
NINE. AS WELL AND THEN IT
RELATES TO ALL THE OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS- SO WITH THAT I
WANT TO HAND IT. OVER TO CHAIR
HOPE SHIELDS AND THEN. WE CAN
YOU QUESTIONS AT THE END. THANK
YOU. OKAY GO RIGHT AHEAD. THANK
YOU CHAIR GONZALEZ RECOUNTS KEY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
APPEAR BEFORE YOU TODAY MY NAME
IS DAVID HOPES ALL THE TIME
CHAIR THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION AND I'M JOINED TODAY
BY HAND AND WRIST SCHOOL WHO IS
OUR DEPUTY IN CHARGE OF THE
ENERGY COMMISSION'S QUIT
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM MANAGES
A TEAM OF SEVENTY PEOPLE
OVERSEEING. ALL THE
INFRASTRUCTURE DEPLOYMENT WE'RE
GOING TO TALK ABOUT I'M GOING
TO BEGIN JUST BY SAYING THANK
YOU TO ALL OF YOU IN THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THE LEADERSHIP-YOU SHOWN ON THE COMMITMENT TO
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION. IT IS
MAKING A DIFFERENCE I REALLY
THINK IT IS WORTH REMEMBERING
THAT YOU KNOW THE MODERN SOLAR
WIND INDUSTRY BEGAN IN
CALIFORNIA SPREAD AROUND THE
COUNTRY AROUND THE WORLD THE
FIRST UTILITY SCALE SOLAR WIND
PROJECTS WERE DEPLOYED HERE
BECAUSE OF POLICY AND THEY'RE
NOW THE LOWEST COST FASTEST
GROWING SOURCES OF ENERGY IN
THE WORLD AND WE'RE ON A PATH
TO DO THAT FOR ELECTRIC
VEHICLES AS WELL. AND YOUR
POLICY MAKING IS INSTRUMENTAL
IN THAT AND SO I WANT TO START
REALLY WITH A SNAPSHOT OF WHERE
WE ARE. AND I CANNOT OVERSTATE
THE RULE OF CALIFORNIA IN
DRIVING THIS INDUSTRY- TODAY
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTS 50% OF
THE U. S. MARKET FOR ELECTRIC
VEHICLES. WE HAVE HAD EIGHT
HUNDRED DOLLARS LIKE TO BE A
SOLD. INYOUR MISSION AND
SEVENTY THOUSAND- PUBLIC
CHARGERS NOT INSTALLED TODAY
AND IS TIED TO MENTION WE HAVE
THIRTY FOUR COMPANIES
MANUFACTURE ELECTRIC VEHICLES
IN THE STATE TODAY IT WAS OUR
NUMBER ONE EXPORT IN TWENTY
TWENTY- AND SO YOU HAVE BUSES
ELECTRIC BUSES MADE BY
COMPANIES LIKE PROTERRA. AND B.
Y. D. BEING SHIPPED TO FORTY
STATES AROUND THE COUNTRY- AND
WE'RE JUST GETTING STARTED- THE
MOST VALUABLE CAR COMPANY IN
THE WORLD IS A CALIFORNIA
COMPANY TESLA JUST TO PUT THAT
IN PERSPECTIVE. IF YOU COMBINE
THE MARKET CAP OF FORD GM AND
FIAT CHRYSLER TOGETHER AS LOW
AS FORTY HAVE TIMES MORE
VALUABLE IN ALL THOSE THREE
COMBINED BUT THEY'RE CATCHING
UP ABOUT FOURTEEN AND GM IN
PARTICULAR INVESTING ABOUT
FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. TO PROMOTE
ELECTRIFICATION AND WE'RE
SEEING SOME REALLY EXCITING
DEVELOPMENTS IN NEW CLASS OF
VEHICLES BEING INTRODUCED-
ELECTRIC FORD F. ONE FIFTY IS
COMING OUT NEXT YEAR THAT WILL
HAVE A THREE YEAR MILE RANGE.
AND THIS WEEK AS YOU MAY HAVE
HEARD. THE CHEVY. ELECTRIC I
GOT ANNOUNCED IT'LL BE OF
HUNDRED BILLION FOR. VEHICLES
ARE REAL- EXPANSION IN THE
VEHICLE CLASSES WERE SEEKING- A
LOT OF THIS MOMENTUM IS BEING
DRIVEN IS REALLY. ROOTED IN THE
REDUCTION IN THE BATTERY COSTS
SO WE'VE SEEN A NINETY PERCENT.
REDUCTION IN THE COST OF
LITHIUM ION BATTERIES OVER THE
LAST TEN YEARS. AND THERE'SA
LOT MORE COST TO COME OUT OF
THE BATTERY PACK REPRESENTS
ABOUT HALF THE COST. OF THE
VEHICLES BUT BECAUSE THE WHOLE
MARKET IS WATCHING THIS TREND.
ARE YOU REALLY SEEN INVESTMENT
SHIFT HEAVILY EVERY MAJOR CAR
COMPANY IN THE WORLD IS NOW
INVESTING IN ELECTRIC VEHICLE
MODELS. AND ARE BLOOMBERG NEW
ENERGY FINANCE WHICH TRACKS
THIS- REPORTS THERE WILL BE A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SEVEN NEW
MODELS OF ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
COMING TO THE NORTH AMERICA
MARKET BY THE END OF NEXT YEAR
SO- THIS MOMENTUM- IS UNIONS
UNDER WAY AND I CANNOT THANK
YOU ENOUGH FOR THE MESSAGE YOU
SENT- FOR A COMMITMENT TO THIS.
BINTI NATIONS NOW. MADE IT AS
WELL GO 2% ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES- AND OF COURSE
GOVERNOR NEWSOM. WITH THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER IN SEPTEMBER-
AND FOLLOWED BY- THAT'S IT THE
GOVERNMENT CHOOSES TO DO THE
SAME THING AND- WE EXPECT
ANYMORE. SO I WOULD TURN
INFRASTRUCTURE I REALLY THINK
AT THIS POINT. YOU KNOW THE
MESSAGES WE NEED TO GET OUR
BHUTAN AND BUILDERS
INFRASTRUCTURE TO MAKE IT-
REALLY- TICKLED ACROSS THE
STATE AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
AND TO SEND THE MESSAGE THAT
OTHERS LONG TERM CERTAINTY HERE
FOR ALL THESE COMPANIES TO
SCALE. I AM IN GROW FOR
CALIFORNIA TO LEAD THAT- ONE
OTHER POINT I WANT TO MAKE THAT
IS A GOOD SIGN AS AS WE CHARGE
THESE VEHICLES. OF THE VEHICLES
GET CLEANER EVERY YEAR BECAUSE
THE ELECTRIC PORTFOLIOS
CLEANING UP SO. LAST YEAR- WE
HAD 63% OF THE ELECTRICITY. IN
CALIFORNIA COMING FROM CARBON
FREE SOURCES OBVIOUSLY WE'RE ON
ROUTE. TWO HUNDRED PERCENT- NOW
INCALIFORNIA AND SO THAT'S A
NICE FEATURE- AS WELL- I DO
WANNA. OUT THAT- YOU. MISTER
SEEKING COULD A- AUTHORITY ALL
FOR. THE BILL OUT OF THE
SENTENCE THROUGH THE ENERGY.
QUICK TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM SO
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THIS. BILLION DOLLARS IT DOES
NOT REALLY APPLY TO THE PROGRAM
IS MANAGED BY. THE RESOURCES
BOARD THAT- MY COLLEAGUE
WILLIAM RANDOLPH IS GONNA TALK
ABOUT- IN ADEPT SO THERE'S
REALLY THREE FUNDING STREAMS
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE THERE IS THE
MONEY. YOU HAVE ASKED US TO
DEPLOY AT THE ENERGY COMMISSION
THROUGH THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM. THERE
IS THE MONEY. INVESTED BY
UTILITIES WHICH MY COLLEAGUE
CLIFF WRECK SHOP IS GOING TO BE
SPEAKING ABOUT AND THERE'S
MONEY FROM SETTLEMENTS LIKE
OTHER B. W. SOMEONE LIKE FIVE
ERICA. SO WE'RE WE ARE TODAY-
WE HAVE SEVENTY THOUSAND
GOAL FOR TWENTY TWENTY FIVE IS
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND. WE
THAT'S ENOUGH TO SUPPORT A
MILLION HAPPY OF COURSE WHICH
IS THE- THE BILL WE BELIEVE
WE'RE SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLAR
CHARGER SHORT. OF THAT SO- THIS
THIS FUNDING WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT- WILL HELP. CLOSE THAT
GAP BY TWENTY THIRTY THE GOAL
IS TO HAVE ONE AND A HALF
MILLION BY TWO CHARGERS AND TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND. HEAVY DUTY
CHARGES TO SUPPORT A TOTAL OF
EIGHT MILLION. ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES- IS TO GET A SENSE OF
COST SO TYPICAL LEVEL TWO
CHARGER. WHICH IS THAT'S THE
VAST MAJORITY CHARGES GOING. WE
SPENT ABOUT FORTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER CHARGER ON THAT
THAT REPRESENTS ABOUT A THIRD
OF THE COST- SO WE'RE WE'RE
PROVIDING THIS INCENTIVE IN THE
WE'RE LEVERAGING. PRIVATE
INVESTMENT. FOR SCHOOL BUS IT'S
SIX CAME THE CHARGE. TRANSIT
BUS REYES FROM C. TO TWO
THOUSAND- AND THEN DUTY. M.
HEAVY DUTY- TO BE SIXTY ALL THE
WAY UP TO TWO HUNDRED TWO
THOUSAND- SO THERE'S A QUESTION
EARLIER ABOUT HYDROGEN- WE HAVE
FORTY FIVE HYDROGEN STATIONS
ARE OPEN NOW THE GOAL FOR THE
STATE THAT WE'RE PURSUING IS.
TWO HUNDRED STATIONS BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE WE PROJECT AT THIS
POINT WILL BE TWENTY ONE
STATIONS SHORT BY THAT TIME HI
THE AVERAGE COST FOR HYDROGEN
STATION FOR US IS ONE POINT
THREE MILLION IN THAT
REPRESENTS ABOUT HALF OF THE
COST THE TOTAL COST- I DID WANT
TO MENTION AS WELL WE HAVE A
GOAL THEIR TUITION TO DO 50% OF
OUR CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE LOW
INCOME AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES- AND I WOULD POINT
OUT ONE. ONE POSITIVE
DEVELOPING THIS HAPPENED LAST
YEAR'S IS A REALLY HEALTHY
RESALE MARKET A SECONDARY
MARKET FOR ELECTRIC VEHICLES SO
YOU CAN FIND OUT A USED NISSAN
LEAF FOR FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS TYPICALLY
NOT GOING TO BUY. A NEW VEHICLE
ANYWHERE. FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
IS A IS A PRICE THAT DOES NOT
WORK. WITHOUT UBIQUITOUS
CHARGING AND SO REALLY. ARE WE
WANT TO CHARGING TO BE LIKE.
YOUR PHONE WHEN YOU GET A PHONE
YOU NEVER WORRY ABOUT WHERE AM
I GOING TO FIND LECTURES
OPPONENTS UBIQUITOUS IN OUR-
HOMES AND OFFICES AND WE HAVE
TO GET THEIR PARTICULARLY FOR
LOW INCOME SO I ACTUALLY SEE
THE EQUITY INVESTMENT. AS A
NECESSITY I SEE IT AS A AS A
DANCE INSTRUCTOR JUST AS AN
EQUITY STRATEGY ACTUALLY. I
WANTED WHEN I WANT TO MENTION
THAT IS ALSO THINK OF POSITIVE
FEEDBACK CYCLE. IS THAT-
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING FOR
THE FEW THINGS THAT. GIVES US
ACTUALLY DOWNWARD FORCE ON
ELECTRIC RATES SO. ALLERGIC
VEHICLES HAVE ALREADY
CONTRIBUTED ABOUT A BILLION
DOLLARS TO THE RATE BASE AND SO
THAT'S WHAT IT WAS GOING TO THE
OIL INDUSTRY IS NOW COMING IN.
AND YOU'RE ABLE TO SPREAD THOSE
FIXED COSTS OVER. MORE KILOWATT
HOURS ENOUGH TO POWER FORCE
WHICH IS A POSITIVE. A POSITIVE
THING- I WILL JUST CLOSE BY
SAYING YOU KNOW WE WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH CARPETS GOKU'S
WITH THE PC. CURRENTLY USING
PARTICULARLY I MEAN THEY HAVE
TAKEN THEIR LUMPS- TO DEPART
JOBS I REALLY WANT TO GIVE
GREAT CREDIT TO EACH AGENCY. I
DON'T BELIEVE WE WOULD BE WHERE
WE ARE WITH THE PROGRESS WE'RE
SEEING A NEW VEHICLE
INTRODUCTIONS WITHOUT CARDS
LEADERSHIP. AND THE INCREDIBLE
WORK ON OF SANTA FE THEY HAVE
MANAGED ON THE PC AS WELL HAS
BEEN PUSHING I UNDERSTAND I
THINK. OF THE UTILITY CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE THE PC'S
INVESTMENTS- THE NOW REPRESENTS
OVER HALF. OF THE- THE TOTAL
YOU TO INVEST IN CHARGING SO I
REALLY- INCREDIBLE WORK THERE.
I WILL STOP THERE AND TURN IT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE SHARE- THE
AND READ OFF FROM. THEIR RECENT
SUPPORT. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AND
WELCOME CHIRLA RANDALL. GO
RIGHT AHEAD. THANK YOU CHAIR
HOTEL AND KIDNAPPED KARAGANDA
AND SHE WHAT HOW INMEMBERS AND
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK HERE
TODAY- I AM THE AND RANDOLPH
CARE THEIR RESOURCES BOARD AND
I'M GONNA BE TALKING ABOUT
CARDI EFFORTS TO FACILITATE THE
EQUITABLE TRANSITION TO ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES INCLUDING
HYDROGEN FUEL CELL AND ELECTRIC
VEHICLES. AND CARDS REGULATIONS
AND PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S VERY MISSION VEHICLE
EXECUTIVE ORDER. THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR INCLUDING
PASSENGER VEHICLES HEAVY DUTY
TRUCKS AND OFF ROAD VEHICLES AS
WELL AS THE FIELD NEEDED TO
POWER THEM IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
MORE THAN HALF OF CALIFORNIA'S
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
PARTICULARLY IF YOU INCLUDE
UPSTREAM EMISSIONS. ALSO
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE MAJORITY OF
SMOG CAUSING POLLUTANTS AND IS
A SIGNIFICANTSOURCE OF TOXIC
AIR CONTAMINANTS THAT DIRECTLY
IMPACT COMMUNITY HEALTH. TODAY
OVER TWELVE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS BREATHE UNHEALTHY
AIR. IN SEVERAL AREAS OF THE
STATE ARE STILL IN NON
ATTAINMENT WITH NATIONAL
AMBIENT AIR QUALITY STANDARDS.
EXPOSURE TO OZONE AND
PARTICULATE MATTER LEADS TO A
RANGE OF RESPIRATORY AND
CARDIOVASCULAR HEALTH IMPACTS.
INCLUDING EXACERBATIONS OF
ASTHMA AND HEART DISEASE IT IS
ESTIMATED TO CONTRIBUTE TO
APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY FIVE
HUNDRED PREMATURE DEATHS IN
CALIFORNIA EACH YEAR. CLEAN AIR
AND REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS ARE NECESSARY TO
ENSURE THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF CALIFORNIANS AND OUR
NATURAL ENVIRONMENT. AS WELL AS
TO AVOID AND MITIGATE THE MOST
SEVERE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE. PGG REDUCTIONS NEEDED
TO MEET THE SENATE BILL THIRTY
TWO CLIMATE TARGET BY TWENTY
THIRTY IN ADDITION TO THE
CARBON NEUTRALITY GOAL BY
TWENTY FORTY FIVE ARE
SIGNIFICANT. R. B. OXIDES OF.
MICHIGAN OR NOT IN PARTICULAR
IT MATTER EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS
NEEDED TO MEET AMBIENT AIR
QUALITY STANDARDS FOR OZONE AND
PARTICULATE MATTER. GIVEN THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR
CONSTITUTES THE LARGEST SOURCE
OF EMISSIONS IN CALIFORNIA WE
MUST TAKE AGGRESSIVE STEPS TO
ACCELERATE THE TRANSITION TO
ZERO EMISSION TECHNOLOGIES AND
MOBILITY OPTION. IMPORTANCE OF
THIS DATA OF TRANSITION IS
EVIDENCED BY VEHICLE
MANUFACTURERS EFFORTS TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF STAFF
MODELS AVAILABLE AND THE
GROWING NUMBER OF STATES IN
CITY DEDUCTING TARGETS. SIMILAR
TO CALIFORNIANS. I HOPE HE'LL
DISCUSS WE'VE SEEN CONSIDERABLE
PROGRESS IN ADVANCING JERRY
MISSION TECHNOLOGY AND BRINGING
IN A VARIETY OF CLEANER
VEHICLES TO THE MARKET. HOWEVER
THE INCREASINGLY SEVERE IMPACTS
OF THE CLIMATE CRISIS AND THE
EFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE ON
OUR ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES. AS WELL AS THE
UNEVEN ACCESS TO CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION FOR THESE
COMMUNITIES HIGHLIGHTS THE NEED
TO ACCELERATE THIS TRANSITION.
WHAT CALIFORNIA HAS ESTABLISH
AMBITIOUS AIR QUALITY CLIMATE
CHANGE AND JEFF DEPLOYMENT
GOALS. WE REALLY MUST DEVELOP
THESE POLICIES IN ADVANCED
TECHNOLOGY USING IT A STRONG
EQUITY IN LAND SO THAT NO
COMMUNITY IS LEFT BEHIND. SO IN
A LIGHT DUTY SPACE CARBON'S
DEVELOPED AND IS DEVELOPING A
NUMBER OF REGULATIONS AND
COMPLIMENTARY INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS THAT WILL SUPPORT THE
TRANSITION TO THAT. THE LIGHT
DUTY VEHICLE TARGET IN
DEFINITIONS THAT EXECUTIVE
ORDER WILL BE A KEY DRIVER IN
CAR NEW. ADVANCE CLEAN MILES-
DANCING CARS REGULATION
CURRENTLY UNDER DEVELOPMENT.
OUR SUITE OF CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION INCENTIVES BUILT
UPON A REGULATORY FRAMEWORK BY
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS IMPROVING AIR QUALITY
PROTECTING PRIORITY COMMUNITIES
AND REDUCING PETROLEUM
DEPENDENCY. THE CLEAN MILE
STANDARD REGULATION WHICH IS
ESTABLISHED THREE SENATOR
SKINNER SB TEN FOURTEEN. WILL
ALSO SUPPORT THE TRANSITION
HEARING MISSION TECHNOLOGY.
THIS REGULATION WILL ESTABLISH
AGGRESSIVE ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED TARGETS
THAT WILL REQUIRE
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK
COMPANIES SUCH AS UBER AND LEFT
TO TRANSITION THEIR FLEETS TO
SAYS STARTING IN TWENTY TWENTY
THREE AND RAMPING UP THROUGH
TWENTY THIRTY. IN ADDITION THE
CLEAN MOUTH STANDARD IS ALSO
DESIGNED TO ENCOURAGE PULLING
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION AND
CONNECTIONS TO PUBLIC TRANSIT
WHICH PROMOTE INCREASE ACCESS
TO TRANSPORTATION
OPPORTUNITIES. TO CLEAN MY
HOUSE STANDARD IS EXPECTED TO
RESULT IN CUMULATIVE REDUCTION
OF MORE THAN ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION METRIC TONS OF CARBON
DIOXIDE BETWEEN TWENTY TWENTY
THREE AND TWENTY THIRTY ONE.
ANOTHER PROGRAM IS THE CLEAN
FUELS REWARD. WHICH REPLACES
EXISTING EASY REBATES AND
INCENTIVES OFFERED BY ELECTRIC
DISTRIBUTION UTILITIES SUCH AS
HIGHER USE AND THE PUBLICLY
OWNED UTILITIES TO THEIR
CUSTOMERS FUNDED BY THEIR LOW
CARBON FUEL STANDARD CREDIT
PROCEED. THE CREAMFIELDS
REWARDS STREAMLINES THE PROCESS
OF PAYING OUT THESE REBATE AND
MAKES THEM AVAILABLE AT THE
POINT OF SALE WITH THE ADDED
BENEFIT OF MAKING THE PROCESS
AND INCENTIVES CONSISTENT
STATEWIDE AND AVAILABLE TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS. AS SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE YOU MENTIONED AN
INCENTIVE ON THE HOOD THAT'S
QUICK AND EASY YEARS. CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS AND INVESTMENTS WILL
ALSO CONTINUE TO PLAY AN
IMPORTANT ROLE IN GENERAL WHERE
NASH DEPLOYMENT AND ADOPTION.
FOR EXAMPLE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET WOULD PROVIDE
SEVENTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS FOR
PROGRAMS LIKE CLEAN CARS FOR
ALL WHICH HAS RESULTED IN
HELPING LOWER INCOME
INDIVIDUALS AND HELPFUL.
REPLACED ELEVEN THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED OLD HIGHER POLLUTING
VEHICLES WITH MORE RELIABLE
BATTERY ELECTRIC AND PLUG IN
HYBRID ELECTRIC VEHICLE. THE
HEAVY DUTY SECTOR IS ALSO
CRITICAL TO THE STRATEGY. CARP
HAS ESTABLISHED PROGRAMS AND
REGULATIONS TO FACILITATE THE
TRANSITION OF THE HEAVY DUTY
SECTOR BECAUSE OF TECHNOLOGY.
HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS UNIT ONE
THIRD OF STATEWIDE KNOX
EMISSIONS AND A QUARTER OF
STATE MY DIESEL PM EMISSIONS
REDUCING EMISSIONS FROM HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES IS CRITICAL TO
MEETING THE STATE ALL. THIS
TRANSITION IS ESSENTIAL TO
IMPROVING AIR QUALITY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES WHICH ARE OFTEN
SURROUNDED BY WAREHOUSES
HIGHWAYS PORTS AND OTHER
EMISSIONS. CORPORATION SURE
THAT MANUFACTURERS ARE MAKING
THE NECESSARY INVESTMENTS TO
SUPPORT A FULL TRANSITION TO
ZERO EMISSION TECHNOLOGY IN THE
HEAVY DUTY SECTOR INCREASED
CLEATS THE INSURANCE THAT THEY
WILL HAVE QUALITY PRODUCTS
AVAILABLE FOR MANUFACTURERS. IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN CARBON DOT THAT
ITS FIRST HEAVY DUTY ZERO
EMISSION REGULATION THE
INNOVATIVE CLEAN TRANSIT
REGULATION WHICH IS DESIGNED TO
TRANSITION THE STATE'S TRANSIT
FLEET TO ZERO EMISSION BY
TWENTY FORTY THROUGH A PURCHASE
REQUIREMENT. THE REGULATION
WILL COMPLETELY ELECTRIFIED IN
STATE FLEET OF ROUGHLY FOURTEEN
THOUSAND TRANSIT BUSES AND IS
EXPECTED TO RDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS BY NINETY MILLION
METRIC TONS BY TWENTY FIFTY. IN
TWENTY NINETEEN HARBOR DR THE
HEARING MISSION AIRPORT SHUTTLE
BUS REGULATION WHICH WILL
TRANSITION THE STATE AIRPORT
SHUTTLE FLEET HE GERRY MISSION.
AS WELL AS THE HEARING MISSION
POWER TRAIN CERTIFICATION
REGULATION. WHICH ENSURES
MANUFACTURERS ARE PRODUCING.
QUALITY PRODUCTS FOR CONSUMERS
AND FLEETS. THE BOARD APPROVED
THE ADVANCE CLEAN TRUCKS
REGULATION IN TWENTY TWENTY
THIS REGULATION REQUIRES
pMANUFACTURERS TO PRODUCE AND
SELL MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY SAYS
CALIFORNIA BEGINNING WITH THE
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR MODEL YEAR.
DESERVE SALES REQUIREMENT UNDER
THIS REGULATION RAMPS UP
THROUGH THE TWENTY THIRTY FIVE
MODEL YEAR. AND THIS REGULATION
IS ANTICIPATED TO RESULT IN THE
DEPLOYMENT OF ROUGHLY THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND JERRY MISSION
TRACKS BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE. I
WAS ALSO WORKING ON FUTURE
REGULATIONS THAT WILL FOCUS ON
JERRY MISSION REFRIGERATED
TRUCKS AND TRAILERS. CARGO
HANDLING EQUIPMENT FORKLIFTS
AND LOCOMOTIVES. IN ADDITION TO
THESE REGULATIONS CARBS
DEMONSTRATION AND PILOT
PROGRAMS HAVE ILLUSTRATED THE
FEASIBILITY OF HEARING MISSION
TECHNOLOGY FOR USE IN A WIDE
VARIETY OF TRUCKS AND BUSES.
SEVERAL CAR PROGRAMS ARE
INCREASING DEPLOYMENT AS AS
INCLUDING THE HYBRID. AND ZERO
EMISSION TRUCK AND BUSTED OUT
YOUR INCENTIVE PROGRAM MANAGE
H. FAT WHICH PROVIDES POINT OF
SALE VOUCHERS FOR FLEET TO BUY
CLEAN FEEL. SCREEN VEHICLE. THE
FARMER PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES
FUNDING THROUGH LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS TO REPLACE OLD HIGH
EMITTING AGRICULTURAL EQUIPMENT
THIS NEW LOW EMISSION CLEAN
EQUIPMENT. ZERO AND NEAR ZERO
EMISSION FREE FACILITY PROGRAM
WHICH PROVIDES GRANT FUNDS TO
PROJECTS THAT ACCELERATE
ADOPTION OF CLEAN FREE
TECHNOLOGIES AND REDUCE AIR
POLLUTION CAUSED THANK ITS
MOVEMENT. AND I REALLY WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE NECESSITY OF AN
EQUITABLE TRANSITION TO ZERO
EMISSION TECHNOLOGY AND
ADOPTION OF CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS. WELL
THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
AND AIR POLLUTION AFFECTS ALL
OF US THOSE WHO LIVE IN
DISADVANTAGED AREAS AND LOW
INCOME AREAS ARE ESPECIALLY
VULNERABLE AND FACE THE MOST
SEVERE IMPACTS. CALIFORNIA HAS
SET AMBITIOUS EV DEPLOYMENT
TARGETS AND IT IS CRUCIAL WE
ACTIVELY SUPPORT COMMUNITIES
AND PROVIDE THEM WITH RESOURCES
THEY NEED FOR THIS TRANSITION.
TO TAKE STRATEGIC STEPS TO MEET
COMMUNITY IDENTIFIED
TRANSPORTATION NEEDS. AS OF
TECHNOLOGIES IN THE MARKET
PRETTY TECHNOLOGIES CONTINUE TO
DEVELOP STEPS WILL BECOME
INCREASINGLY AFFORDABLE. AS HAS
BEEN DISCUSSED THIS AFTERNOON
THE COSTA DOES HAS DECREASED IN
RECENT YEARS AND IS EXPECTED TO
DECLINE MORE RAPIDLY IN THE
FUTURE. STUDIES ESTIMATE THAT
BY TWENTY THIRTY THE COST OF
OWNING ANDOPERATING AS A WILL
BE LOWER THAN THAT OF OWNING A
GASOLINE OR DIESEL. VEHICLE WE
REALIZE THAT WE NEED TO MEET
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY ARE TO
PROVIDE AFFORDABLE. SAFE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS AND MUST
DO MORE TO ENSURE THAT THOSE
TECHNOLOGIES ARE AVAILABLE AND
AFFORDABLE. THE CARD SAYS
PROGRAMS ARE DESIGNED TO
IMPROVE SOCIAL EQUITY BY
ENSURING THAT THE BENEFITS OF
TECHNOLOGY ADVANCEMENTS AND
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS
ARE SHARED BY ALL CALIFORNIANS.
FOR EXAMPLE I MENTIONED THE
CLEAN CARS FOR ALL PROGRAM
WHICH IS ONE OF OUR VEHICLE
PURCHASE INCENTIVE PROGRAMS.
97% OF CLEAN CARS FOR ALL
PARTICIPANTS WERE LOCATED IN
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS OUR
COMMUNITY. HI BEEN VESTED A
SUITE OF CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
AND MOBILITY EQUITY PROJECTS TO
COMPLEMENT VEHICLE PURCHASE
INCENTIVES AND ADDRESS THE
BROADER TRANSPORTATION NEEDS.
CARBS CLEAN MOBILITY OPTIONS
PROJECT INCLUDE PROJECTS
INCLUDE THE NEWLY LAUNCHED
STATEWIDE CLEAN MOBILITY
OPTIONS VOUCHER PROGRAM. OR CMO
AS WELL AS OTHER LOCAL AND
REGIONAL INVESTMENT. BMO
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR SMALL SCALE
PROJECTS SUCH AS ZERO EMISSION
CAR SHARING BIKE SHARING
INNOVATIVE TRANSIT SERVICES AND
COMMUNITY TRANSPORTATION NEEDS.
THE SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION
EQUITY PROJECT OR STEP PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR LARGER SCALE
PLANNING CAPACITYIN PROJECT
IMPLEMENTATION GRANTS THAT
FURTHER ADDRESS COMMUNITY NEEDS
INCREASE ACCESS AND REDUCE
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED. CENTRAL
TO CARD EQUITY INVESTMENT
STRATEGY IS COMMUNITY OUTREACH
EDUCATION AND ENGAGEMENT.
ACCESS CLEAN CALIFORNIA
FORMALLY KNOWN AS A ONE STOP
SHOP PILOT PROJECT YOU
STREAMLINING ACCESS TO AND
COORDINATING OUTREACH FOR CARDS
CONSUMER FACING PROGRAMS
INCLUDING CLEANING CARS FOR ALL
AND OTHER PROGRAMS. INVESTMENT
IN HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE PROGRAM
IS INTENDED TO ACCELERATE
DEPLOYMENT. DEVELOPMENT A
DEPLOYMENT OF CLEAN TECHNOLOGY
TO IMPROVE AIR QUALITY AND
ENHANCE ACCESS TO CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION. IN ADDITION TO
STANDARD VOUCHERS PROVIDED
THROUGH EACH STEP AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER CARP ALSO
PROVIDES SATCHER ENHANCEMENTS
FOR HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES
DEPLOYED IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND AS A RESULT
OVER TWO THIRDS OF THE H. THAT
THAT'S YOUR FUNDING HAS BEEN
INVESTED IN PRIORITY.
POPULATION WELL IT DEFINITELY
UNDERCARDS FARMER PROGRAM
AROUND 65% OF PROGRAM FUNDS
SPENT TO DATE HAVE BENEFITTED
PRIORITY POPULATIONS. INCLUDING
INCENTIVE FUNDING FOR
AGRICULTURAL HARVESTING
EQUIPMENT HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS AND
OTHER EQUIPMENT SED IN
AGRICULTURAL OPERATIONS. SO
THROUGH THIS SUITE OF LIGHT AND
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE PROGRAMS
HARBAGE WORKING TO ENSURE
HISTORICALLY OVERBURDENED
COMMUNITIES AND LOW INCOME
HOUSES HELPFUL OUR PRIORITY IN
THIS TRANSITION. I'D LIKE TO
CLOSE BY REITERATING CARDS
COMMENT COMMITMENT TO
TRANSITIONING TO TRANSPORTATION
SECRETARY MISSION. AND WORKING
WITH THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO ACHIEVE THIS AND
DURING THIS AND FUTURE. THANK
YOU AND I'LL HAND THE FLOOR
OVER TO COMMISSIONER ACCEPTANCE.
THANK YOU CHAIRWOMAN RANDOLPH
WELCOME COMMISSIONER REX OFTEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR GONZALEZ THE
WHITE HOUSE YOU KNOW OTHER
MEMBERS I'M CLOSE FRANK JOHNSON
ON THE C. P. UC'S COMMISSIONER
ON ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
DEPLOYMENT I WANT TO ECHO THE
THANKS OF MY COLLEAGUES WILL
READ THE STRONG LEADERSHIP OF
THE LEGISLATURE IN THIS AREA.
AND. FRIDAY AFTERNOON TO- TO
DELVE INTO THESE. HELD BY HIM
PORTENT ISSUES THE P. YOU SEE
OF COURSE THIS IS THE PRIMARY
REGULATOR OF OUR ELECTRIC AUDIO
USE AND AS SUCH HAS SEVERAL KEY
ROLES IN SUPPORTING OUR
TRANSITIONS DESERVES THAT I'LL
TALK ABOUT CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE DEPLOYMENT.
ELECTRICITY RATES AND FUEL
COSTS VEHICLE GREAT INTEGRATION
AND INTER AGENCY COORDINATION
ICING COVERED THE COORDINATION
VERY WELL IT EXTENDS TO MANY
RELATED PROCEEDINGS BEYOND THE
IMMEDIATE SEPT PROCEEDINGS I
WILL TALK MORE ABOUT THAT. I'LL
DESCRIBE THESE OTHER ROLES IN
THE SECOND I DO WANT TO MENTION
THAT AS PART OF OUR EFFORT TO
BEST COORDINATE WHAT WE DO WITH
THE PC IN TWENTY NINETEEN WE
OPENED UP A COMPREHENSIVE
PUBLIC DOCKET TO EXAMINE THE
ROLE OF UTILITY INVESTMENTS AND
OTHER ACTIONS UTILITIES NEED TO
TAKE AS WE ELECTRIFY OUR
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR AND THAT
INCLUDES MAKING SURE THAT THEY
ARE PREPARED. FOR THIS
SUBSTANTIAL GROWTH IN THE
ELECTRICAL- THAT'S GOING TO
RESULT FROM WIDESPREAD.
ADOPTION OF SENSE. A CENTER
PARK OF THE PROCEEDING A
CENTRAL OBJECTIVE OF OURS WAS
TO STREAMLINE THE PROCESS THESE
WE FOLLOW FOR APPROVING UTILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE. INVESTMENT SO
AS PART OF THAT PROCEEDING WITH
ISSUED A DRAFT FRAMEWORK WE'VE
BEEN GETTING STAKEHOLDER
FEEDBACK ON IT WE EXPECT TO
ISSUE SEVERAL DECISIONS
THROUGHOUT THIS YEAR THE FIRST
ONE PROBABLY THE NEXT TWO OR
THREE MONTHS. I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT AS WE'VE
BEEN WORKING THROUGH THIS MORE
COMPREHENSIVE LOOK AND
FRAMEWORK FOR UTILITY
INVESTMENT WE HAVE CONTINUED TO
EVALUATE AND APPROVE UTILITY
PROGRAMS BOTH OF THOSE PROGRAMS
HAVE COME. THROUGH THE
AUTHORIZATION PROVIDED BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN SB THREE FIFTY
SO LET ME TALK NOW ABOUT THOSE
FOUR MAIN ROLES THE FIRST IS
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
DEPLOYMENT. OVER THE PAST FOUR
YEARS WE'VE AUTHORIZED
UTILITIES TO INVEST ALMOST ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION A ZERO
EMISSION INFRASTRUCTURE JUST TO
GIVE SOME CONTEXT FOR THAT I
KNOW CENTER GONZALEZ AZT SO I
MEAN ABOUT THIS AND SHE HOPES
SHE'LL MENTION THIS. THE FIG
FOR THE ENTIRE COUNTRY OF ALL
TWENTY FIVE PLUS STATES THAT
HAVE AUTHORIZED UTILITY
INVESTMENT. THE TOTAL FIGURES
TWO POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
CALIFORNIA ALONE HAS AUTHORIZED
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION OF THAT
TWO POINT FOUR BILLION AMOUNT
SO FAR. ABOUT HALF OF THE
INVESTMENT HAS BEEN IN
INFRASTRUCTURE. THE CHARGE
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES
THAT IS A PRIORITY FOR THE
REASONS MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
ARTICULATED. THOSE VEHICLES
DISPROPORTIONATELY BECAUSE
POLLUTION IN HEAVILY BURDENED
COMMUNITIES ALREADY THE OTHER
HALF IS BEEN IN WORKPLACE AND
PUBLIC CHARGING STATIONS. FOR
LIGHT DUTY ELECTRIC VEHICLES
PUBLIC CHARGING STATION JUST
REFERS TO THINGS THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS ACCESS TO AS OPPOSED
TO SOMEONE'S PERSONAL GARAGE OR
DRIVEWAY. WE HAVE A VERY STRONG
FOCUS ON EQUITY EVERY PROGRAM
WAS APPROVED IN THE PAST FOUR
YEARS HAS RECORDED ANYWHERE
FROM TWENTY FIVE. 52% OF ALL
INVESTMENTS. IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES OUR MOST RECENT
DECISIONS HAVE REQUIRED 50% OF
INVESTMENT BE. IT IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES. WE'VE ALSO BEEN
FOCUSING ON THE OST DIFFICULT
BARRIERS THE MOST DIFFICULT
MARKET SEGMENTS TWO ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE ADOPTION. THAT
INCLUDES INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
RENTERS AND OCCUPANTS OF MULTI
FAMILY BUILDINGS. THEY RELY ON
SHARED A PUBLIC CHARGING OR
COULD BE WORKPLACE CHARGING IN
ORDER TO FUEL THEIR VEHICLE. WE
IMPLEMENTED THE REQUIREMENTS OF
TWO BILLS FROM THE LEGISLATURE
AB TEN EIGHTY TWO IN TEN EIGHTY
THREE THOSE AUTHORIZED
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAMS AT
SCHOOLS STATE BEACHES AND PARKS.
LAST MONTH WE ISSUED A PROPOSED
DECISION OR IMPROVING EXPANSION
OF SAN DIEGO GAS AND ELECTRIC'S
PROGRAM FOR WORKPLACES IN MULTI
FAMILY UNITS. IN SEPTEMBER OF
LAST YEAR WE AUTHORIZED
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON TO
SPEND ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ON A
SIMILAR PROGRAM THAT IS BY FAR
AND AWAY THE LARGEST UTILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM. IN THE
COUNTRY. WE ARE ALSO CURRENTLY
IMPLEMENTING A BILL THAT YOU
FOR THE LEGISLATURE PASSED LAST
YEAR AB EIGHT FORTY ONE A
SETTLEMENT KINGS BILL THAT
CHANGES THE REVIEW PROCESS FOR
HOW WE ANALYZE COST UTILITIES
IN CORE. TO INSTALL
INFRASTRUCTURE ON THEIR CITED
THE METER AND WE HAVE A
DECISION OUT PROPOSING HOW TO
DO THAT- TALK ABOUT RATES AND
FUEL COSTS OBVIOUSLY
ELECTRICITY ELECTED GRACE THE
COST OF FUEL VEHICLE. CAN HAVE
A VERY SUBSTANTIAL IMPACT ON
OUR CUSTOMERS DECISION ABOUT
WHETHER TO PURCHASE A VEHICLE
AND HOW MUCH IT COSTS TO
OPERATE IT. IMPORTANTLY
ELECTRIC VEHICLES CAN OFFER
REAL SAVINGS COMPARED TO
CONVENTIONAL VEHICLES. WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING VERY HARD TO
DESIGN AND IMPLEMENT A VARIETY
OF RATES FOR BOTH COMMERCIAL
AND INDUSTRIAL CUSTOMERS AND
RESIDENTIAL CUSTOMERS. ALL
THREE OF OUR LARGE INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES NOW OFFER EVEY
RATES FOR COMMERCIAL AND
INDUSTRIAL CUSTOMERS. THAT
ADDRESS VERY IMPORTANT COST
BARRIERS THAT WERE KEEPING THEM
FROM ELECTRIFYING. LOOTING
DEMAND CHARGES YEAH AND THAT IN
PARTICULAR IS RESPONSIVE TO
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTION THAT WE
ADDRESSED AREAS LIKE DEMAND
CHARGES. THE UTILITIES ALL ALSO
OFFER EVEY RATES TO RESIDENTIAL
CUSTOMERS BETTER DESIGNED TO
ENCOURAGE THEM TO CHARGE AT
TIMES THAT ARE MOST BENEFICIAL
OR LESS STRESSFUL THE GREAT
SUCH AS OVERNIGHT. AND THAT
ALSO SAVE CONSUMERS MONEY SO
FOR EXAMPLE FOR EACH OF THE
MAJOR UTILITIES IN THE STATE.
RESIDENTIAL DRIVERS WHO CHARGE
OFF PEAK AGAIN TYPICALLY
OVERNIGHT THEY CAN CHARGE THEIR
CARS AT ONE THIRD TO ONE HALF
THE COST OF FUELING THEIR CAR
AT A GAS STATION. THE THIRD
AREA AS VERY PROMISING AREAS
THAT WERE DEVELOPING AND ALSO
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE ENERGY
COMMISSION ON HIS VEHICLE GRID
INTEGRATION IT'S A BUZZWORD
IT'S THINGS WE WILL BE LOOKING
FOR ALL EVERY EVERY YEAR WE
KEEP THINKING IT'S NEXT YEAR
BUT IT IS COMING SOONER RATHER
THAN LATER. AND BROADLY
SPEAKING IT REFERS TO POLICIES
AND BEHAVIORS THAT SHAPE
CHARGING BEHAVIOR IN A WAY THAT
BOTH MAXIMIZE BENEFITS TO THE
GRID. AND SAVE CUSTOMERS MONEY
THAT COULD BE AS SIMPLE AS
SMART CHARGING WHICH IS
CHARGING AT TIMES THAT ARE BEST
FOR THE GRADE. AND MORE
SOPHISTICATED TO CAN BE VEHICLE
ACTS AS A BATTERY AND FEEDING
POWER BACK TO THE GREAT AT
TIMES IT IS MOST NEEDED. LAST
DECEMBER WE ISSUED A MAJOR
DECISION IMPLEMENTING CENTER
BRADFORD STILL SB SIX SEVENTY
SIX THAT OUTLINES STRATEGIES
FOR VEHICLE GRID INTEGRATION
DEVELOPMENT. METRICS TO USE.
THE MEASURE SUCCESS OF THESE
PROGRAMS AND WE AUTHORIZED
ABOUT THIRTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN. ISLETS WERE
CONTINUING TO WORK TO ADDRESS
BARRIERS TO SCALE BGI- TO
ENSURE THAT ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING IS OPTIMIZED WITH
GREAT CONDITIONS. AND THEN
LAST- INDICATED AS AS AS A
TYSON MADE CLEAR WE'RE VERY
ACTIVELY COORDINATING WITH
OTHER STATE AGENCIES FOR ALL
THESE EFFORTS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND I'M NOW
GOING TO. TURN IT BACK TO TYSON
TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
COMMISSIONER. GREAT WELL THANK
YOU EVERYBODY I THINK THAT ALL
THESE OTHER BREATH YOU KNOW FOR
THAT FROM OUR LEAD AGENCIES I
THINK BUT IT HAD IT BACK TO YOU
AT CHAIR GONZALEZ- FOR YOUR FOR
YOUR QUESTION SO WE APPRECIATE
THE TIME. AND BILL THE TALK
THIS THROUGH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- SO WE WILL THAT.
CONCLUDES THE SECOND PANEL SO
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND CLICK
OUT FOR MEMBER QUESTIONS. AND
WE HAVE SENATOR WHAT KOWSKI FOR
FIRST QUESTION GO RIGHT AHEAD
CENTER C. THANK YOU FOR THE
FEDERAL A PRESENTATION ARE. SO
WHERE WE ACT ON HOW IS THE
STATE'S INVESTMENTS- BEEN
SCORED BY THE DIFFERENT
AGENCIES ARE PAPER SAYS AT THE
END OF TWENTY TWENTY WE HAVE
EXACTLY FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY
SEVEN THOUSAND ELECTRIC
VEHICLES ON THE ROAD. WE ALL
KNOW THAT WE HAVE ARE THE NEVER
USES THIRTY MILLION SO WE GOT
ONE SIXTIETH OF THE VEHICLES
AFTER ALL THESE PROGRAMS WE'VE
GONE THROUGH EACH OF YOU HAVE
HIGHLIGHTED ALL THE DIFFERENT
THINGS YOU DOING. ALL THE
PROCEEDINGS THAT ARE GOING ON
HOW DO WE EVALUATE THE COSTS
THAT THAT HAS TO THE STATE. AND
THEN THE OBVIOUS QUESTION AFTER
THAT IS HOW DOES THE BUDGET THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. MOVE THE
NEEDLE ON THOSE THINGS I MEAN
IT'S NICE TO TALK I'M BLEEDING
HEART LIBERAL SOME OF THE STUFF
YOU SAID BRINGS TEARS TO MY
EYES I THINK I'M DOING THE
RIGHT THING I FELT SO RIGHTEOUS
BEING THE SENATOR VOTING FOR
THOSE. BUT ARE WE- PRODUCING
THE RESULTS THAT WE FIND SO
DESIRABLE. YEAH SO I THINK ONE
THING ON THE NUMBER AND YOU
KNOW THAT FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY
SEVEN THOUSAND THAT WAS IN THE-
THE SENATE REPORT SEATED NUMBER
WE USE EIGHT HUNDRED AND THREE
THOUSAND YOU KNOW GOOD BECAUSE
INCLUDES PLUG IN HYBRID
ELECTRIC VEHICLES THE TIME AND
SO IT JUST DEPENDS ON THE
SEMANTICS OF USE THAT NUMBER.
WE'RE PRETTY CLOSE TO THE ONE
MILLION TARGETS AND IF YOU- IN
A DEAL IN YOUR GROWTH PASSED-
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE EIGHT RUN
TRACK ABOUT ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION CITY BUT START THERE
MANY OF MY CO PANELISTS BECAUSE
WHEN TO JUMP AND. I THINK IT'S
AN UNEQUIVOCAL YES- NOT JUST
FROM. THE VEHICLE BEING
DEPLOYED BUT ALSO FROM THE
VEHICLES BEING MANUFACTURED
WITH SEVENTY THOUSAND.
EMPLOYEES NOW IN THIS SPACE AND
WE'RE GROWING AS IMAGES OF
NUMBER ONE EXPORT LAST YEAR. I
THINK WE'RE JUST AT THE- EARLY
EARLY PHASE OF THIS- SO THE
STATE IS WELL POSITIONED TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS IMAGES
EXAMPLE. NO PROTERRA AND DIVERT
IT MAKING BUSES AND SELLING
THOSE INTO FORTY STATES YOU'RE
SEEING. YOU KNOW. THE STATE'S
YOU WOULDN'T THINK WOULD BE BY
ELECTRIC BUSES ACCEPTOR LINE OF
TEXAS AND- PLACES LIKE THAT BY
THE END. OF THE BATTERY PACKS A
MAJOR THE BUSES ARE MADE HERE
SO. ALL OF THIS INDIAN WIRE
THOSE COMPANIES HERE ITS
PROXIMITY TO THE MARKET. IF YOU
TALK TO CEOS AND I HAVE. THAT
IS ONE OF THE MAIN KIT TO MAKE
SO I JUST I THINK THAT
MANUFACTURING IS A PARTICULARLY
EXCITING. THING TO REMEMBER
WHEN ORDERED ECONOMIC RECOVERY-
AND YOU KNOW JUST GENERALLY.
THE WAY THE COSTS COME DOWN-
FOR TECHNOLOGY. IS REALLY
SIMPLE BUT IT'S THREE THINGS
ITS INNOVATION AUTOMATION AND
SCALE. AND ALL THREE OF THOSE
HABITS REALLY THE POLICY IS
DRIVING THE SCALE SO. I THINK
WE'RE ON A- VERY GOOD GLIDE
PATH TO YOU KNOW TO REACH OUR
GOALS BUT JUST MAKING. IT IS.
CHEAPER OVER TIME AND THEN- YOU
KNOW THE VEHICLE SENATE'S WILL
WIND DOWN THAT'S A TEMPORARY
EXERCISE. I I'M JUST READING
THE EXECUTIVE ORDERS AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER SAY XABSI NOT
P. H. E. V. SO THERE'S- WHETHER
IT'S FOUR HUNDRED EIGHT
HUNDRED. YOU KNOW. HOW WE
WANNA. COUNT THINGS. IS I. A
THE FOR UP TO THE WERE NOT
THERE BECAUSE- COMMISSION YOU
INTO. TO YOUR SUBSIDY. THE BAD
CHARGERS AT FOUR THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED. HE SAID I THINK I GOT
THAT AND I GOT THE SMALL
COMPANY IN MY DISTRICT ARE WORK
THE TOWN WHERE I LIVE THEY'RE
SELLING TESLA SELLING. BATTERY
CHARGES FOR FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
WHAT'S THE WHY IS THAT WHAT'S-
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A PRIVATE
CHARTERED SERVICE HOME WE DON'T
FUND PROJECTS THIS IS. PUBLIC
CHARGERS THAT WE'RE HAVING TO
GET THE POWER TO THE SITE YOU
KNOW BUILD A- FACILITY TO HOLD
IT SO IT'S A DIFFERENT KETTLE
OF FISH. TO HOLD. THREE WHAT
YOU'RE SEEING ARE RIGHT SO- YOU
CAN BY CHARGING FOR HOUSE FOR
DRUGS THAT'S NOT WHAT WE PAID
FOR WE ONLY PROVIDE. NO PUBLIC
CHARGING- AND THAT'S WHAT THE
WITH THE FORTY FIVE HUNDRED IS
OUR COST. THE ALL ENCOMPASSES
ABOUT THREE TIMES SINCE WE PAID
ABOUT. ONE THIRD OF THE TOTAL.
I GUESS MANAGER IS AN ACT FROM
THE AGENCIES. WHAT STEPS GOING
FORWARD CAN THEY TAKE- ON THE
ROAD TO TRY TO. CLOSE THE GAP
YEAH WE'VE WE TEND TO PASS A
LOT OF BILLS THAT WE GOT THESE
GOOD IDEAS WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
DO BUT- YOU KNOW YOU'VE
IDENTIFIED SOME OF THE GAPS. IN
THE CURRENT PROGRAMS AND IN
ORDER TO ACHIEVE DUG THE
BOULDER- WE WANT. AND WHAT IS
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN NEW
LEGISLATION THAT NEEDS TO OCCUR
AND HOW THEY CAN BE AGENCIES
INDEPENDENTLY CAN- WORK ON
THEIR OWN. WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE THAT QUESTION. SEVEN OKAY
SAID IN TERMS OF WHAT WE CAN DO
IS AGES I MEAN THERE'S A LOT OF
LEVERS WE CAN YOU CAN AND ARE
HOLDING UP ADVANCED MRK AT THE
NOTES THAT. BIG FOCUS ON EQUITY
PROGRAMS GETTING OURS GREEN
CARS AND THE PEOPLE WHO NEED IT
MOST THE MOBILITY. IT'S UTILITY
INVESTMENTS PERMITTING WE GET A
LOT OF WORK ON AN
INFRASTRUCTURE PERMITTED BUILD
OUT THE STATIONS AND MORE
QUICKLY REDUCING THE SOFT
COSTS- IT'S REALLY KIND OF
SWEET OF EVERYTHING THAT YOU'VE
YOU'VE HEARD. YEAR IT'S YOU
KNOW THE STATE OF STATE
CONTRACTS THAT TIME
MUNICIPALITIES IF MANAGE UP TO
BUY AND- YOU KNOW SPACE LIKE
LOOKING AT MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY IT'S- I'M- LISTENING GO ON
AND ON. BUT I THINK BAY.
THERE'S A LOT OF ROOM FOR
OPTIMISM AND IS LOOKING AT THE
STATS YOU TALK ABOUT INVESTMENT
AT THIS MORNING. LAST YEAR IN
TWENTY TWENTY THERE IS FIFTY
SIX POINT SEVEN SIX BILLION
DOLLARS INVESTED ENDED ELECTRIC
VEHICLE. RELATED COMPANIES IN
THE GLOBALLY. THIRTY ONE POINT
THREE THREE BILLION ABOUT A 55%
CAME TO CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
PRETTY EXCITING BECAUSE OF THIS
POLICIES WITH THIS YEAR IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TODAY WE'VE
HAD ABOUT A LITTLE OVER
NINETEEN BILLION. AND FIFTEEN
BILLION OF THAT IT'S COME TO
CALIFORNIA SO THAT'S THE A 76%
SO WE'RE REALLY LEADING LEADING
THE WAY AND I THINK THAT'S-
THIS IS ONE SIGN YOU KNOW THE
OTHER PART THAT'S COMING
CERTAIN THE A LOT MORE.
ADVERTISING YOU KNOW IT THAT
THIS IS A REAL PRODUCT ANALYSIS
YOU KNOW WILL FERRELL'S IN THE
GAME B. W. HAS A SUITE OF
COMMERCE IS OUT THERE BUT IT'S
REALLY APPLYING TO. HIGH MASS
MARKET AND SO I THINK THAT'S
KIND OF THE PART OF THE PIVOT
POINT THEY WERE LOOKING FOR.
CAN I. JUST ADD. THEM JUST
REALLY PRE. AND I THINK YOU
CALIFORNIA'S A GREAT EXAMPLE OF
HOW. YOU KNOW THE REGULATORY-
ACTIONS DRIVE THE PRODUCTS-
WHICH DRIVES THE- DEPLOYMENT
WHICH DRIVE THE MARKET- WHICH-
AS YOU SEE. WITH YOU KNOW AN
OUNCE MEANS BY AUTOMAKERS.
TALKING ABOUT THEIR GOALS FOR
THEIR OWN AND SAYS. WOMEN IN
VEHICLE RIGHT IS NOW RESULTING
IN THE MARKET DURING. DOING IT
HEALTHCARE UNITED TOWN THAT THE
MANUFACTURERS ARE STEPPING UP
AND THEY'RE PRODUCING PRODUCTS-
AS YOUR HOPES OF MENTIONED YOU
KNOW HUNDRED AND SIXTY SEVEN-
AT NEW VEHICLES- THAT. THAT
MEET THE NEEDS OF THE VARIETY
OF PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE
OLD ENOUGH TO. HERE'S DOZENS
AND DOZENS OF FAKE OF
COMMERCIALS BY CAR DEALERS
TELLING US THIS IS THE GREATEST
THING AND I'M GONNA BE THE
SEXIEST GUY IN THE WORLD IF I
GET THIS VEHICLE AND INTO THIS-
WE'LL SEE HOW THAT GOES OFF
CHAIR RANDOLPH. THIS COULD
SERVE ON A FINE POINT. THE
GOVERNOR'S DOESN'T PROPOSE ANY
FUNDING FOR VEHICLE SUBSIDIES
SUCH AS THE- CTRP. WE JUST
HEARD TESTIMONY FROM THAT WE
THINK THE SUBSIDIES IN OCTOBER
YOU VERY NECESSARY BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. I'M SITTING HERE
IN. A NICE APRIL AFTERNOON IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE Y. EIGHT ZERO
FOUR- TO SEE THE R. P. IT SAID
THAT TRY TO YOUR SHOP. SO WE DO
HAVE AN EXISTING INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS AS A STATE TACKED
ABOUT WITH CLEAN CARS FOR ALL
YOU KNOW REALLY WANTING TO LEAN
INTO- INTO EQUITY AND MAKING
SURE THAT WE ARE DEPLOYING
VEHICLES- FOR EVERYONE- AND-
ALSO DRIVING THE SECONDARY
MARKET WHICH HELPS- DR THE- AND
THE NEW VEHICLE MARKET AS WELL.
SO IT. IS NOT OUR ONLY OUR ONLY
PROGRAM AND WE DO HAVE EXISTING
PROGRAMS TO CONTINUE TO
INCENTIVIZE RIGHT TO BE- AND
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES BUT WE YOU
YOU KNOW THAT THERE ARE THREE
CARE DISTRICTS ARE DOING NINE
CARS FOR ALL IT'S A MODEST
PROGRAM AND IT'S A YOU KNOW
WHEN YOU GET A GREAT SUBSIDY IF
YOU'RE LOW INCOME BUT THERE
ARE. YOU KNOW THIRTY MILLION
pVEHICLES WHAT WHAT ARE WE
TARGETING FOR THE AVERAGE
CALIFORNIAN TOOK THE BICYCLE
THE ONCE THE BY ELECTRICAL
RIGHT NOW THIS ADMINISTRATION
SAYING THERE'S NOTHING FOR YOU.
THERE'S NOTHING I MEAN IF
YOU'RE LOW INCOME AND YOU LIVE
IN THE RIGHT ZIP CODE YOU CAN
GET A GOOD DEAL ON A FOUR YEAR
OLD- LEAF GREAT BUT IF YOU'RE
JUST AN AVERAGE CONSUMER COMING
OUT OF THIS PANDEMIC. THERE'S
NO INCENTIVE FOR YOU OTHER THAN
IT'S THE RIGHT THING AND WE
THINK THAT IT'S A WE'RE GOING
TO BUILD THESE CHARGING
STATIONS ONCE FROM THE TIME
YOU. IT SEEMS THAT YOU'RE JUST
LETTING THIS VERY POPULAR
PROGRAM AND YOU KNOW THAT THIS
TOPIC HAS BEEN OVER SUBSCRIBED
YOU CAN RUN OUT OF MONEY IN
THREE WEEKS AND YET THERE'S
BEEN YOU KNOW THAT YOU NEED TO
DO SOME SUBSIDY YOUTH THAT
TESTIMONY TODAY'S BENDER HAS TO
BE SOME SUBSIDY. AND YOU'RE
TELLING ME THAT THERE'S OTHER
PROGRAMS I KNOW THERE'S OTHER
PROGRAMS I'M TALKING ABOUT C.
V. R. P. WHICH IS POPULAR
YOU'RE SAYING TO THE MIDDLE
CLASS TO CALIFORNIA THERE'S
NOTHING FOR YOU. YOU MAKE IT A.
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS JUST
NO CAR FOR YOU. WELL AT I ALSO
NOTED THERE IS THE- CLEAN SHE
REPORT PROGRAM- WHICH DOES
APPLY. REGARDLESS OF INCOME AND
SO ON ON THE HOOD INCENTIVE TO.
PERSEVERE BECAUSE OUT THE DOOR
I APOLOGIZE OVERLOOKED THAT
YOU'RE YOU'RE- CORRECT ABOUT.
THAT I'M JUST SAYING THE- THE
TONE THAT'S COMING OUT OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS THAT THERE'S
NOTHING HERE. AND THERE'S SOME
OF US TO SIT HERE FOR YEARS
LOOKING AT THIS OVER SUBSCRIBED
PROGRAM- SCRATCHING OUR HEADS
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND. THAT YOU
GUYS ARE ALL TALKING WITH EACH
OTHER IT'S NICE TO HAVE THIS P.
C. P. U. C. AND C. ENERGY
DEPARTMENT ALL TALKING AND THIS
IS THE PLAN THAT YOU GUYS COME
UP. I'M VERY. INTERESTED TO SEE
WHAT YOU GUYS COME UP IN MAY.
COULD YOU IT'S POP. WITH
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE
THESE REBATE PROGRAMS AND
THEY'D LIKE TO SEE YOU GUYS
COME UP WITH A PROGRAM THAT'S
THAT PUTS IT MONEY ON THE HOOD.
AND IT'S A FRONT LOADED AND
WE'RE NOT BLEEDING SIX TO EIGHT
MONTHS BECAUSE SOME OF US THINK
THAT THAT MAY MAKE IT EVEN MORE
POPULAR. IF I COULD OFFSET MY
SALES TAX BUT- I'LL BE WAITING
TO SEE WHAT COMES OUT A CARB.
IN THIS AREA IN THE MARCH IN
THE MAY REVISE. THANK YOU
SENATOR MCCASKILL I THINK MANY
OF. BUT I JUST WITH I JUST
WANTED TO IF I COULD JUST. I
NOT TO GET IN THE MIDDLE OF
THAT THIS DISCUSSION TOO MUCH
BUT THOSE CLEAN THE CLEAN FEELS
REWARD PROGRAM THAT SURE ENOUGH
MENTIONED AT WHICH IS ON THE
WOULD PROGRAM. DOES OFFER
INCENTIVES UP TO FIFTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS DEPENDING ON
THE SIZE OF THE BATTERY SO IT.
IT IS A SUBSTANTIAL INCENTIVE
PROGRAM. THANKS CLASS. THANK
YOU VERY THANK YOU- COME AND I
WE ALL HAVE THOSE. I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF UP. CBO PEAK
FIELD WORDS CARS FOR ALL. BUT I
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE SENATOR
SAYING IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE
THERE'S AN OVERALL STRATEGY FOR
REALLY ENSURING THAT- EVERY
CALIFORNIA. CAN GET TO AN EEVEE
AND AT THE END AND THAT THE
MARKETING ACTUALLY- IS TAILORED
TO- PEOPLE. GETTING CARS- THAT
ARE ELECTRIC SO I THINK YOU
KNOW WE'VE GOT A LOT OF WORK TO
DO I ALSO AM AM VERY CURIOUS AS
TO WHAT MAY WILL BRING. AND
WITH THAT I MET- SAID OVER TO
SENATOR STERN WITH QUESTIONS
WELL. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR M.
AND THANK YOU- IT TO BOTH THE
CHAIRS FOR. UP THIS. THE
CRUCIAL TOP ANTI- GOT TO QUICK
BUT HOPEFULLY- USEFUL QUESTIONS
TO ASK. I WANNA BE MORE
AMBITIOUS THAN WHAT. THE
GOVERNOR HAS PUT OUT THERE AND
WHAT YOU PUT OUT THERE IN YOUR
BUDGET- AND I THINK THE
PRESIDENT HAS SAID THAT OR
HIGHER FOR ALL OF US- SO. YOU
KNOW THAT THE ONE POINT FIVE IT
WAS PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET- AND
THE AND THE TRAJECTORY THAT
YOU'RE ON FOR EITHER CHARGING
STATIONS OR- ZAGS PURCHASED BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE EIGHT WE
HEARD SOME OF THOSE NUMBERS ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION- YOU KNOW
SORT OF DIFFERENT TRAJECTORIES
YOU'RE ON WITH. CURRENT
ANTICIPATED FUNDING LEVELS- BUT
YOU KNOW BY MY MASTER WITH A
HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO BILLION.
PROPOSED AMERICAN JOBS PLAN ON
HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO BILLION
EVEN IF THEY DIVIDED THAT LIKE
BY FIFTY STATES. BUT WOULD
STILL BE AT ABOUT FIVE BILLION-
FOR THIS STATE. SO IF WE HAD
THAT THAT FIVE BILLION DOLLAR
NUMBER JUST PICKING THAT NUMBER
ALSO BECAUSE ENERGY SEIZE
MODELING THEY WERE JUST SAYING
BETWEEN FOUR TO SIX BILLION IS
REALLY WHAT WE NEED TO GET. ALL
THE WAY THERE BY. TWENTY
THIRTY- WE HAD FIVE BILLION
ANNUAL OF FOR THIS THIS. NEXT
FIVE YEAR PERIOD- HAVE YOU GUYS
DONE THAT MODELING THOSE
PROJECTIONS HOW FAR WOULD WE
GET. THIS HAVE THAT DATA. YOUR
WITH YOUR PERMISSION I'D LIKE
TO HAS CAMERA SCHOOL TO RESPOND
ON THE STRUCTURE SIDE OF FIRST.
YEAH YEAH THANK YOU FOR THAT
AND- IT'S A GREAT QUESTION AND
I'LL JUST SAY WHAT A DIFFERENCE
A YEAR MAKES YOU KNOW TO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE FUNDING
FROM THE STATE AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY- LET ME MAYBE A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT WERE CUT
DURING THE PAST. SO LAST YEAR
WE DID A YEAR INVESTMENT ARE
TRENT PER ABOUT THE PLAN AND
THAT WE TO MAKE REALLY TO FIX.
SO FOR THAT YEAR PLAN IN THE
YEAR WILL HAPPY ON LIGHT DUTY.
ALSO I MEAN TO HAVING TO THAT
SECOND YEAR WE OF DID SOMEONE
THE METAL A LOT HERE MUCH MORE
HAVE DUTY AND MEDIUM DUTY LEFT
IN MY TO THE- WITH THIS INFLUX
OF MONEY WE DON'T HAVE TO MAKE
THE TOP CHOICES. WE CAN WHAT
LEAST BE DONE THE DUTY WE CAN
DO ANYTHING ME AND HAVE TO DO.
TO PUT MORE COLOR TO. WE REALLY
TO DO IT BECAUSE AND CLOSER GAP
WHICH TWENTY. WE CAN DO THAT
THROUGH AN EXTENSION OF THE
CALATHEA P. PROGRAM. WHICH USES
REALLY GRANULAR DOT AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL. TO TARGET WITH
THE BIGGEST GOT. THE OTHER
THING I WANT TO DO. IS
CURRENTLY RUN FOR. PROBE SO WE
NEED TO. IN THE- EXT. ON UNIT
DWELLINGS. WE NEED A PROGRAM
THAT FOCUSES. ON RURAL
COMMUNITIES- WORSE DESIGNING
PROGRAM NOW. WE WANT TO BE FOR
THE- OF WHAT COULD COME. OR
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. WE
WANT TO PUT IN PLACE THE
VEHICLE. WE CAN REALLY QUICKLY
I'M NOT. AT ALL HAVE EQUITY
COMPONENT WELL. SIMILARLY WERE
TIED TO ME DO YOU HAVE DECIDE.
AGAIN YOU KNOW. WE HAVE TO MAKE
UP IT DIDN'T OF MONEY FROM DEAD
BUT IF WE DO HAVE YOU
OPPORTUNITY THAT ALLOWS IT TO
DO MORE AT THE SCALE WE NEED
THEIR- ON THE COMMUNITY HOW DID
YOU DECIDE. WE WANT TO MORE
GREAT TRUCK. EXTREMELY
POLLUTING TRUCKS THAT ROCKET
ONE NATION AND LOW ENERGY. WE
WANT YOU MORE TRANSIT BUSES.
COLLECT THEM FOR TRUCKS. AND
ALSO WE HAVE AN ON MEDIAN HEAVY
DUTY BLOCK. FOR THE BY THE
COMMISSION IN MARCH WHAT PART
OF CALIFORNIA NOT WANT. TO
DEPLOY ACROSS ALL THE NEEDED DO
YOU HAVE A DEFECT. REALLY WHAT
THIS LITTLE US TO DO IT TO MAKE.
TARA NOT. BUT I BROUGHT ABOUT
THE ENTIRE RIGHT. AND MY ONE
FALL UP QUESTION IS NO TO DO DO
THE BUDGET SET SHARES- AND YOUR-
YES THIS AGO MISTER A- IF THEY
WAS MORE. IS THERE OPEN. STATE
THEATER BORDER WRIT LARGE
WITHIN THE ADMINISTRATION TO
EXPANDING AND LOOKING AT CGRP
ENHANCEMENTS OR OTHER- INSTEAD
IS THAT MIGHT MOVE US YOU KNOW
INTO A PLACE WHERE EVERY MIDDLE
CLASS CALIFORNIAN YOU CAN START
TO ACCESS SOMEBODY'S PROGRAMS
WHERE YOU KNOW SOME OF THESE
GROSS PUBLIC SCHOOLS AN BE
TURNED IN FOR THE PLUS UP TO
THE CLEAN CARS FOR ALL THEIR
OPENNESS TO. DO EXPANSION.
SENATOR I PROMISE YOU IF YOU
GIVE ME FIVE BILLION DOLLARS- I
CAN I CAN COME UP WITH SOME
HEAVY DUTY. OPTIONS I CAN COME
UP WITH- AS YOU KNOW LATE DUTY
VEHICLE OPTIONS- SCHOOL BUS
OPTIONS- YOU KNOW MORE
AGRICULTURAL EQUIPMENT OPTIONS
I CAN COME UP WITH OPTIONS.
RIGHT I WOULD JUST SAY. I DON'T
MEAN IT JUST AS A FLIP SORT OF
REFERENCE TO A BIG NUMBER IT.
IT SOUNDS LIKE IT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT AND SO. TO GET PREPARED
FOR IT AND TO BE ABLE TO
ARTICULATE WHAT THOSE BENEFITS
COULD LOOK LIKE THAT EVERY
SCHOOL KID IN CALIFORNIA CAN GO
TO SCHOOL IN A BUS THAT WILL
MAKE THEM SICK WITH EVERY
MIDDLE CLASS CALIFORNIA HAS A
CHANCE TO GET INTO AN ELECTRIC
VEHICLE- DOES SEEM. LIKE IT'S-
ASPIRIN SO THE MORE YOU ALL CAN
EVEN ARTICULATE THAT
ASPIRATIONAL STUFF IF WE HAD
MORE YOU'D GET THIS IF WE HAD
MORE YOU'D GET THAT. THAT THAT
WOULD HELP US IN THE
LEGISLATURE ALSO KNOW HOW BIG
THIS IS AND BY THE WAY IT'S NOT
IT'S NOT ME. THE PRESIDENT SO
HE HE'S GONNA BE THE ONE
HOPEFULLY TO DELIVER HERE BUT
WE'LL JUST TAKE TAKE ALL THE
CREDIT- ANYWAY THANK YOU FOR
DREAMING BIG I THINK IT'S NOT
THE TIME FOR. INCREMENTALISM
HERE I THINK THAT THERE'S
APPROPRIATE SKEPTICISM AND
SCRUTINY COMING FROM HIS
OVERSIGHT HEARING INTO WHAT
HAVING PUSH YOU GUYS TO DO MORE
BUT I THINK THAT'S TO ME WHAT I
TAKE AWAY IS LIKE. NEED TO DO
MORE AND A LOT MORE AND SO WE
HOPE. WE HAVE TO. SEND YOU GUYS
PUSH. THANKS A LOT I'M HERE.
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN- HEAR
YOU LOUD AND CLEAR ON THAT
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THOSE
ITEMS UP AND- SO NEXT WE HAVE A
SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. SO I JUST WANTED TO GET
A RECAP ON WHAT I. HEARD AB CAN
CREDIT SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE ONE
AND A HALF MILLION. JOBS BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THAT'S THE
FIRST GOAL AND THEN BY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE. NO MORE CELLS OF JOBS
OBVIOUSLY IN IN CALIFORNIA
WE'RE GONNA HAVE MANUFACTURES
MAKING THOSE STEPS. SO IS THAT
IS THAT WHAT I HEARD IN THE
PLANNED BETWEEN NOW AND THEN IS
THE RESOURCES WE HAVE AVAILABLE
TO US. TO GET US TO TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. AND I ALSO IS A
FOLLOW UP ON THAT AS WELL.
THERE WAS A COMMENT ABOUT YOU
KNOW PRIVATE CAPITAL OR OR
BRING IN THAT. THE PRIVATE
INVESTMENT IN AND THAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN AT TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
IS THAT THE POLICE AND I KNOW
THAT THAT. THAT MANUFACTURERS
ARE. PUTTING THEIR CAPITAL UP
TO. MEET DEMAND FOR THE MARKET
AS WELL. YEAH MAYBE US SENATE
PRIVATE CAPITAL PART I MEAN
IT'S ALREADY HAPPENING IF YOU
LOOK. AND YOU KNOW THAT. CAN
ENTER COMMISSIONER BILL GINGER
HOTEL CAN TALK ABOUT IT BUT YOU
KNOW LIKE THAT MATCH THEIR-
THEM OUT OF PRIVATE PUBLIC
CAPITAL AS TO PUT IN THAT IT
NAME OUTOF PRIVATE CAPITAL
THAT THAT'S ATTRACTING IS
INCREASING. BUT EVEN IF YOU
JUST TAKE A STEP BACK AND LOOK
AT WHERE WE ARE WITH CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE. THE MAJORITY OF
INVESTMENT TO DATE HAS BEEN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR IN IN PUBLIC
CHARGING FOR EXAMPLE AND THEN
IF YOU LATER ON LIKE WORKPLACE
CHARGING THAT'S EVEN MORE. THAT
WAY AND SO IT. IT'S REALLY
ABOUT CREATING MARKETPLACE
CERTAINTY THAT THEY KNOW THIS
MARKET IS COMING IN AND IF YOU
LOOK IN THE FUTURE YOU KNOW
THAT TWENTY TWENTY. FIVE IS
KIND OF A BAD. A GOOD PIVOT
POINT TO THINK ABOUT THE GOING
BACK TO SIMON MOVIES-
PRESENTATION YOUR- TOTAL COST
OF OWNERSHIP. IT MAY DECADE IS
WHERE IT STARTS TO LOOK REALLY
ATTRACTIVE FOR- YOU KNOW THE
NUMBER OF CLASSES OF VEHICLES.
THAT'S ALSO THE YOU KNOW IS A
GREAT REPORT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION COMMENCE WITH YOU
SEE ABOUT I'D HIDE YOUR
GENERATED WITH RENEWABLE
HYDROGEN YOU CAN SEE THE COST
COMPETITIVENESS WITH DIESEL AND
GASOLINE IN THAT MID DECADE YOU
KNOW. AND THAT'S OF COURSE
ASSUMING. A NUMBER OF SUPPORT
OF POLICIES BUT IT'S- I. THAT
WILL WORK ON BUT IT. SO THERE'S-
YES IT'S TWENTY ONE POINT FIVE.
RAMPING UP VERY QUICKLY. DO YOU
KNOW HOW TO PERCENT- BY. TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE. MY OBSERVATION IS
THAT- THE LAST COUPLE BUT LOWER
THE LAST MONTH WE'VE- WE'VE HAD
THE- HI SPEED. AND IT ALREADY
WE DID IT THERE WAS AUDIT
BASICALLY- AND THEY WERE
SUPPOSED TO BE PRIVATE
INVESTMENT AND PARTNERSHIPS
COME ON THAT AND THEY HAVE
REALLY DEVELOPED- WE HAD AN
AUDIT ALSO OF THE CAREER
RESOURCES BOARD WHICH I THINK
FROM. BROUGHT A LOT OF- POINTS
ON REALLY THE LOW INCOME PEOPLE
WITH A RISK THERE'S A HUGE
DISPARITY ON WHO'S GETTING THAT
THE- THE RESOURCES- WE KNOW
THAT I THINK IT WAS THE SENATE
MEMBERS SALAS THAT DID ACTUALLY
READ THE NUMBERS WERE HIS
COMMUNITY WAS VERY LOW. THIS IN
THE- BALLY IN THE COASTAL FOLKS
WHO WERE WELL MORE WEALTHY-
WE'RE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THAT
SO I'M I'M REALLY SKEPTICAL AND
ON AND I WAS HOPING WE WOULD
GET A LITTLE BIT MORE ON THE-
TRANSITION HOW IT REALLY GETS
AT THIS IS THAT. I THINK IT AND
YOU'RE ASKING THE LEGISLATURE
TO STEP UP AND ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENT EXECUTIVE ORDER ARE
PUTTING PLANS TO GET THERE. AND
I'M HAVING A TOUGH TIME FIGURE
OUT HOW WE'RE GONNA GET TO EVEN
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. WHAT THE
RESOURCES THANK GOD WE HAVE YOU
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF MONEY IN
THE GENERAL FUND RIGHT NOW. GET-AVAILABLE BUT- I'M ASSUMING
THAT THIS ECNOMY IS NOT GOING
TO STAY THIS STRONG JUST COMING
OUT A- LITTLE BIT. HERE SHORTLY
WE MAY SEE A WHOLE DIFFERENT
SCENARIO. TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
IT'S GONNA BE TOUGH. AND THEN
FROM THERE ON IT'S GONNA BE
REALLY TOUGH IN IT I DON'T KNOW
VERY MANY MEMBERS THAT WILL. BE
SOME WILL BE AROUND- AFTER
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE BUT-
ASSISTANCE THIS CALL ORDER I
WAS HOPING TO GET A LITTLE MORE
INFORMATION ON. REALLY HOW THAT
LOOKS LIKE IT'S GOING TO WORK.
WELL I CAN. I CAN ADD BRIEFLY
THAT- YOU KNOW. AS AS WE HAVE
DONE FOR SEVERAL YEARS THE AND
YOU KNOW WE REALLY RELY ON A- A
COMBINATION OF REGULATORY
ACTIONS AND INCENTIVES- AND-
AND INFRASTRUCTURE AS SENATE
THE CDC FOLKS CAN TALK ABOUT-
AND SO YOU KNOW WE WILL.
CONTINUE AND TO DO THAT
CONTINUE TO COORDINATE CLOSELY
WITH OUR SISTER AGENCIES TO THEEXTENT- THAT- ADDITIONAL-
FUNDING COMES FROM THE YOU KNOW
THE- FIGHTING IN MINISTRATION
OR OR AND- FEDERAL SOURCES YOU
KNOW WE CAN. WE HAVE A LOT OF
STRATEGIES THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
TO DEPLOY- YOU KNOW AS WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT EARLIER ARE RURAL
SCHOOL THAT- PROGRAM- COULD
PUT. A YOU KNOW A THOUSAND
BUSES- ON THE STREET- IN RURAL
AREAS IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES- AND AT YOU KNOW SO
THERE'S A LOT OF LEVERAGE THAT
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO THE
CLAY- AS WE CONTINUE TO
COORDINATE VERY VERY CLOSELY
WITH OUR SISTER AGENCIES. I
COULD ADD CENTER DOLLARS DEBT.
THAT THE INVESTMENTS ARE NOT
GOING TO BE FOREVER JUST AS
THE- INVESTMENTS IN FOR A CAR
FOR PURCHASE OF VEHICLES WILL
BE WILL BE ABLE TO TAPER OFF AS
THE PRICE OF ELECTRIC VEHICLES
COMES DOWN AND BECOMES THE SAME
AS A TRADITIONAL CARD IS OF
COURSE ALREADY CHEAPER TO
OPERATE ELECTRIC VEHICLE YOU
SAVE ON MAINTENANCE AND OTHER
COSTS. THE SAME IS TRUE IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE SPACE RIGHT NOW
WE'RE SUBSIDIZING AS A STATE IN
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE IN MULTI FAMILY
UNITS HARD TO ACCESS MARKET
SEGMENTS. BECAUSE THE PRIVATE
SECTOR DOESN'T SEE ENOUGH
PEOPLE DRIVING ELECTRIC
VEHICLES TO MAKE THOSE CHARGING
STATIONS PROFITABLE BUT ONCE
MORE PEOPLE DRIVE THE CARS. WE
WILL BE ABLE TO STEP BACK AND
PRIVATE COMPANIES WERE ALREADY
ANXIOUS TO COME INTO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE REMARKABLE STEP
IN AND INCREASINGLY THEY'LL B
ABLE TO MAKE A PROFIT GO BE A
BUSINESS CASE FOR THOSE
CHARGES. AS MORE MORE PEOPLE
ADOPT VEHICLES SO YOU'VE HEARD
THE CHICKEN AND THE EGG THING
WITH ELECTRIC VEHICLES MANY
TIMES BUT THAT'S HOW WE'RE
ENVISIONING THINGS WE HAVE TO
GET OVER TO. THE GAP OVER THE
NEXT FIVE TEN OR MORE YEARS BUT
THEN. THE MARKET WILL BE SELF
SUSTAINING. LAB IS BEEN THAT. I
JUST GOT LOOKED TRYING MEAN
THAT I THINK THERE OVERLY
PRICED RIGHT NOW I THINK THERE
RECENTLY PRICE ACTUALLY IF YOU
START LOOKING AT A COMPARABLE
CARS ON THERE NOT OVER PRICES
STEP INSTRUCTION THAT'S A
BARRIER AT LEAST FOR ME- AND
THE RANGE THAT THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO YOU KNOW
COMMUTE. BUT BUT BUT WE'VE I'M
NOT TALK TO THE DEALERS OUT
THERE WHO'VE BEEN FORCED ME WE
PUT LEGISLATION THROUGH THIS
FORCE THEM TO HAVE SO MANY CARS
THAT THEY HAVE TO GET THE DEBT
TO MOVE AND THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO
MOVE AND SO THE DEMAND IDE
EVEN WITH INCENTIVES AND I
AGREE WITH THE- THE CENTER. OF
MY CASKET IT. WILL IF WE'RE NOT
GONNA INSTEAD OF IT WOULD.
FIGURE WAY OUT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE CAN GET A- ON- I THINK
IT'S GONNA BE DIFFICULT AND WE
HAVE TO. SOMEHOW YOU KNOW IT'S
JUST. IT'S MIND BLOWING WHEN I
SEE. TWENTY NINE AGENCIES THAT
THE FIRST CHART WITH ALL THOSE
ACRONYMS ON THEIR AND- LOGOS.
COORDINATING THIS WHOLE PROCESS
IS. TO ME IS. YOU KNOW I'M I'M
NOT CONFIDENT THAT. THOSE
AGENCY ALL THOSE AGENCIES
TOGETHER- CAN GET THIS JOB DONE
AND IF WE DUMPED. BILLIONS IN
THESE PROCESSES AS WELL SO FAR
SO RIGHT. BUT I ACTUALLY WANT
TO BUY WHEN I LOOKED UP I WILL
NOT SAY I I'M I'M I DRIVE A-
FORD. AND I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE
AN ELECTRIC WHEN I JUST THAT
YOU'D BE COOL IF I COULD GET
FIVE HUNDRED MILES OUT OF IT I
DRIVING ONE EVEN IF IT WAS
COST. SO BUT I GOTTA BE ABLE TO
GET FROM POINT A TO POINT B.
AND SO. AND THAT'S TWO OR THREE
YEARS OUT THAT'S CLOSE TO OUR
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE MARK BEFORE.
THOSE VEHICLES ARE GONNA BE
AVAILABLE. THANK YOU SENATOR
DAHLE AND I- WE'RE ALL IN
AGREEMENT HERE YOU KNOW WE I
THINK THE END OF THE END GOAL
HERE IS THIS OVER ARCHING
STRATEGY THAT WE'RE- REALLY
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT AND I DO
HAVE ONE QUESTION ABOUT THAT-
BUT THE- LEGISLATURE DOES HAVE
A LOT OF. DECISIONS TO MAKE IN
FRONT OF IT IN TERMS OF A
BUDGET APPROPRIATIONS AND SO WE
WANT TO ENSURE THAT WERE. TYING
THOSE TO THE CORRECT STRATEGIES
HERE- AND BEFORE I ASK MY
QUESTION ACTUAL GO TO SENATOR
ARCHULETA. YES THANK YOU
VENTURE JUST WANT TO CLARIFY.
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT- I
STILL HAVE- FROM THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO TESTIFIED TODAY. BUT
THAT JUST HYPOTHETICAL THERE'S
A PARK. WITHIN TWO MILES OF ART
CAPITAL HERE. IN THE CITY IS
AGREED TO PUT IN FOR. A
CHARGING STATIONS. SO LET'S
LOOK AT THE PARTNERSHIP IN THE
COSTS WHAT WOULD THAT LOOK LIKE.
HI HEADED AGAIN DO YOU WANT TO
SPEAK TO HOW WE'RE-
INCENTIVIZING- THE CITY
INVESTMENTS. CAN YOU SPEAK UP
PLEASE. YES COMMISSIONER YEAH
I'LL BE HAPPY TO- OKAY YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU NOW. OKAY GREAT
YEAH SO THE WAY WE DO THAT IS
WE RUN FOR THE TAKING BEEN
PARTNER WITH- DIFFERENT PRIVATE
ENTITIES BUSINESSES AND
MUNICIPALITIES AS WELL SO IF
YOU'RE EXAMPLE STATE PARK ONE
TO DO IT THEY CAN APPLY FOR ONE
REPLICATION OR IF THERE WAS
ENOUGH OF A PUBLIC POLL FOR
THAT WE WOULD NINE APPLICATION
AROUND THAT. MAKE IT ELIGIBLE
FOR FOLKS AND WE OUGHT TO DO
THAT IS IF WE USE THE BLOCK
GRANT THERE'S ONE DESIGN BOOKS
SOMETHING LIKE THIS WE WOULD BE
ONE WHERE WE SENT A VERY CLEAR
SCORING CRITERIA A LOT OF THAT
OFF NOT WITH NOT SHARING. AND
THE PEOPLE WOULD THEN APPLY TO
IT AND WE SCORED DOWN. NOT LIVE
AND FUND PROJECTS. FOR
SOMETHING LIKE YOU DESCRIBE. I
COULD SEE IF NAY. WHERE WE- YOU
KNOW WE WANT ME 2% SHARING
PARTNER. AND THEY WILL COME US
WE CORD. GET THE BACK BANG FOR
THE UP DOLLAR. AND ALSO ENSURE
WE MAY SMART- AND PARKED IN THE
WHERE. GO IN THE CAR. IT SO
CARACAL THE I. P. PROGRAM WE
YOU FORTY HUNDRED DOLLAR PER
LEVEL TWO STATION AND NOT FROM
THE PUBLIC DOLLAR WE LEVERAGE
AN ADDITIONAL ABOUT EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR FOR THE DC FAST CHARGERS
SO FOR EXAMPLE IN ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE DOING ABOUT CHARTER ABOUT
SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLARS- PUBLIC
SECTOR. LEVERAGING ABOUT ONE
THIRD FROM THE OTHER. THANK YOU
VENTURE THANK YOU SENATOR
ARCHULETA OKAY MY FINAL
QUESTION AND THEN WE HAVE OUR
LAST AND FINAL A PANEL HERE-
JUST SORT OF IN THE SAME SENSE
OF COORDINATION I THINK WE'VE
HEARD THAT A COUPLE TIMES FROM
SOME OF OUR- SOME OF SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES HERE. BUT IT IS-
DESCRIBED IN OUR BACKGROUND
PAPER AS WELL- FOR INSTANCE ONE
EXAMPLE THAT C. E. C. AND THE
P. YOU SEE MANAGING- AND
FUNDING THE ARE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE THE CHARGING
STATIOS VERY DIFFERENTLY. HOW
IS THAT RECONCILED AND WHO IS
THE OVER ARCHING BODY TO BE
ABLE TO COME TO A- AT IT A
CERTAIN GOAL AS TO HOW WE WOULD
GET TO OUR CHARGING STATION-
GOALS AND INFRASTRUCTURE GOALS
I THINK. AGAIN I'M STILL TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND WHERE WE'RE
HEADED IN THAT DIRECTION BUT
THIS IS ONE EXAMPLE OF MANY
OTHER. PLACES WERE SEEING WHERE
WE MAY BE. NEEDING MORE
COORDINATION AND WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHO'S-
RESPONSIBILITY YOU GET A CHECK
IN I CAN SPEAK TO THAT IN THE-
TURKISH SOCCER CAN. CHINA'S SO-
BASICALLY. IS ON POINT MOST
VEHICLES THE ENERGY COMMISSION.
WAS DIRECTED BY THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AB TWENTY ONE
TWENTY SEVEN TO DO THE
STATEWIDE ASSESSMENT FOR
CHARGING NEEDS AND THEN WE FIND.
CHARGERS THROUGH THE DEEPLY
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM AND THE
P. YOU SEE OVERSEAS. THE NOT
UTILITIES BUT THE INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITY INVESTMENTS IN
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE- AND SO
WE WORK VERY CLOSELY- TOGETHER
WITH THEM THE COMMISSION WRECK
SHOP IN A MATURE YOU WOULD ADD
MORE THERE WELL THAT'S RIGHT WE
FOLLOW THE CDC'S LEAD IN TERMS
OF THE OVER THE NEED FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE SO WE T<c.cyan>.</c>
BOTH THE SEGMENTS OF THE NUMBER
OF CHARGERS TO THEIR OVERALL
ASSESSMENT AND I THINK AT THE
HIGHER LEVEL GOBIZ KEEPS US ALL
ON TRACK TO MAKING SURE THAT
COLLECTIVELY WE ARE MEETING THE
ADMINISTRATION CALLS. YEAH I
THINK THAT'S RIGHT I THINK. AND
SO EACH STATE AGENCY HAS IF IT
IS NOT DUPLICATIVE IT'S VERY
COMPLEMENTARY THEY WORK HAND IN
GLOVE TOGETHER ARE ROLLING GO
IS MAKE SURE THAT CONTINUES TO
HAPPEN. WE DON'T HAVE TO DO
MUCH THEN THAT FRONT REALLY
EVER BECAUSE EVERYBODY'S
WORKING SO CLOSELY TOGETHER BUT
IT'S YOU KNOW IF THERE EVER IS
AND THAT DISPUTED WE NOTICED
SOMETHING IS GOOD HEY THIS IS
ACTUALLY DUPLICATIVE THAT'S
WHEN WE GO WE TALK WE SORT THAT
OUT MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE-
LEVERAGING OUR RESOURCES MOST.
EFFICIENTLY AS POSSIBLE BUT
THAT THEREABSOLUTELY
COMPLEMENTARY ANY THEY WORK
DECISION THAT COMES OUT OF
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION HAS
TAKEN THE ENERGY COMMISSION
ANALYSIS INTO ACCOUNT. THAT THE
C. SAME THING WITH THE UTILITY
INVESTMENTS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WERE GIVEN THE MARKETS THAT WE
NEED TO. THE MOST. AND IF I
COULD- YOU KNOW AS AN EXAMPLE
OF- COORDINATION- RECENTLY WE
DID CAN. BE COMPETITIVE
SOLICITATIONS WHERE HE HE AND
CARP APPLICATION PROCESS EASIER
STREAMLINED. AND THAT RESULTED
IN FIFTY AND HEARING MISSION
TRADES TRACKS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE- WITH SO THE CDC
FUNDED THE INFRASTRUCTURE PART
WE FUNDED THE VEHICLE CARE AND
WE DID IT IN A REALLY
COORDINATED FASHION. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT- WILL
CONTINUE TO ADD TO ASK THESE
QUESTIONS AND ENSURE ALL
COORDINATING EFFECTIVELY BUT I
APPRECIATE THAT THE ANSWER IS
NONETHELESS. OKAY SO WE'RE
GONNA I DON'T SEE ANY OTHER
MEMBER QUESTIONS SO WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND- START OFF WITH OUR
THIRD PANEL ON FINAL PANEL WILL
START WITH PROFESSOR STEVE
RITCHIE HE'S THE DIRECTOR OF UC
INSTITUTE OF TRANSPORTATION
STUDIES AND PROFESSOR OF CIVIL
AND- AND FROM. ENVIRONMENTAL
ENGINEER. AT UC IRVINE- WELCOME
PROFESSOR RICHIE AND I WANT TO
THANK OUR LAST PANEL FOR THEIR
COMMENTS AS WELL. GO RIGHT
AHEAD. GREAT THANK YOU FOR THAT
AND GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRS AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEES I'VE
BEEN ASKED TO PROVIDE COMMENTS.
TO THIS SPEAK WITH YOU THIS
AFTERNOON. GREAT WE CAN HEAR
YOU GO RIGHT AHEAD. ON THE
LIGHT DUTY VEHICLE SECTOR THE
HEAVY DUTY SECTOR REALLY IS NOT
AS WELL UNDERSTOOD FROM
RESEARCHING PUBLICLY. IT
FEATURES GREATER COMPLEXITY
WELL CITY OF DATA LACK OF TOOLS
FOR POLICY ANALYSIS INCLUDING.
PROFESSOR RICHIE I THINK YOU
MIGHT BE GOING IN AND OUT A BIT.
ARE YOU STILL ABLE TO SEE MY
SLIDES AND GETTING SOON
MESSAGES THAT IT'S QUICK. YES
YOUR PRESENTATION IS NO LONGER
UP- WE CAN SEE YOU BUT WE CAN
HEAR YOU NOW PERFECTLY SO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO GO AHEAD AND
PROCEED- COLLEGE EYES FOR THAT
I'M NOT SURE WHAT HAPPENED
WOULD SOON BUT- SO HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES ARE RELATIVELY SMALL
IN NUMBER BUT THERE. THE BIG AN
IMPACT IN CALIFORNIA WE'VE GOT
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND CLASS EIGHT. TRUCKS
SEES A LARGE THREE AXLE TRACTOR
IS ALMOST HOLDEN USED DIESEL.
AND I THINK YOU'RE WELL AWARE
OF THE DISPROPORTIONATE AIR
QUALITY IMPACTS OF THESE
VEHICLES- THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
IMPORTANT HEAVY DUTY DIESEL
ATTRIBUTES TO CONSIDER WHEN
DEVELOPING POLICY TO TRANSITION
SERVICE THIS HELPS US TO FIND
THE VEHICLE TYPES AND
APPLICATIONS THAT ARE TO BE
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSED. THE
FEASIBILITY OBSERVE
TECHNOLOGIES AND TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE BEFORE AND
AFTER- IMPLICATIONS OF POLICY
IMPACTS AND SO. THEIR NUMBER OF
ATTRIBUTES IS INCLUDE THE CLASS
OF THE VEHICLE THAT'S
RELATIVELY STRAIGHTFORWARD THE
FEDERAL HIGHWAY ADMINISTRATION
IS A WEIGHT BASED CLASS SYSTEM
WITH DIFFERENT AGENCIES INCLUDE
DIFFERENT CLASSES IN THE
DEFINITIONS OF. WHAT AN HDD IS.
THERE A DIFFERENT VOCATIONS
THINGS LIKE DRY AGES WITH WITH
HEARD REFUSE SHORT LONG WALL
AND OFTEN INVOLVES VEHICLES
WITH DIFFERENT CHARACTERISTICS.
THE COMMODITIES OF THESE
VEHICLES CAREY CAN BE IMPORTANT
TO DISTINGUISH BETWEEN THEIR
AGE DISTRIBUTION. IS IMPORTANT
OLDER VEHICLES TEND TO BE
HIGHER EMITTING- RECENT WORK
SHOWS. THAT MANY CONSTRUCTION.
VEHICLES ARE ALL THAN OF WE-
AND THE CONCERT DIRECT IN THE
AREAS. THE FLEET SIZE IS
IMPORTANT TOO BECAUSE THE OWNER
OPERATORS AND SMALL FLEETS
MIGHT FOCUS WE THINK ON UP
FRONT PURCHASE PRICES. OF ZIV
TO A GREATER DEGREE THAN SAY
THE TOTAL COST OF OWNERSHIP OF
THE LIFE THE EAGLES SLUDGE
FLEETS MIGHT CALCULATE AND THE
SMALLER FLEETS MAY FEEL PRICED
OUT OF THE MARKET. ACTIVITY
PATTERNS OF THE VEHICLES ARE
ALSO PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT FOR
EXAMPLE WHETHER THEY RETURNED.
TO BASE AT NIGHT OR EVEN DURING
THE DAY. IT WOULD CASE IT FOR.
ON SITE OR HOME BASE BUSINESS
ON ROAD CHARGING AND REFUELLING.
AND THE CAR DOORS IN THE
COMMUNITIES IN SWEET KIND OF
HEARD THESE VEHICLES TRAVELS
THROUGH AND THE RESULTING AIR
QUALITY AND HEALTH IMPACTS CAN
HAVE IMPORTANT ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE AND- PUBLICATIONS. SO
CALIFORNIA HAS ABOUT SEVENTY
THOUSAND MILES- INDEPENDENT
OWNER OPERATORS THEY OPERATE
PRIMARILY CLASS AGE WELL IT'S
TRUCKS THEY HAVE A MEDIAN NET
INCOME OF FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS. CALIFORNIA PORTS ARE
ALSO KNOWN TO RELY HEAVILY ON
SMALL FLEET AN OWNER OPERATOR-
VEHICLES SO HEAVY DUTY SAID
POLICIES REALLY NEED TO
RECOGNIZE THE POTENTIAL
ECONOMIC IMPACT. ON SMALL
FLEET'S WHICH ARE AN IMPORTANT
WORKFORCE STATEMENT TO AVOID
POTENTIALLY PRICING THEM OUT OF
THE SECTOR OR CREATING NEW
BARRIERS TO ENTRY WHEN THERE'S
ALREADY A SHORTAGE OF EVERY
DUTY AND DRAPES DRIVERS. WELL
ACTUALLY THE IDEAS OF MINE- WE
CONDUCTED RECENTLY A SMALL WITH
VERY DETAILED SURVEY OF TWENTY
FLEETS FROM SMALL TO LARGE IN
SIZE ACROSS VARIOUS LOCATIONS.
AND IDENTIFIED NUMEROUS FACTORS
INFLUENCING THE ADOPTION OF.
FUEL HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES
INCLUDING BATTERY ELECTRIC AND
FUEL CELL. THE PURPOSE OF THE
SURVEY WAS TO ACT AS A PILOT TO
DEVELOP A THEORY OF FLEET FUEL
ADOPTION BEHAVIOR AS A
PRECURSOR TO A MUCH LARGER
SURVEY. WE DOING THIS SUMMER IN
ORDER TO FORECASTING MODEL IF
YOU DESERVE. ADOPTION THE FACT
IS THAT EMERGED NOT IN ORDER OF
IMPORTANCE INCLUDED TECHNOLOGY
CHARACTERISTICS SUCH AS THE
AVAILABILITY AND SUITABILITY OF.
AS IN EAGLE IS THE REASON ONE
OF THE AVAILABLE FOR THE
FUNCTION OF THE SENATE NEEDS.
OF THE TOTAL COST OF OWNERSHIP
WHICH IS PURCHASE PRICE
OPERATING MAINTENANCE COSTS
RESELL VALUE. THE FUEL CRISIS
AND INFRASTRUCTURE. THERE WERE
SEVERAL ORGANIZATIONAL
CHARACTERISTICS THAT EMERGE ONE
WAS ENVIRONMENTAL CONSCIOUSNESS
ONE MIGHT CALL IT. A NUMBER OF
FANS WHO GENERALLY INTERESTED
IN GREEN TECHNOLOGIES FOR BOTH
SOCIETAL AS WELL AS BUSINESS
REASONS. SOME FIRMS ALSO
EXPRESSED A RELUCTANCE TO MOVE
TO THE NEWER DESERVES HAVING
ALREADY COMMITTED SIGNIFICANT
RESOURCES. TWO ONE FUEL SUCH AS
NATURAL GAS COMPRESSED NATURAL
GAS WAS PARTICULAR CASE IN
POINT IN THAT MIGHT DELAY THEIR
CONVERSION TO OTHER. GOOGLE'S
THIS WELL. SO LET ME JUST WRAP
UP IN CONCLUSION I'D LIKE TO
SUGGEST WE STILL HAVE MANY
UNCERTAINTIES IN DATA GAPS THAT
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED AND THESE
INCLUDE- WITH A SPECIFIC
SEGMENTS OF THE HDV SECTOR
SHOULD BE PRIORITIZED FOR
INCENTIVES WITH THE BATTERY
ELECTRIC OR FUEL CELL WHICH
ONES AND WE'VE HEARD ABOUT YOUR
AGE IN PARTICULAR BEING A
PRIORITY ONE. THE END WAS WHAT
OBJECTIVES GREENHOUSE GASES
REDUCTION- CRITERIA POLLUTANTS
PUBLIC HEALTH STATEWIDE OR MORE
LOCAL FOCUS SECTIONS AROUND THE
PORTS IN PARTICULAR AND
DISADVANTAGED AREAS CONSIDERING
THE WORK FORCE IMPACTS AND THE
EQUITY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ISSUES. WHAT OF
REGULATIONS AND INCENTIVES TO
USE. WE ALSO NEED A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING I BELIEVE IT
REDUCES THE PURCHASE DECISION
MAKING BY PLEADS AND HAVING
TOOLS TO. BETTER PREDICT ZIV
MARKET PENETRATION YVOLUTION
THREE TWENTY FIFTY. HELLO WE'LL
SMALL FLEETS AND OWNER
OPERATORS BE IMPACT IMPACTED
AND WILL THEY REACT DIFFERENTLY
FROM LARGER FLEETS. WE KNOW
THAT SAID TECHNOLOGY AND COST
SKEPTICAL THRUSTER OF SLOWER
THAN EXPECTED SO WE REALLY NEED
REGULAR REASSESSMENT ALL SEASON
PROGRESS TOWARD TARGETS. AND A
FINAL POINT IS HOW WILL HEAVY
DUTY FLEET ELECTRIFICATION AND
CHARGING IMPACT- INCREASINGLY
DECARBONISE ELECTRIC GRIDS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WILL THIS
AFFECT THE TOTAL COOPERATION.
CERTAIN THE TOTAL COST OF
OPERATION OKAY WE DO DESERVES
AND- IN WHAT FASHION BECAUSE
THAT COULD BE QUITE SIGNIFICANT.
IN TERMS OF PURCHASE DECISIONS.
NONE- IN MY COMMENTS THERE
THANKS I'M SORRY ABOUT THE
ZOOM- THAT IS THE CLEANING UP.
THANK YOU PROFESSOR RICHIE WE
APPRECIATE THAT- NEXT WE HAVE
MEREDITH ALEXANDER POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR CAL START WELCOME
IS ALEXANDER. NO YOU CAN'T GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CAN YOU HEAR ME OK NOW.
YES WE CAN. OKAY GREAT TRYING
TO GET THE SENDS FLETCHER MODE.
I'M JUST GIVE ME ONE SECOND
WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING ME HERE THIS AFTERNOON.
AND I THINK HOPEFULLY I'M GOING
TO COMPLEMENT A LOT OF THE
THINGS YOU'VE HEARD TODAY AND
TRY TO DROP AND CONNECTIONS.
BETWEEN VARIOUS SPEAKERS AND
TOPICS THAT THEY'VE COVERED-
AND WE GET CAL START OUR AND
NUMBER BASED FIVE A ONE TWO
THREE. WE HAVE MEMBERS ALL
ACROSS THE G. CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION SPECTRUM FROM
VEHICLE MANUFACTURERS TO
PUBLICLY. TECHNOLOGY PROVIDERS.
ETCETERA AND SO I CULTURE WE
REALLY ADVOCATE FOR AS-
PROFESSOR RICH YOU JUST ALLUDED
AN ECOSYSTEM APPROACH TO
POLICY. AND WE'VE HEARD TODAY
ABOUT OUR EXTREMELY AMBITIOUS
GOALS AND WHAT THE CARD IS
DOING ON THE REGULATORY SIDE TO
ADVANCE THEIR EMISSION
VEHICLES- AND YOU KNOW WE ARE.
LOOKING AT. CHANGE FOR THIS
MARK AND I WANTED TO POINT OUT
AS- MY PROFESSOR RITCHIE ALSO
TO THIS IS A VERY COMPLEX
SEGMENT- A LOT OF. THESE
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS TODAY
HAVE DEALT WITH LIGHT DUTY
VEHICLES. INTENDED FOR LIGHT
DUTY VEHICLES AND CHARGERS-
WHICH OF COURSE HELP START
THINGS ARE INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT- BUT WANTED TO TALK
ABOUT THIS VERY DIVERSE SEGMENT
AND SAY THAT. WE CERTAINLY DO
NOT PREDICT THAT WE WILL NOT
NEED AND SENATE HAVE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. FOR THE MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY SECTOR- WHAT CARVING
HELP START HAVE LAID OUT HERE
IS THIS THEORY OF CHANGE ABOUT
WIENER. OF MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY AND OFF ROAD VEHICLES. AND
THAT WE ARE TRANSITIONING IN
DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF THE WAY
IN. THE EARLY MOVERS TO THOSE
THAT ARE GOING TO BE MORE
COMPLICATED ON THE RIGHT END.
OF THE SPECTRUM LIKE LONG HAUL
TRUCKS. THAT WOULD THIS IS
REALLY AND WE SEE THAT THERE
WILL BE A NEED FOR ANY KIND OF
FOR A LONG TIME- AND WE ARE
GONNA NEED TO WALK AND CHEW GUM
AT THE SAME TIME TO COMPLETELY
TRANSFORM THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR I'M NOT GONNA SPEAK
ABOUT EACH OF THESE. FOR THE
SAKE OF TIME BUT THERE ARE SO
MANY DIFFERENT ELEMENTS THAT
THE STATE NEEDS TO FOCUS ON-
I'M- YOU KNOW. EQUITY AND WHEN
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE RIGHT
ROLE OF INCENTIVES- AND
PROVIDING ALL CALIFORNIANS WITH
ACCESS TO CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
AND CLEARING. THE AIR IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. BUT I DO WANT TO
FOCUS ON THE LAST ONE WHICH IS
THAT WE DO IDENTIFY THAT THE
INITIAL PURCHASE PRICE OF THE
VEHICLE. AND THE INFRASTRUCTURE
COSTS IT'S STILL THE NUMBER ONE
BARRIER. HE THEN ADOPTING A
CULTURE. AND THAT WE REALLY
THINK THAT WE NEED THE STATE TO
BACK UP YOUR. GOALS AND
REGULATORY. THIS MS ALEXANDER.
CAN YOU GO RIGHT AHEAD. WE CAN
I THINK EVERYTHING IS FINE ON
OUR END. SHE GOT ON OUR END.
OKAY NOW IT LOOKS LIKE YOU'RE
MUTED YES I'M BACK ON COMPUTER
AUDIO I'M SO SORRY THAT WERE
SILENT ON THE PHONE FOR HOURS
AND IT DECIDED TO CUT OUT RIGHT
IN THE MIDDLE OF MY
PRESENTATION AND THAT WAS OUR
DAY WE'RE SORRY ABOUT. THE
RIGHT. HI ALWAYS FUN EXAM- SO I
THINK WHAT I WAS SAYING IS THAT
WE NEED THE STATE TO BACK UP
OUR ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES WITH
FUNDING. MOST NEEDED IS TO SEND
A SIGNAL TO THE INDUSTRY THAT'S
BRINGING THESE VEHICLES FOR
MARKET. SHARE ON ON THE BEACH
HEAD SIDE. THAT FUNDING BE OF
THE AND THEREFORE DEMAND WILL
BE THERE IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
REALLY DRIVEN THIS MARKET
ESPECIALLY FOR MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES I THINK YOU'VE
ALSO HEARD WE'VE DRIVEN THIS
MARKET FOR LIGHT DUTY VEHICLES.
AND IF MANUFACTURERS ARE GOING
TO CONTINUE RAMPING UP THE
MODELS THAT THEY MAKE AVAILABLE
AND COUNTING ON INCREASED SALES
VOLUME IN CALIFORNIA WE NEED
PREDICTABILITY AND CONSISTENCY
IN VEHICLE INCENTIVES. SO YOU
KNOW WHERE WE WERE WITH EACH
BANK IS WE HAVEN'T HAD. SINCE
OCTOBER OF TWENTY NINETEEN SO
YOU KNOW WE'VE SEEN DRAMATIC
DECREASE IN- PURCHASES AND
ORDERS IN CALIFORNIA AND AGAIN
WE WANT MANUFACTURERS TO RAMP
UP THEIR PRODUCTION THAT'S
REALLY THAN SENDING WRONG
MESSAGE. AND WE TRULY BELIEVE
THAT IF WE CAN GET TO
INCREASING VOLUMES COSTS WILL
COME DOWN SALES WILL GO OUT AND
OVER TIME WE CAN AS INSIDE
FRANCISCO FROM. ONE SEGMENT
MEDIUM AND HEAVY MARKET TO. SO
THIS IS STAR MODEL AND IS FREE
PANDEMIC I'M THEY WANTED TO
AGAIN THAT IN TWENTY TO THE
BUDGET FOR DUTY INCENTIVE WAS
NO. AND THE PHONE RAN OUT. ALL
TO NINETEEN. I'M AND SO. OF
CHANGE IS WE SEE. VEHICLE OF.
WHICH MEANS. DEMAND FOR. IS
GOING TO RAMP UP. OVER THE-
FIVE TO SIX YEARS. AND THEN THE
OF BEING IN A THIS IS CAL STAR.
NOT NOT THE CARD PROJECTION-
THESE ARE OBVIOUS IDEAL. BY AS
WE TO HIT TIPPING AND MARKETS
TANK WE COULD DECREASE IN AND-
FOR THOSE THE CLASS. IN THE
PHASE THEM OUT. INSIDERS WILL
THEN BE A- TO VEHICLE TYPE THAT
AREN'T. TODAY SUCH AS LONG HAUL
TRUCK- AND MARMI DUTY WORK
TRUCKS LIKE FORD F. TWO FIFTY
THREE FIFTY IS THE WORLD AREN'T.
YET AVAILABLE. NUMBER EXACT.
MANUFACTURERS AND SUPPLIERS IN
THE STATE AND WE SEE A LOT OF
SMALL AND MEDIUM SIZED
BUSINESSES IN THIS SPACE I'M
THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY UNIQUE
COMPANIES. I THINK THIS IS A
REALLY POSITIVE MESSAGE SB.
OVERLOOKS CITED A GREAT JOB
TALKING ABOUT ALL THE AMAZING
BENEFITS WE WILL GET FROM THIS
TRANSITION. AND WE THINK
CONTINUED JOB GROWTH IN
CALIFORNIA. WILL CERTAINLY BE
ONE THING. SO REALLY QUICKLY
I'M- NOT GONNA GO THERE
ACTUALLY. REALLY QUICKLY
TURNING TO INFRASTRUCTURE FOR A
MOMENT. WE'VE TALKED A LOT
ABOUT INFRASTRUCTURE TODAY-
COMMITTEE ON ALASKA REALLY
GREAT QUESTIONS I WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT. THE MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY INFRASTRUCTURE SIDE
IS REALLY BEHIND LIGHT DUTY.
I'M CUSTOMERS THAT COSTS FOR
ESPECIALLY CHARGING FOR HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES ARE REALLY
SIGNIFICANT THEY CAN BE FIFTY
TO A 100% THE VEHICLE COST. AND
THE CDC IS COMMITTED OVER THE
NEXT FEW YEARS TO PUTTING A
HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION INTO
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S FROM THE
CUSTOMER SIDE PROGRAMS. AND IF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED TRAILER
BILL IS APPROVED THEY'LL PUT IN
ANOTHER FIVE HUNDRED MILLION.
WE THINK THIS SENDS A REALLY
STRONG SIGNAL TO THE INDUSTRY-THAT THE STATE WILL BACK THEM
UP ESPECIALLY FOR EARLY
ADOPTERS. AND WE ARE DEFINITELY
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS IDEA OF
HAVING A LONG TERM. FUNDING
SOURCE FOR INFRASTRUCTURE WERE
ALSO VERY HAPPY THAT THE QC HAS
AUTHORIZED THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES THE POINT I'M
SIGNIFICANT INVESTOR. UTILITY
FUNDS ONTO THE DISTRIBUTION
GRID TO PROVIDE THE UPGRADES
NEEDED FOR THESE VEHICLES. BUT
I DO WANT TO SAY THAT WE THINK
IT'S QUITE IMBALANCED HOW LONG
TERM FUNDING PLAN OR AT LEAST A
PROPOSAL THAT WE HOPE WILL BE
ADOPTED FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDING WITHOUT A CORRESPONDING
LONG TERM PLAN OR EVEN JUST
THREE YEAR PLAN FOR VEHICLE
INCENTIVE FUNDING FOR THE
SECTOR SO. I'LL START WOULD
LOVE TO SEE THE LEGISLATURE ARM.
TAKE ACTION THERE. YEAH THE
LAST COUPLE I WAS TO TALK WORK
FOR. AND WE ARE. SUPPORTIVE OF
FINDING FINANCING SOLUTIONS FOR
THE SWEETS ESPECIALLY SMALL AND
PUBLICLY YOU'RE REALLY GONNA
NEED. WRAPAROUND FUNDING EVEN
IF THEY GET THAT EACH WITHOUT
SURE THEY STILL NEED TO BORROW.
A COUPLE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO BUY ZERO EMISSION
HEAVY DUTY TRUCK. WE'D LOVE TO
SEE PROGRAMS LIKE HOW CAP
EXPANDS SO THAT THEY CAN SERVE
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
PURCHASERS. AND WORKING WITH
NRDC WE WOULD LOVE TO SEE
BUYERS BE ABLE TO LEVERAGE
THEIR FUTURE SAVINGS AND
REVENUE STREAMS FOR THOSE LINES.
I'MAND THEN ON. I DID WANT TO
SAY THAT. YOU KNOW WE THINK
EVERY CALIFORNIAN DRIVING THEIR
OWN ELECTRIC VEHICLE ISN'T
REALLY SHOULDN'T REALLY BE THE
GOAL- BUT EVERY CALIFORNIAN
BREATHING CLEAN AIR. AND HAVING
ACCESS TO CONVENIENCE IN ZERO
EMISSION CHOICES FOR MOBILITY.
AND WHETHER THAT'S A BUSCA BIKE
WEARING E. V. IS A GREAT CALL.
THERE'S NO ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH I AM AND CLEARING THE
AIR IN OUR COMMUNITIES BY
CONVERTING TRUCK AND BUS
FLEETS. IS DEFINITELY BRINGING
EQUITY. I'M NOT SURE RAN
MENTIONED THIS WELL THE NEW
CLEAN UP OFF PROGRAM WITHIN
IT'S A GREAT EXAMPLE OF HOW THE
STATE. CAN SUPPORT PRIORITY
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE IT ELEVATES
THE ROLE THAT THEY PLAY. AND
ALLOWS THEM TO TAKE THE LEAD IN
ADDRESSING THEIR PARTICULAR
LOCAL TRANSPORTATION ISSUES.
AND FINDING SOLUTIONS THAT WORK
FOR THEM- SO THESE ARE ALL THE
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE APPLIED
FOR FUNDING UNDER THIS PROGRAM
THERE'S BEEN. REALLY HIGH
DEMANDS WHICH WE THINK IS
EXTREMELY POSITIVE- THE
NEGATIVE SIDE OF THAT IS THAT
ALSO. CMO I'M IN THE SUITE OF
CARDS EQUITY PROGRAMS USUALLY
GETS. A ONE YEAR APPROPRIATION.
I THINK LAST YEAR ABOUT A ONE
TIME APPROPRIATION FROM SAN.
EARLIER YEAR FUNDS IN SEVERAL
ALSO YOU'RE ONLY BEING FUNDED
BY G. JURASSIC IS NOT
NECESSARILY. UNSUSTAINABLE AND
WE THINK THERE SHOULD BE OTHER
SOURCES OF FUNDING PUT INTO
REALLY CRITICAL CLEAN ABILITY
PROGRAMS LIKE SAM ALL. BUT
WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF. THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR
EQUITY AND WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
SEE MORE FUNDING INTO EQUITY
PROGRAMS THAT PROGRAMS LIKE
THIS CAN EXPAND. I THINK GIVEN
THE TIME IN THE EVENING I WON'T
STOP THERE AND HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS AFTER THANK YOU MS
ALEXANDER WE APPRECIATE THAT
AND WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE AND FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
AND OUR FINAL WITNESSES BILL
MCGOVERN POLICY DIRECTOR WITH
THE COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR. A
WELCOME AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE MISTER MCGOVERN. THANK
YOU SHARES AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. FOR INVITING ME HERE
TODAY THE REGULATORY AGENCIES
THAT YOU'VE HEARD FROM HAVE
BEEN IMPLEMENTING PREVIOUS
STATUTORY DIRECTIVES FROM THE
LEGISLATURE AND I THINK WHAT
THE LEGISLATURE CAN MOST HELP
WITH. NOW IS TO BRIDGE THAT
FINANCIAL GAP. AND SPEED THE
DEPLOYMENT OF CLEAN CARS TRUCKS
AND BUSES WITH A PARTICULAR
FOCUS ON THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE HISTORICALLY DISADVANTAGED
AND LOW INCOME. WE CAME
TOGETHER WITH OUR PARTNERS IN
THE CHARGING A CALIFORNIA
CAMPAIGN IN TWENTY FOURTEEN AND
SPONSORED SENATE BILL TWELVE
SEVENTY FIVE WHICH MADE IT
STATE POLICY TO ELECTRIFY THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR IN A
MANNER THAT ENSURES THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY THOSE
MOST IMPACTED BY VEHICULAR AIR
POLLUTION CAN REALIZE THE
BENEFITS THAT ELECTRIC VEHICLES
CAN PROVIDE. AND LARGELY AS A
RESULT OF THAT LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA HAS A RICH PORTFOLIO
WELL UTILIZED EQUITY FOCUSED
PROGRAMS DESIGNED TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES AND MOBILITY IN
DISADVANTAGED AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES ARE INCLUDING
SOMETHING THAT YOU'VE HEARD
ABOUT. ALREADY TODAY ALL THOSE
PROJECTS ARE ARE OVERSUBSCRIBED
AND OUR OLD EITHER OUT OF
FUNDING FOR ALMOST OUT OF
FUNDING. KNOWS LIGHT DUTY
VEHICLE PROGRAMS ARE
COMPLEMENTED BY A CRITICAL ZERO
EMISSION MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLE PROGRAMS THAT REDUCE
TOXIC DIESEL EMISSIONS THAT WE
KNOW DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
THAT ARE OFTEN DOWNWIND
FREEWAYS CHORDS RAILYARDS
WAREHOUSES AND OTHER. GOODS
MOVEMENT FACILITIES. SO
THEREFORE WE- THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PUT INTO LAW EQUITY
REQUIREMENTS THAT WOULD ASSURE
THAT AT LEAST HALF OF THE
ENERGY COMMISSION SCREEN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM USED TO
SUPPORT TRANSPORTATION
ELECTRIFICATION THE PRIMARY
BENEFIT OF OR PRIMARILY SERVING
RESIDENTS OF DISADVANTAGED OR
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES. OF FOR
EXAMPLE BY PROVIDING THE
CHARGING IN MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING WHICH IS BEEN DIFFICULT
TO AS WELL AS DISCUSSED EARLIER.
WE ALSO RECOMMEND THATAT LEAST
HALF OF THOSE PROJECTS. SB
ASSOCIATED CHARGING AND
REFUELING STATIONS LOCATED IN
DISADVANTAGED LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND THAT NO LESS
THAN 30% OF THE PROJECT SUPPORT
ZERO MISSION MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES. AND THAT
INCLUDES BOTH BATTERY ELECTRIC
VEHICLES AND HYDROGEN FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC VEHICLES I THANK
CENTER ARCHULETA WE'RE WAITING
OUT THE IMPORTANCE OF HYDROGEN.
THE GOVERNOR'S REQUESTED A
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE TRANSPORTATION EQUITY
PROJECTS WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THAT RAISE TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS- BECAUSE THESE ARE THE
PROGRAMS THAT EXPAND THE
BENEFITS OF CLEAN MOBILITY TO
ALL CALIFORNIA. AND THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD ESTIMATES THE
NEED AT A HUNDRED NINETY TO TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT MILLION SO
ACTUALLY OUR REQUEST IS ON THE
LOW END THAT- AND WE SUPPORT
APPROVAL OF AT LEAST. THE
GOVERNOR'S REQUEST OF THREE
HUNDRED FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
FOR CLEAN TRUCKS BUSES AND OFF
ROAD EQUIPMENT THERE ARE
EMITTING THAT TOXIC DIESEL
EXHAUST THAT IS PARTICULARLY
BURDENING COMMUNITIES OF COLOR-
WE ALSO ASK FOR A RE
AUTHORIZATION OF THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION AND AIR QUALITY.
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM THAT WAS
LAST AUTHORIZED UNDER AB EIGHT
BECAUSE IT PROVIDES INCENTIVES
TO SUPPORT INNOVATION AND
ACCELERATE THE DEPLOYMENT AND
DEVELOPMENT FINANCE
TRANSPORTATION TECHNOLOGIES AND
FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE. AND WE
DO SUPPORT THE SECURITIZATION
OF A BILLION DOLLARS OF THE
FUTURE REVENUES TO SUPPORT THE
EXPANSION OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE
AS WE DISCUSSED TODAY. THOSE
POSITIONS THAT I JUST LAID OUT
ARE ENDORSED BY SO FAR TWENTY
THREE GROUPS FROM ENVIRONMENTAL
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND
HEALTH AND LABOR ORGANIZATIONS.
AND I WANT TO ADD ON BEHALF OF
THE COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF POLICY
BILLS THAT WE'RE SUPPORTING
THAT WOULD ALSO HELP VERY MUCH
WITH JEFF DEPLOYMENTS ABOUT
YOUR GONZALEZ OF COURSE AS
SENATE BILL SEVEN TWENTY SIX TO
RE AUTHORIZE THE GREEN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM. THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF BILLS TO MAKE
ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS MORE
AFFORDABLE INCLUDING SB THREE
SEVENTY TWO BY CENTER LEYVA SB
FIVE FORTY TWO BY CENTER WE'VE
GROWN AND AB ELEVEN TEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROBERT RIVAS-
WHEN IT COMES TO CARS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY HAS AB TWELVE
EIGHTEEN. WHICH WOULD PROVIDE
SOME MORE FUNDING FOR- FOR
CLEAN CARS AND MIGHT IN FACT BE
ABLE TO SUPPLY SOME OF THAT
NEED THAT HAS IN THE PAST BEEN
SERVED. BY THE CLEAN VEHICLE
REBATE PROJECT. WE ALSO NEED
TO- MAKE IT EASIER TO PERMIT.
THE CHARGING STATIONS SOME OF
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
ACTUALLY NOT OBSERVING CURRENT
STATE LAW AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY.
WOULD SPEED UP THAT PROCESS OF
GETTING THAT URGING STATIONS
DEPLOYED. AND FINALLY CENTER
MEN WHO I HAVE TO THANK FOR
STAYING ON THE ZOOM- ALL THE
WAY PAST FIVE O'CLOCK. AS AN
EXCELLENT BILL SB FIVE HUNDRED.
WHICH WOULD GUARANTEE THAT ALL
AUTOMATED VEHICLES BE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES SO- THAT'S
THE ONE OTHER ONE THAT WE-
IMMENSELY YOU. AND US SINCE I
AM THE LAST SPEAKER ON FRIDAY
AFTERNOON I WILL CLOSE THERE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR MCGOVERN WE-APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR YOUR
WORK WITH US AS WELL. THANK YOU
OKAY NOW IF- FINALIZE OUR LAST
PANEL WE WANT TO THANK ALL OF
THE WITNESSES FOR PARTICIPATING
AT THIS VERY LATE OUR ON A
FRIDAY SO WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE- WE'RE GONNA GO TO
MEMBER QUESTIONS AND FIRST WE
HAVE SENATOR ALAN AND THEN
WE'LL GO TO SENATOR MCCASKEY.
YEAH I SUPPOSE THIS IS MERRY
FOR THE WHOLE PANEL BUT MAYBE
IF IT LET'S START WITH WITH THE
MISS ALEXANDER. I LOVE YOU JUST
GET A BETTER SENSE OF AND WHAT
SORT OF- DASHBOARD WHAT WOULD
WHAT SORT OF- OF STATS WE ARE
GONNA BE COLLECTING AND THEN
EVALUATING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE PROGRAMS ARE. ARE ARE A
REALLY AND SHOWING. YOU KNOW
SHOWING SHOWING REAL BANG FOR
BUCK- YOU KNOW. YOU KNOW
THERE'S LOOK AT YOUR SOME OF
THE PROJECTS A MILLION DOLLARS
FOR A- IN A BIKE SHARE PROGRAM
SOMETHING LIKE THAT I MEAN THE
ALL SOUNDS ALL SOUNDS GREAT BUT
HOW ARE WE HOW ARE WE REALLY
ENSURING. THAT THESE ARE THESE
ARE BEING UTILIZED BY FOLKS AND
REALLY MAKING A DIFFERENCE IN
IN. IN IN EASING PEOPLE TOWARD
CLEANER TRANSPORTATION. THANK
YOU SENATOR ALAN ARE YOU
REFERRING SPECIFICALLY TO
PROGRAMS LIKE CMO OR WOULD YOU
LIKE ME TO COMMENT SORT OF ON
METRICS OVERALL. YEAH SHOULD
LOVE I LOVE BOTH AND- BECAUSE
ESPECIALLY IF THEY AND THEY SIT
HERE AND I SORT OF THINK TO
MYSELF. YOU KNOW WE HAVE WE'RE
SO WE HAVE WE HAVE WE HAVE SUCH
A- SUBPAR PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM WHEN YOU COMPARE US TO.
THE NEW YORKER OR OR AND OR
EUROPE CERTAINLY OR JAPAN- YOU
KNOW. POLICY WHEN WE LIVE WHERE
WE ARE PUTTING MONEY THROUGH SB
ONE ANOTHER'S IN INTO THAT IN
THAT SYSTEM BUT BUT- YOU KNOW I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WITH
ALL THESE INVESTMENTS REALLY
ARE MAKING A DIFFERENCE- AND I
AND ARE WE STUDYING B. THE DATA
AND ARE AND ARE WE- BEEN
CHANGING OUR- OUR- OUR- YOU
KNOW OUR OUR OUR TRAJECTORY
BASED ON THE DATA SO YES I'D
LOVE THAT BOTH THE MACRO AND
THE MICRO. PERSPECTIVE ON ON
NOT. GREAT I'LL TRY TO BRIEFLY
SPEAK ABOUT AND SEE IF ANY OF
MY OTHER NGO COLLEAGUES HAVE
THOUGHTS THAT OFTEN EQUITY ON I
THINK SOME IMPORTANT. IMPORTANT
METRICS ARE OBVIOUSLY WE WANT
TO BE REDUCING THE ANTI WHICH
IS A TREND WE HAVE NOT YET
ACHIEVED IN CALIFORNIA AND SO
GLOBAL CAN DOWN NECK. HOW CAN
WE MAINTAIN YOU KNOW THE
REDUCTIONS IN BMT AND DIFFERENT
WAYS. AND WE'RE GOING TO SEE
PEOPLE JUST RETURNED TO THE USE
OF SINGLE OCCUPANCY
AUTOMOBILES- YOU SHOULD BE
TRACKING NOT VERY CLOSELY
COMING OUT OF THIS PANDEMIC.
AND ALSO LOOKING INTO THINGS
LIKE. ARE PEOPLE YOU KNOW
RETURNING TO PUBLIC TRANSIT
WHAT IS THEIR ACCESS TO TRANSIT
THERE ARE OTHER ORGANIZATIONS-
BESIDES CAL START. MONITOR
THESE THINGS VERY CLOSELY- AND
AGAIN ARE ARE. PEOPLE USING
LAST OF THEIR DAHLE YOU KNOW
TAKE HOME PAY ON TRANSPORTATION
WE KNOW THAT. LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS THEY NOT ONLY
DISPROPORTIONATELY FOR HOUSING
BUT BECAUSE THEY'RE LIVING
FURTHER AWAY FROM THEIR JOBS
THEY'RE SPENDING MORE DOLLARS-
THERE IN. PERCENTAGE OF THEIR
INCOME ON TRANSPORTATION SO I
WOULD SAY A COUPLE OF THOSE
METRICS ARE CRITICAL AND WE ARE
TRACKING VERY CLOSELY THE
NUMBER OF ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES AND CHARGERS AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
ACTUALLY PAYING. AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES WERE PRETTY MUCH ON
TRACK WITH THE NUMBER OF
CHARGERS FOR CAPITAL. AND N. H.
BETTER BY CHAIR RANDALL SHARED
THAT ALMOST TWO THIRDS OF THE
DOLLARS HAVE BEEN SPENT IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WHICH
MEANS THAT THERE ARE CLEANER
VEHICLES ON THOSE ROADS. AND WE
THINK THIS CLEAN VEHICLES MILES
TRAVELED IS A REALLY CRITICAL
METRIC I'M IN THE MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY SECTOR. I'M AND THEN
OTHER METRICS WE CAN THINK OF
IN TERMS OF HOW ARE WE DOING
OBVIOUSLY WE NEED CHEERING I'M
CONFIDENT CAR WILL DO THIS
TRACK CLOSELY THE NUMBER OF
DEPLOYMENTS IN EACH VEHICLE
CLASS. AND HOW ARE THOSE PRICES
FOR THESE VEHICLES COMING DOWN
AS WE SAID AS WE HIT THESE
MILESTONES. AND IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT THE INITIAL PURCHASE
PRICE BUT WE'RE ALL VERY
FOCUSED ON THE TOTAL COST OF
OWNERSHIP. AND WHEN ARE WE
GONNA REACH. PARITY WITHIN HER
CLOSE TO BEING THERE. IN SOME
VEHICLE CLASSES AND YOU KNOW
BUT WE NEED TO BE CLOUT I AM
VERY CAREFULLY TRACKING THAT
METRIC IS THE RUMOR GOING TO
HIT THOSE CHECKING POINTS. OUT
SIMON OUR BELL- DOCTOR REACHING
HAVE OTHER COMMENTS ON ON THIS
QUESTION WELL I WOULD JUST ADD
THAT THE AUDIT THAT SENATOR
DOLLY REFERRED TO EARLIER DID
IDENTIFY THAT. THERE IS MORE
DATA THAT CARBS SHOULD BE
COLLECTING AND ANALYZING ABOUT
THE INCENTIVE PROGRAMS AND WE
AGREE THAT MORE DATA WOULD BE
HELPFUL. AS LONG AS IT DOESN'T
YOU KNOW VARGAS DOWN SO MUCH AN
ANALYSIS THAT WE STOP DOING
ANYTHING BUT CARP HAS COMMITTED
NOW TO GATHERING THAT DATA AND
SO I THINK THAT WILL. HELP
SENATOR. ALLEN TO GET WHAT
YOU'RE ASKING. GREAT THANK YOU
SENATOR- NAY WE HAVE DI. I
NEEDED. YOU CAN YOU KNOW WE CAN
HEAR YOU NOW THANK YOU ALL I
HAVE A REAL QUICK QUESTION I
WOULD JUST LIKE A- IF IT'S A
POSSIBLE TO HAVE ALL THOSE
PRESENTATIONS THAT WERE. A
SLIDE PRESENTATIONS THAT WERE
THAT WERE PRESENTED TODAY
AVAILABLE TO- THE SENATORS ARE
LEAST MYSELF I'D LIKE TO GO
OVER THOSE I WOULD I WOULD. WAS
REALLY INTERESTED IN THE HEAVY
DUTY- SLIDE THAT THE PROFESSOR
HAD- SINCE I'M IN THAT TRUCKING
BUSINESS AND I'M ONE OF THOSE
INDEPENDENT. TRUCKERS I'M
INTERESTED THAT INFORMATION SO
JUST AT GREAT JOB BY THE WAY
CENTER LINO THAT STAND UP THERE
ALL DAY. AFTER SHE DID STUFF
AND IF I COULD JUST GET THAT
INFORMATION BE HELPFUL THANK
YOU ABSOLUTELY SENATOR THANK
YOU- AND I HAVE JUST ONE
QUESTION AND THEN WE'LL TURN IT
OVER TO PUBLIC. COMMENT I KNOW
THINK MS ALEXANDER YOU HAD IN
YOUR SLIDES THAT. MEDIUM HEAVY
DUTY COSTS 32323100% MORE- YOU
HAD IT N A TIME LINE IT LOOKS
LIKE AND I'M JUST TRYING TO SEE
IF. THIS IS ACCURATE IT LIKE
MAYBE IT TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT TIMELINE IN
TERMS OF- CAN YOU CLARIFY THAT
OTHER SIDE THERE WAS ANOTHER
SIDE THAT HAD A TIMELINE ON
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT. YEAH I THINK
YOU'RE REFERRING TO A GRAPH I
SHARED THAT WAS CAL START SORT
OF MODELING- INCENTIVE FUNDING.
YES THEY CAN PULL THAT OFF THE
FRONT EIGHT THANK YOU KNOW MANY
CABBIE OUTS AROUND. LAKE THIS
IS A SMALL PART OF THE FUNDING
NEED THAT SIMON WAS ALLUDING
TO. AND THIS IS JUST INCENTIVES
WE KNOW. YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE
PROVIDING AN ARTIFICIAL CAP
HERE WE NOW THE DEMAND FOR EACH
SAMPLE PROBABLY FAR EXCEED.
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR. WE WERE YOU KNOW APPLYING
SOME ARTIFICIAL CAPS IN SAYING
THAT WE DIDN'T KNOW IF WE'D
EVER GET A BUDGET APPROPRIATION
THAT BIG BUT- WHAT WE'RE
SUGGESTING HERE IS THAT. WE
HOPE THERE ARE A LOT AND-
MEDIUM DUTY AND SOME HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLE CLASSES THAT ARE GOING
TO REACH THAT TCO PARITY.
SOMETIME YOU KNOW IN THE MIDDLE
THIS DECADE IF WE IF WE STAY ON
THAT TRAJECTORY. WE'RE AIMING
FOR AND THINGS I CAN DANCE
CLEAN TRUCK. SO WE COULD TAKE.
VANS I THANK. THAT WE- YOU KNOW
BY TWENTY FIVE WILL BE SEEN.
THANK VOLUMES OF DELIVERY VAN.
THEY WILL BECAUSE COMPETITIVE
WITH THEIR DIESEL. OR GASOLINE
COUNTERPARTS AND WE COULD
START. FOR EXAMPLE PHASING THEM
OUT OF EACH BED YOU KNOW TWO
CREASING DOLLARS. GIVEN
VEHICLES EVERY YEAR AND THEN
FREEING UP THOSE DOLLARS FOR
OTHER VEHICLE TYPES. AND SO
THAT IN THE LATTER PART OF THIS
DECADE WHEN ADVANCE CONTRACTS
IS REALLY RAMPING UP ACTUALLY
IN TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN. WE WILL
HAVE HOPEFULLY BROUGHT. THE
COST DOWN AND NOTHING DIFFERENT
VEHICLE CATEGORIES THAT WE CAN
PUT THOSE IN FRONT OF DOLLARS
INTO TRUCKS THAT ARE JUST
COMING TO THE MARKET IN THOSE
LATER YEARS. I'M AND NOT SWEAR
WE EXPECT TO SEE HOPEFULLY SOME
LONG HAUL YOU KNOW MODELS
REALLY PICKING UP AND FILLING
IN THAT GAP AND THEN ALSO
SEEING MORE. OF THOSE MEDIUM
DUTY. WORK TRUCKS BECOMING
AVAILABLE SO. AND SAY THERE IS
WILL NAY IN SOME. IN THE LATER
OF THE STAFF BUT HOPE FOR VIA
CLASSES. OKAY THANK YOU AND-
THIS IS I KNOW IT IS A TOTAL
CORRECT SAID WHAT IS THE PER
VEHICLE I THINK SENATOR
MCCASKEY BEEN ASKING ABOUT THE
PER VEHICLE TRAJECTORY. SO I
DON'T KNOW IF I'M DR RICHIE MAY
HAVE THAT. DATE ON THAT AS WELL
BUT FOR ANY EXAMPLE I HAD A
CLASS EIGHT. TRACTOR TRAILER
THAT IS COMING TO MARKET FROM
VOLVO OR DAIMLER WE EXPECT THE
INCREMENTAL COSTS TO BE BETWEEN
A DIESEL AND A ZERO EMISSION
BATTERY ELECTRIC TRUCK TO BE IN
THE REALM OF TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS. AND YOU KNOW
I DON'T HAVE A PREDICTION OF
WHEN BACK COST COMES DOWN BUT
WE KNOW THAT THIS SIGNIFICANT
COST DIFFERENCES ALSO DUE IN
PART TO THE FACT THAT THEY ARE
JUST NOW ENTERING PRODUCTION.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT MISS ALEXANDER I
APPRECIATE THAT- WONDERFUL I
DON'T SEE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM SENATORS AND I JUST WANT
TO CLARIFY THAT- THE
PRESENTATIONS ARE ALREADY UP-
ON OUR SENATE WEBSITE FOR
TRANSPORTATION HAVE TO THINK
KßT FOR THAT. SO THEY'RE
ALREADY UP AND DONE ALL RIGHT
WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND- MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THIS TIME. WE'RE
GOING TO JUST LOO FIRST TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANY WITNESSES HERE
IN THE GALLERY I SEE NONE
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE WE
SEE NONE- SO THANK YOU WILL
MOVE ON NOW TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT VIA TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS. MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT WE WILL BEGIN.
ABSOLUTELY AND LAYS IN GERMAN
ON THE PHONE LINE IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENTS
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. OPERATOR WILL ASSIGN YOU
A NUMBER AND THEN I WILL CALL
ON THAT NUMBER ONE READY FOR
YOUR COMMENTS AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENTS PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. AND AT THIS TIME- LOOKS
LIKE WE HAVE ABOUT SIXTEEN IN
THE QUEUE. OKAY LET'S START
WITH THE FIRST COMMENT PLEASE.
ABSOLUTELY WE WILL START WITH
LINE THIRTY EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
TEARS MEMBERS DANIEL BROUGHT ON
BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA. THE TESTIMONY DAY
HIGHLIGHTED THE GETTING TO A
100% THERE EMISSION VEHICLES
AND INSTALLING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO POWER THESE
VEHICLES ARE SCHEDULED TO SIGN
THE CLIMATE CRISIS IN CLEANING
OUR AIR. THE TESTIMONY ALSO
SHOWED TO BE NECESSARY CALLS
ARE GOING TO REQUIRE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT. THE
LEGISLATURE MUST MAKE BIG
INVESTMENTS RIGHT AWAY. FOR
EXAMPLE BY ADVANCING THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL TO EXTEND AND
SECURITIZED AB EIGHT SEEDS
WHICH ARE ACCELERATE THE
DEPLOYMENT OF ZERO EMISSION
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
ALLAYING CONSUMER RAGE ANXIETY
AND IN TURN ACCELERATING. ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE ADOPTION. THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD ALSO SUPPORT
THE YOUR KIDS EACH YEAR ASPEN
TO HELP REPLACE HEAVY DUTY
DIESEL ENGINE AND HELP
CALIFORNIANS GET INTO ELECTRIC
VEHICLES. FINALLY ALL THESE
INVESTMENTS MUST PRIORITIZE THE
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN MOST
IMPACTED BY TRANSPORTATION
RELATED POLLUTION. AS SUCH CAN
THE CHARGER HEAD
RECOMMENDATIONS OUTLINED BY
BILL GABBERT. I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU TO ADVANCE
EQUITABLE DETERMINATION
TRANSPORTATION IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I'LL JUST REMIND-
EVERYONE ON THE PUBLIC COMMENT
SIDE EVERYONE HAS ABOUT ONE
MINUTE SO WE'LL GO ON TO THE
NEXT. COMMENT PLEASE. THE NEXT
WILL MOVE TO NUMBER FIFTY SIX
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MICHAEL PIMENTEL
EXECUTOR AFTER THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION REPRESENTING
EIGHTY FIVE TRANSIT AGENCIES
ACROSS THE STATE. THAT
CALIFORNIA'S TRANSLATED THESE
HAVE BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT OF
YOUR MISSION BUCK DEPLOYMENT
NATIONWIDE. TODAY WE HAVE
APPROXIMATELY EIGHT HUNDRED
YOUR MISSION BUSES IN OPERATION
OR ON ORDER IN CALIFORNIA. ALL
OF THEM THEIR DIRECT RESULT OF
SPEED INTERNET AND WE'RE
BUILDING TOWARD A TRANSITION
WERE ALL BUSTED IN THE STATE
WILL BE ZERO EMISSION BY TWENTY
FORTY. CONSISTENT WITH THE
ARBY'S INNOVATIVE CLEAN TRANSIT
REGULATION. AS AN INDUSTRY
WOULD BENEFIT FROM A STRONG
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATE
WHICH OF COURSE HAS PROVIDED
THAT DIRECT FUNDING SUPPORT TO
TRANSIT AGENCIES THAT FUNDING
HAS ALSO CREATED A ROBUST
MANUFACTURING BASE FOR YOUR
MISSION BOXES IN CALIFORNIA
WE'VE GOT PEOPLE IDEA LANCASTER
GILLIGAN WILL DELIVER MORE.
GREEN POWER IN PORTER BILL
IMPROVE CARE IN THE CITY OF
INDUSTRY ALL OF THEM AGAIN
DIRECT BENEFITS FROM STATE
SUPPORT NO WE APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION BUT HAD TODAY
AROUND INCREASED COORDINATION
BETWEEN CITY AGENCIES WERE
ENCOURAGED THAT TO CONTINUE.
BUT WE DO WANT TO NOTE THAT
THERE ARE INDUSTRIES LIKE OURS
THAT HAVE SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM
TEMPLATE THAT WILL BENEFIT FROM
CONTINUED SUPPORT WITH THAT
I'LL JUST THE BOYS ARE SUPPORT
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION'S ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT INTERMISSION
VEHICLES AND INFRASTRUCTURE.
WITHIN THAT FUNDING WE ARE
ASKING FOR EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE THREE HUNDRED
AND FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
OUTLINE FOR YOUR MACHINE TRUCKS
BUSES OPERATE FOR TRANSIT
AGENCIES SPECIFICALLY THAT WILL
SUPPORT THE DEPLOYMENT OF FOUR
HUNDRED Q. FISCAL DURING
MISSION. THE NEW YORK. THANK
YOU VERY MICHAEL WE APPRECIATE
THAT. NEXT CALL PLEASE. WE WILL
NOW MOVE THE LINE FORTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- NINE STEPHEN THE
MANAGER THE MANAGER YOUR
ADVOCACY OF AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION- THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR CALIFORNIA'S LEADING
SOURCE OF HARMFUL AIR POLLUTION
AND DISBURSING TAXABLE INCOME
UNDERSTAND COMMUNITIES. FOR THE
FULL TIME THIS IS OUR MISSION
CARS TRUCKS BUSES EXACTLY
POSSIBLE. OBLIGATION MUST AGREE
ACTION ON TEACHER ALLOCATIONS
AND MAKING A COMMITMENT YOU CAN
BE THE CONCERN. EDITIONS
SUPPORT LETTERS PROPOSALS FOR
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION FOR
HEAVY. DUTY GERMISTON TRUCK.
AND NOT ABOUT THE COLLISION.
MEDICAL TO GERM TRANSPORTATION
THINK AROUND INCREASES A
MILLION. THE CONTINUOUS
SUPPORTER THE AUTHORED TO.
INCREASE PROGRAM FUND TO INVEST
ONE BILLION IN SHELTER. IF YOU
THAT BOTH OF US. EMISSIONS HAVE
INFRASTRUCTURE THE BUYER
PRIORITY TO A PHARMACY THE
AMONG. AND THERE SHOULD BE A
KLEENEX AND THE TRANSPORTATION
TO. A QUALITY FORM OF TECH PPD.
THANK YOU VERY. THANK YOU NEXT
COME PLEASE. WELL NOW GO TO
NUMBER FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JUSTIN AND
I AND I WAS OF ST PIETRO WHICH-
IN- IN THE HARBOR AT THE PORT
OF LA- I JUST WANTED Q. PUSH MY
DEPARTURE MORE INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR HYDROGEN CHART AND
CHARGING- COOPER. AND FOR
PERSONAL VEHICLES AND OFTEN FOR
THE TRACKING- WE ARE EIGHT FEW
LEGAL HOUSEHOLDS- WE ONE OF OUR
VEHICLES AS ELECTRIC AND THE
OTHER ITS HYDROGEN LEARNED THAT
THE ELECTRIC GREAT BUT THERE
ARE A LOT OF THE DAMAGES OF
HIGHER EDUCATION ESPECIALLY. IF
YOU LIVE FAR AWAY FROM WHERE
YOU WORK AS WE DO SO AM I JUST
WANTED TO- EXPRESSING SUPPORT
FOR THAT AND ALSO ENCOURAGE-
ANYTHING WE CAN DO. TO CLEAN UP
THAT. US AIR QUALITY THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU SIX COMMENT.
NEXT WE'RE GOING TO NUMBER
SIXTY THREE PLEASE AHEAD. ONE
CHAIR MEMBERS AND YOUR HANDS WE
HEAR TODAY ON FIVE PANTS ON
BEHALF OF ADVANCED ENERGY
ECONOMY OR NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION. OF ADVANCED
ENERGY- BUSINESSES- WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT- THE FOCUS ON CLEAN UP
FOR STRUCTURE JOBS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S RECALL BUDGET- WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THE PROPOSED A
STRATEGY ON EXPENDITURE CAP AND
TRADE FUNDS. FOR MARKET
TRANSFORMATION IN THE TRACK NEW
PRIVATE CAPITAL WHILE CLOSING
THE SIGNIFICANT GAP WE SUPPORT-
DO YOUR FUNDS AS WELL FOR
EQUITABLE CLEAN MOBILITY
OPTIONS AND ACCELERATING THE
TURNOVER OF THE MOST POLLUTING
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY FLEETS.
EVERY RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
LEGISLATURE FROM QUICKLY- TO
TAKE ACTION TO ADOPT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL- RESERVE
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND ALSO
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST OF THE
LEGISLATURE SUPPORT- CONSISTENT
SOURCE OF INDEPENDENT DOLLARS-
IN THE LIGHT DUTY AND- FOR LOW
INCOME AND MODERATE INCOME
FAMILIES AS WELL. FOR ALL THESE
REASONS WE SUPPORT QUICK ACTION
AND WE THANK. THE LEGISLATORS.
OKAY ATTENTION TODAY THANK YOU
FIVE ON THE ISSUES SURROUNDING.
THANK YOU ANDREW WE APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS NEXT COME PLEASE.
NEXT WE'RE GOING TO NUMBERS
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THE
SHUFFLING COVER HERE FROM YOUR
CEMEX MORE ON BEHALF OF THE
ALLIANCE AUTOMOTIVEINNOVATION
WE WOULD HAVE LOVED TO HAVE
BEEN A PARTICIPANT ON THE PANEL
TODAYBUT NEVERTHELESS HE
APPRECIATED TODAY'S DISCUSSION
ON THE ADMINISTRATION. THERE
ARE MISSION CRITICAL PROPOSAL
BUT REGRETFULLY EXPRESSED OUR
HOLD RECOMMENDED POSITION ON
TWO IMPORTANT PROPOSAL
CONTAINED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL NUMBER ONE WE
OPPOSE LIMITATION OF FUNDING
FOR THE CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE
PROGRAM AND BELIEVED FUNDING
FOR THAT PROGRAM SHOULD BE
RESTORED THE TRADITIONAL LEVEL
OF AT LEAST TWO HUNDRED
MILLION. IN Q. WE OPPOSE THE
EXTENSION AT THE END OF THE
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM
WITHOUT STATUTORY AUTHORITY
CHANGES THAT ENSURE MY DUTY
REVEALING INFRASTRUCTURE
CONTINUE TO RECEIVE AMPLE
FUNDING. AT TWENTY TWENTY
BETTER SALES ACCOUNTED 48% OF
NEW VEHICLE SALES IN THE STATE
THE GAP BETWEEN WHERE WE ARE
TODAY AND WHAT WE WANT TO BE IN
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE MILLION
MARCH. ST MARKETING TO MAKE
PROGRESS IN THE CLINTON OF DAD
DURING THE INTERIM PERIOD BY
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AUTOMAKERS
WILL HAVE INVESTED TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY BILLION AND INDUSTRY
FUNDING FOR YOU GUYS AND. GET
COLLECTED. OKAY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- NOT JUST REMIND EVERYONE
HAVE ONE FOR EACH- PERCENT.
THANK YOU FOR THOSE NEXT
COMMENT PLAY. THE NEXT WILL BE
NUMBERED SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
IT COULD HAVE BEEN A MANAGER
MEMBERS BY NAME IS BUILDABLE
AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN BUSINESS
COUNCIL REPRESENTING OVER
HUNDRED TWENTY COMPANIES THE
DISTANCE OF HYDROGEN AND FUEL
CELL TECHNOLOGY. WITH COUNCIL
AGREE CONCERNED BY THE LACK OF
BALANCE IN THE STATE'S APPROACH
TO CLEAN TRANSPORTATION THIS
BUDGET PROPOSAL AMONG THE-
POLICY MAKERS THAT ACTED WITH A
HEAVY BY ESCORTING BATTERY
ELECTRIC VEHICLES BUT EXPANSION
PROGRAMS TO POLITICAL CHARGING.
AT THE EXPENSE OF EXCLUSION OF
ZERO EMISSION FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND HYDROGEN
FUEL CENTERS. IN DOING SO
POLICY MAKERS HAVE MADE A
CHOICE ALL CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
CHOICE THAT MIGHT NOT SUIT
EVERYONE'S LIFESTYLE INCOME
LEVEL PERSONAL NEEDS FOR
COMMERCIAL INTERESTS.
CONTINUATION OF THE CURRENT BY
IT SEEMS TO MISS A SINGLE
CHOICE. FOR THE POLICY MAKERS
REALIZE IT OR NOT THEY HAVE
LIMITED SEVEN CHOICES FOR THOSE
THAT DO NOT HAVE THE ABILITY TO
ADAPT. FOR EXAMPLE THOSE WHO
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO GARAGE
PARKING BILLS TO REQUIRE LONGER
RANGE REQUIRE A LARGER VEHICLE
AND OR PREFER THE CONVENIENCE.
OF FASTER REFUELING TIMES. I
ALSO LIKE TO SEE AT EMPHASIS ON
THE- BE STAFF REGION INTEREST.
CONSUMERS WANT MORE THAN ONE.
AND STARKEY THIS RARE COMMENT
INSPECTION RECORDS THE- THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. NEXT WILL BE
NUMBERS ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RYAN
WHILE SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA TRANSIT
DISTRICT REPEATS YOU TRANSIT.
IS THE TRANSIT IS CALIFORNIA'S
LARGEST BUSTLING TRANSIT
AGENCIES HAVE BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT OF ZERO EMISSION TO
POSTPONEMENTS NATIONWIDE SINCE
TWO. YEAR TWO THOUSAND WE ALSO
SERVE- CHEER WHITE HOUSE YOU
DISTRICT. DURING HAVE TWENTY
SIX ZERO. BOSSES AND- WITH
ANOTHER FORTY THREE ON THE WAY
IN OUR BUILDING TO UPHOLD
TRANSITION BY TWENTY FORTY- WE
KNOW THAT WORK BUT YOU'RE NOT
GOING ON ADMINISTRATIONS ON
PROPOSAL TODAY. CENTRAL TO OUR
ABILITY TO MEET OUR ZERO
EMISSION BUS DEPLOYMENT
TARGETS. IS CONTINUED ACCESS TO
FUNDING THEREFORE WE SUPPORT
THE ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN YOUR
MISSION VEHICLES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE SPLIT CONSIDER
THE DISINVESTMENT WE URGE YOU
TO CREATE- EIGHT MILLION MARK
SET ASIDE- FOR TRANSIT AGENCIES
WITHIN THE THREE HUNDRED
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR OUTLINED
FOR ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS BUSES
AND OFF ROAD FREIGHT- SERVICE
I'M WOULD GUARANTEE TRANSIT
AGENCIES HAVE ACCESS TO THE-
FUNDING NECESSARY TO DEPLOY AT
LEAST. THANK YOU. FOR HUNDRED
NEW ZERO EMISSION BUSES. THE
NEXT PLEASE. THE NEXT BE NUMBER
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS CAITLIN
JOHNSON WITH POLITICAL SOLUTION
ON BEHALF OF HONDA URGING YOUR
SUPPORT FOR INCLUSION AT THE B.
R. P. FUNDING IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. A NEXT
WILL BE NUMBER FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES I JUST
WANTED TO REINFORCE THAT AS
MANY OF THE PANELISTS IN THE
REPORT SAYS WERE FAILING TO
MEET OUR GOALS AND REALLY
NEEDING TO RECOGNIZE TO THEIR
MACHINE TECHNOLOGY MEANS.
THERE'S A AS A BACKGROUND
PAPER- FAILED TO INCLUDE
ANYTHING IN HYDROGEN IN THE
CURRENT STATUS OF THE GOAL
SECTION THERE'S NO WHERE TO GO
WITH. THOSE IF WE LOOK AT THIS
THAT MARKET STARTING TO MOVE TO
MARKET BASED MECHANISMS
INCLUDING A CAR REPORT ON THIS
BEING A SELF SUSTAINING MARKET
WITHIN A DECADE WHICH WOULD BE
THE FIRST. MARKET IN THE WORLD
TO DO THIS WITH CONTINUED
SUPPORT SO WITH THAT I JUST
LIKE TO SAY WE NEED TO AIM FOR
SUCCESS IN IN BOTH THE COUNTY.
PROCEED AND CONTINUE.
CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP ACROSS.
THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT. THE
NEXT BE NUMBER TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI JERRY MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME MY NAME IS
SHANE STEPHENS I'M ONE OF THE
FOUNDERS OF FIRST ELEMENT FUEL
WE ARE A COMPANY FOUNDED IN
CALIFORNIA AND HEADQUARTERED IN
CALIFORNIA IN ORDER TO BUILD
OUT THE RETAIL NETWORK OF
HYDROGEN STATIONS THAT IS OUR
SOLE FOCUS. FOR MISSION
ORIENTED WE WANT TO ENABLE THE
ADOPTION OF FUEL CELL VEHICLES
BECAUSE WE THINK HYDROGEN HAS A
HUGE ROLE TO PLAY. AND REDUCING
THE IMPACT OF DRIVING ON OUR
PLANET I WANT TO SAY THAT I
THINK SENDING A STRONG SIGNAL
AND HYDROGEN RIGHT NOW. IS A
GREAT TIME TO DO IT FOR
CALIFORNIA WE SEE PRIVATE
SECTOR INVESTMENT SNOWBALLING-
OUR COMPANY CAN'T HIRE ENOUGH
HERE IN THE STATE AND FURTHER
MORE WERE OUTGROWING THE
CURRENT SUPPLY OF EXISTING
HYDROGEN AND NEW HYDROGEN WILL
NEED TO BE DEVELOPED. SO
THERE'S A REAL OPPORTUNITY FOR
CALIFORNIA SMART POLICY TO
CAPTURE THOSE INVESTMENTS AND
ENSURE THAT THEY COME INTO THE
STATE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CASH MY NAME
IS THE PUBLISHER THE IDEA BEING
THAT DUBLIN- ANDAI DERIVED THE
HYDROGEN COP THANK YOU OR
GIVING ME THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE A PUBLIC COMMENT- THAT
EAGLE WHYY- CHU- HI THERE GUYS
OUT THAT YOU TO PROVIDE ME TOO
GAUDY- PRETTY MUCH THE SAME
KIND OF A GOOD- COULD YOU SPEAK
FREEDOM WITH THE OCT ASSERTING
CAUGHT BETWEEN- ROOM WITH
WRITING RANGE RIGIDITY FIVE I
CHARGING TIME- SO I WOULD TO
SUPPORT- WATERGATE HOT OVER THE
CREAM. PROGRAM HYDROGEN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT COMMENT
PLEASE. NEXT WE'LL GO TO NUMBER
SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM MEMBERS STILL
FOR ON THE OF FAIRLY KEY- IN
HE'S ONE OF THE PRODUCERS OF
HYDROGEN AND WE ARE IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF RE
AUTHORIZING THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM AND MORE
SPECIFICALLY. SEEN INCREASES
FUNDING DEDICATED TO FIVE
HUNDRED- UP TO FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION FOR HYDROGEN PER
ADDITIONAL LIGHT DUTY HEAVY
DUTY IN TRANSITIONING STATIONS
AND AS YOU'VE HEARD YOU KNOW
HIDING OFFERS THE STATE A HUGE
OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY
ACCELERATE ITS EFFORTS ON
ACHIEVING A REQUIREMENT VEHICLE
GOALS- PLEASE LOOK TO AIRLIE
KEEN AS A LEADING PRODUCER TO
BE A PARTNER WITH YOU. IN THIS
AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. NEXT BE NUMBERS.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS COURTNEY CHEN ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES METRO THE
BUSIEST TRANSIT AGENCY IN THE
STATE SERVING OVER TEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS IN L. A. COUNTY WE
SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION IS REQUIRED FOR
DEDICATED AGE HAT FUNDING FOR
TRANSIT BUSES PUBLIC TRANSIT
AGENCIES ARE SHOULDERING A
HEAVY FINANCIAL BURDEN TO
CONVERT ITS FLEET. TO ELECTRIC
AND WE NEED THE STATE TO
CONTINUE PROVIDE TO PROVIDE
FUNDING REGULATORY RELIEF AND
INCENTIVES TO OURPUBLIC
TRANSIT AGENCIES STATEWIDE WE
THANK THE DATE FOR THE CENTER
PROGRAMS LIKE H. BETH BUT WE
STILL HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO THE
COST OF ONE ELECTRIC BUSES
NEARLY ONE MILLION DOLLARS AND
THE VOUCHERS PROVIDE ABOUT. A
HUNDRED THOUSAND TOWARDS THOSE
COSTS WERE COMPETING WITH HEAVY
DUTY DIESEL TRUCK TO PROVIDE
CLEAN PUBLIC TRANSIT TO PEOPLE
WHO NEED IT MOST BACK QUIET
SATISFIED FOR TRANSIT BUSES AND
IMPORTANT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTNERING WITH YOU TO FIND
LONG TERM FUNDING SOLUTION TO
MEET THIS CHALLENGE AND
CONTINUE PROVIDING CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION ALTERNATIVES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. NEXT WILL TO
NUMBER THIRTY. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M CONTESTING FROM BALLARD
POWER SYSTEMS WE'VE BEEN
DEVELOPING AND DEPLOYING ZERO
EMISSION HYDROGEN FUEL CELL
BUSES ON CALIFORNIA ROADS FOR
OVER TWO DECADES IN OUR EFFORT
EFFORT TO BENEFIT GREATLY FROM
FUNDING ADMINISTERED BY THE
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS
OF CALIFORNIA IS ABOUT TO NOW
CONSTITUTE A QUARTER TO A HALF
OF THE PLAN THAT PURCHASES IN
CALIFORNIA. IN LARGE PART IN
THESE PROGRAMS ARE DIFFICULT TO
ASSESS PAID BACK FOR MARKET
DEVELOPMENT GROWTH CLEAR THAT
THIS SHIPMENT CAN ONLY BE DONE
BY THIS FUNDING. THE
LEGISLATURE IS RIGHT TO SEEK A
STRONGER VOICE MAPPING OUT AND
DIRECTING HOW THESE
TECHNOLOGIES CAN BE INTEGRATED
INTO A MORE BALANCED
COMPREHENSIVE IN CONTROL PLAN
ENSURES ECONOMIC GROWTH.
MATURATION OF HYDROGEN TO
ACOSTA AFFECTED YOUR MISSION
MEANS OF ENERGY TRANSMISSION
WITHOUT THE MISSION THE POP
APPEAL COURT TAXING ARE
CRITICALLY OVERBURDENED GRANT
FURTHER LEVERAGES THE STATE
INVESTMENT TO CREATE A
COMPETITIVE COMMERCIAL ENERGY
SYSTEM IN AREAS THAT CAN ONLY
BE SERVED BY REGULATED
MONOPOLIES IN THE PAST. THE
COMPANY COMPETITION CREATE A
POWERFUL COMPETITIVE PRICE WARS
AND AFTER ON UTILITIES FURTHER
IMPROVING THEIR ECONOMIC
EFFICIENCY SUPPORTING
COMMERCIAL HYDROGEN FOR
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION
WILL LOWER THE BURDEN ON
ELECTRICITY RATEPAYERS THE
PAPER INTRODUCTION FOR YOUR
CONTENT. REMOTE NEXT COMMENT.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO KNOW FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD HI IS
ROLL RENAULT- I'VE BEEN DRIVING
A HYDROGEN FUEL CELL CAR SINCE
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN BEFORE
THAT I ROVE ELECTRIC BATTERY
ELECTRIC CARS FOR SEVERAL
YEARS. IF YOU'LL- STATIONS ARE
EXPENSIVE- BUT ONCE ONE IS
BUILT IT CONSERVE HUNDREDS IF
NOT THOUSANDS OF VEHICLES AND
THAT'S BECAUSE EACH VEHICLE WE
NEED TO BE THERE FOR A FEW
MINUTES TO REFUEL AND IT ONLY
NEEDS TO COME BACK EVERY THREE
TO FOUR HUNDRED MILES. SO THAT
AN INITIAL INVESTMENT IN
FUELING STATIONS IS IT IS GOING
TO HAVE GREAT PAY BACK AND I
WOULD ENCOURAGE- THE INCREASE.
IN FUNDING FOR HYDROGEN
INFRASTRUCTURE- TEMPLE- BECAUSE
I BELIEVE THAT FOR THE STATE'S
GOING TO GET THE MOST BANG FOR
ITS BUCK IN TERMS OF GETTING
PEOPLE TO ADOPT- ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES- LONG RANGE. RAPID
REFUELING NO NEED FOR HOME
INFRASTRUCTURE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR MODERATOR
WOULD YOU LET US KNOW HOW MANY
MORE- PEOPLE ARE IN THE QUEUE
TO COMMENT. AT THIS TIME IT
LOOKS LIKE ABOUT FIVE OR IN THE
QUEUE STILL OKAY GREAT THANK
YOU NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. WE'LL
NEXT GO TO NUMBER FORTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS THOMAS
WALKING THE FORD MOTOR COMPANY-
I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE- ARE A
LINE OUR COMMENTS WITH THE
ALLIANCE BUT ALSO YOU KNOW FORD
MOTOR COMPANY AGREES THAT THIS
IS A TEAM SPORT. YOU KNOW FORD
IS INVESTING TWENTY TWO BILLION
DOLLARS GLOBALLY TO BRING OUR
OTHER TWO BUCKS FOR CATION TO
OUR VEHICLES AND UNFORTUNATE
THAT. E. R. P. WAS OF THAT WE
THINK IS REALLY HELPFUL TO
OFFSET THE COSTS FOR CONSUMERS.
ZERO ZERO ABOUT THE SAME TIME
WE ARE IN MAKING AN INVESTMENT
IN BRINGING VEHICLES TO MARKET.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ON CREATING
AN OVER YOU KNOW ON OVERARCHING
COMPREHENSIVE. STRATEGY ON ON
HOW TO APPROACH THIS- TO THOSE
THAT. YOU KNOW ARE INTERESTED
THERE WAS OVER THIRTY BILLS
INTRODUCED ON THEM. AND SO IT
IS THERE IN THE NEED TO KIND OF
STREAMLINED THE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE ALL ROWING IN THE
SAME DIRECTION. THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT. THANK YOU THOMAS NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. NEXT IS NUMBER
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR THAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME TO
TALKING ABOUT THE HOBBY AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE-
NATIONAL ALLIANCE ALSO WISH
THAT WOULD FOCUS ON
ACCELERATING. YOUR PHONE
CHARGING TECHNOLOGIES ON THE
COMMERCIAL AND INDUSTRIAL
FACTORS WE SUPPORT THE DETAILS
ARE CRAP BY THE HYGIENIST
STAKEHOLDERS OR CRAFTING
TECHNOLOGY PARITY STEP ON BOTH
THEIR OWN MISSION TECHNOLOGY I
WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT SHE.
WISHES THAT ARE BARELY GETS.
WHEN I WHICH IS THE REGIONAL
ARE. WE CAN WORK WITH A WIDE
STATE DOT- CALIFORNIA ZERO
EMISSION PAUL. WE SEE THAT WITH
THE AGENCIES JOB OTHER STATES
AGENCIES SPEND WHAT SEX GOAL
LINE AND LEVERAGE PUBLIC BY.
SALARY CALL VARY BETWEEN INCOME
THERE ARE TECHNO- DOES FIFTY
DRAIN TRUCKS TO CHANGE I WAS
THE GRANT IN THE EXAMPLE OR
WHATEVER NUMBER WITH SHE
COUNTRY. AND I WAS SURE TO. TWO
DIFFERENT STATE. WHY WHY TO OUR
MISSION RECORD ARCH CAPTURING
IT WOULD MAKE OUR DOLLARS GO
FURTHER MY SECOND
RECOMMENDATION. IN ORDER FOR
EACH HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE SIMPLE
MAJORITY AFTER PROP TWENTY SIX
IF YOU HAPPEN TO BE THE NOT
TAXES IN ORDER TO BE CONSIDERED
A FEAT ACHIEVED. ARE INCLUDED
WHERE SUPPOSED TO BE SPENT ON
VEHICLE THAT CAME FROM FOR
EXAMPLE OVER. SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS. EIGHT FIVE EIGHT. NEXT
PLEASE. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
NUMBERS EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NEW CHAIRS IN MEMBERS OF THE AT
CALIFORNIA FIGHTERS SPEAKING ON
THE OF THE CENTRE THE THING
ENERGY PURCHASE ON IT THANK YOU
HOLDING THE CROSS COMMITTEE TO
DIVE IN. WHAT IS THE BILL
IMPORTANT IN BUDGET AREA I WANT
TO THANK. ALL YOUR ABOUT. THE
WORD THAT EQUITY IN ALL OF OUR
CLEAN VEHICLE PROGRAM AT THE
PROGRAM ADMINISTRATOR FOR C. B.
R. P. EQUITY IS A VITAL
COMPONENT. LEVERAGING A WHOLE
BIG WHITE OF THE- TO REACH.
THOSE HARD TO REACH ME. AND GET
THEM INTO THE- WE ALSO WANTED
TO ECHO CHAIR LIKE HEALTHY
POINT ON THE BOARD THE MATURING
THAT MIDDLE CLASS CALIFORNIANS
CAN ALL AFFORD TO DO THAT. THE
SPECIALLY IMPORTANT THE USED
CAR MARKET BECAUSE IF WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE A ROBUST USED CAR
MARKET NEED TO PROMOTE AND
ACCELERATE EIGHT. EIGHT SOLID
AND ROBOT NEW CAR MARKET AS
WELL. AND FINALLY. WE WANT TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE
GOVERNOR TO PRO PROPOSAL TO
EXTEND NUMEROUS YOUR MISSION
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY PROGRAM. IN ONE GO
DOLLARS. AND YOU IT JUST REALLY
IMPORTANT WE WROTE OF RODE BOTH
OR- THE- ABOUT ON THE VEHICLE
AND INFRASTRUCTURE TO ENSURE
THAT. WE CAN FOCUS ON I THINK
THE- LUCIEN. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
AXOLOTL LINE SIXTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING AARON
RODRIGUEZ FOR THE UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS ECS
STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE PROPOSED
THREE AUTHORIZATION EXTENSION
ONE BILLION DOLLARS SECURITY
STATION UP TO THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM AND THE
PROGRAM ITSELF AND THAT THE
PRODUCT NINE HUNDRED MILLION
EACH YEAR TOWARDS RESEARCH
DEVELOPMENT AND DEPLOYMENT OF
CLEAN VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE
AND ALTERNATIVE FUEL
TECHNOLOGIES ONE THREE EITHER
IF WE BELIEVE THE PROGRAM WILL
BE EVEN MORE POWERFUL AND
CONTINUE ATTRACTING INVESTMENT
THE DOCTOR CALIFORNIA. AND HELP
ENSURE THE STATE CONDITIONS THE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY AIR QUALITY
AND CLIMATE GOALS AND THAT WE
DON'T THE ECHO MANY OF THE
COMMENTS MADE BY COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR AND I JOIN THE CHARGE
AHEAD AFTER DENTURE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION FUTURE OF
ALCOHOL. REPORT RECOMMENDATIONS
TO CODIFY EQUITY REQUIREMENTS I
DON'T THINK CREATING THE
GOVERNOR COSTS FOR A HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION FOR
TRANSPORTATION EQUITY PROJECT
TWO HUNDRED MILLION AND
APPROVED THE GOVERNOR'S REQUEST
FOR THREE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
PER COOK CLEAN TRUCKS BUSES AND
OFFERED TO QUIT WHAT YOU
BELIEVE THE LEGISLATURE MUST
TAKE EARLY ACTION ON TO YOUR US
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. MACKSVILLE
TIMELINE. ONE PLEASE CLASS. HI
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES BECAUSE YES
WE CAN GREAT- MY IS TODD
CAMPBELL WITH CLEANING IN OUR-
THE OF THE CAN NATIONAL SUIT. I
JOIN EXPRESS- CAN. OVER THE
OVERLY FOCUSED- YOU KNOW FOCUS
ON ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES.
GIVEN THE HUGE TASK THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSE REDUCE BOTH-
AIR QUALITY AND CLIMATE AND THE
CHIEF CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS. I
THINK THE FACT THAT- WE HAVE-
VERY SECTORS LIKE TRANSIT AND
OTHER REFUSE- SECTORS YOU'RE
COMPETING FOR FUNDS IT'S A
MONSTER OF THE FACT THAT WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH FUNDS TO DO
AN IMMEDIATE TRANSITION. YES
THE GOAL SHOULD BE ULTIMATELY
ZERO BUT WE ALSO NEED TO THINK
ABOUT HOW WE CAN WALK AND CHEW
GUM AT THE SAME TIME AND BE
ABLE TO REDUCE EMISSIONS IN THE
NEAR TO MID TERM. AND NOT LOOK
TO SEE TWENTY FORTY FIVE- SO I
WOULD ENCOURAGE- THE SENATE AND
THIS COMMITTEE- TO THINK ABOUT-
CREATIVE WAYS TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS NOT JUST LONG TERM
MISSIONS BUT NEAR TERM MISSIONS
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. CONNECT
LEVEL TIMELINE SEVENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE SEVENTY
FOUR CAN YOU HEAR ME M. I. NGT.
EXCELLENT HI MY NAME IS ANDREA
HAD STRUM AND LAST SEPTEMBER
CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR GAVIN
NEWSOM ISSUED AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER REQUIRING SALES OF ALL
NEW PASSENGER VEHICLES TO BE
ZERO EMISSION BY TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE. AND ADDITIONAL MEASURES
TO ELIMINATE HARMFUL EMISSIONS
FROM THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR
ACCORDING TO CALIFORNIA GLOBAL
HOWEVER NOT ONE NEWS REPORT
ABOUT THIS BIG BOLD
ANNOUNCEMENT ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
GOVERNOR NEWSOM DOES NOT HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO MAKE LAWS. AND
HE DID NOT PROVOKE EMERGENCY
POWERS FOR HIS LATEST EXECUTIVE
ORDER CONTRARY TO THE
SERVICES ACT DOES NOT AND COULD
NOT INAUGURATE AN AUTOCRACYIN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
REFLECTS A MEMORIAL
MISAPPREHENSION OF CABIN
NEWSOM'S ALONG THE FORTY. GAVIN
NEWSOM ORDER ALLOWS THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
TO DEVELOP NEW PASSENGER
VEHICLE AND TRUCK REGULATIONS
REQUIRING INCREASING VOLUMES OF
NEW ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE SOLD
AS WELL AS DEVELOPING NEW
REGULATIONS AFFECTING MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES. AND TO
DEVELOP STRATEGY FOR YOUR
COMMENT LOCAL. ENTITIES NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. NEXT TO A LOT
TIMELINE SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING RECORD BACK
AND ON HAPPY THE CALIFORNIA
ADVANCED BIOFUEL CLIENTS. THAT
THE AGENT BERMAN IT WILL BE
BUILT BY BILL WILEY BEFORE ALL
LOW CARBON ALTERNATIVES IN THE
SHIFTING AWAY FROM PETROLEUM
DIESEL I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
ARE KILLED OR DROP IN FIELD
PLACEMENTS PETROLEUM DIESEL
WITHOUT ENGINE TURN OVER OR
EXPENSIVE INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT A COUPLE YEARS AGO
WE LAID OUT A WHITE PAPER ONLY
FOR CALIFORNIATO BE PATROLLING
THREE BY TWENTY THIRTY WITH A
BLEND OF OUR RENEWABLE FUEL.
BACKLOGS FOR CATION OF THE
HEAVY DUTY SECTOR IS DECADES
AWAY. WELL BODIES ON RENEWABLE
PEOPLE ARE AVAILABLE TODAY-
THANK YOU FOR THAT HEARING AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU TO HELP THE CALIFORNIA
COURT THAT YOU ARE
ENVIRONMENTAL. THANK. YOU VERY
MUCH AND- THAT MADAME MODERATOR
IS HOW MANY MORE- IN THE QUEUE
DO WE HAVE PLEASE. AT THIS TIME
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE LEFT IN
QUEUE. OKAY GREAT THANK YOU.
WELL HAVING HEARD ALL PUBLIC
TESTIMONY MEMBERS IF THERE ARE
NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS I JUST WANT TO THANK
ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED. IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IF YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS WE SURELY
WELCOME THEM IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE. YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
VERY IMPORTANT TO US WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS I WANT
TO THANK. CO CHAIR SENATOR WITH
HOUSEKEEPER ALL HIS GREAT WORDS
AND COMMENTS IN ALL OF OUR
MEMBERS HERE TODAY ON THIS
FRIDAY NIGHT THANK YOU BUT-
EVERYBODY AND WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA WE ARE DURING THANK
YOU.